e
good morning everyone please take your
seats it's time to get our activity
started for today science technology and
energy for Monday February
10th
20125 welcome to
everybody we have a full day of activity
and before we get started I'll ask
everyone to rise and join representative
Allegiance i al to the flag of the
United States of America the stands
Nation
okay so thank you everybody we're going
to have three public hearings this
morning the first one is a
continuation of a public hearing that we
recessed last week that's House Bill 567
FN relative to the elimination of useful
classes we'll then move to a public
hearing on House Bill 674 FN relative to
nonwire Alternatives time of you tar
time of use tariffs and multi-year rate
settings and then wrap up the morning
activity with a public hearing on
establishing a
Statewide online energy data
platform at 1:00 this afternoon we will
have an executive SE excession session
on five bills and then after the
executive session we will have public
hearings on three additional bills so
it's a full and busy day here
today so I'm going to now open the
reopen the public hearing on House Bill
FN and because we
recessed this public hearing last year
or last week rather we have 11 pink
cards
from last week so we're going to go
through those first I have a bunch of
pink cards that were submitted this
morning I suspect some of them are dupes
but we'll go through what we have here
first and then we will move on look at
the dupes and see if there's the
duplicates and see if there's
any need to call up anybody
else so that is a nice refresher for
everybody if you want want to testify on
a bill you must submit a pink card so do
so as soon as possible we have another
new innovation here this morning and
that is on the right hand side of the
table that we use for people to testify
before the committee there is now a
placard I suppose the people in the back
of the room can't see it but we can see
it and people looking uh watching from
home will be able to see it on the
camera it says now hearing and then it
lists the name of the bill HB 567 FN
there's a stack of papers on the edge of
that table that has the numbers of all
the bills that we be hearing today and
so I'm going to ask for a volunteer from
the committee to change that
plard uh representative Matson has
volunteered to do that Duty so once we
finish one public hearing and move to
the next public hearing I'll ask you if
you could change that placard please so
with that now we'll continue this public
hearing and I'm going to call First on
representative Harrington to sort of
reintroduce the bill and at least uh
refresh our memory about its contents so
up Mr thank you Mr chairman um I look at
this this useful thermal energy as one
of the worst examples of government that
we have it is just favoritism for a
small group who decided rather than
spend their time time and effort selling
their product based on its merits they
decided to come to conquer and spend
their time and effort on lobbying to get
a law passed so they could be subsidized
useful thermal energy has absolutely
nothing to do with electricity there's
nobody out there that's saying boy I
have electric baseboard heating and I'm
going to put in a wood chip boiler so I
can get useful thermal energy no they're
converting from maybe natural gas or oil
natural gas would would be but maybe a
95% efficiency if it's a condensing more
natural gas furnace to a wood chip
boiler which is a lot lower efficiency
but the fact is it's got nothing to do
with electricity and why we bury this in
the electric rates is still I find it
amazing if you were to PLL let's say
10,000 people in New Hampshire and ask
them do you pay higher electric rates so
wood chip manufacturers can get a
subsidy from your electric bill I bet
you
99,999 would say I don't know what
you're talking about why should I pay
higher electric bills to subsidize would
ship factories or why should I subsidize
I know there's a particular County that
has this so I would be open for some
grandfather uh Amendment because I'm
realistic and realize people aren't
going to vote against their own uh
what's good for their for their County
but the fact remains is that the
electric payers in my towns should not
be paying higher electric rates so that
some County pays lower uh because they
use wood chip they took advantage of the
situation I can understand why they did
that but that that's not my big problem
my big problem was the bill itself like
I said this is government and its worth
secret uh lobbying to get a subsidy
where nobody even knows it's being done
again ask your Co ask go around when you
you get home ask your constituents how
many of them realize they're paying a
higher electric bill and as soon as say
well it's only you know 50 cents or a
dollar or whatever it is but you know we
have a 50 cents here and 50 cents there
and a dollar there and a dollar there
and pretty soon you're talking real
money to kind of paraphrase ever durksen
um and that's the problem with this it's
got nothing to do with electricity uh if
you want to subsidize wood chips and
burning of wood chips then step up to
the plate and say I will pay I will
sponsor a tax on something else so that
we can subsidize wood chips but you
won't do that because oh no taxes are
bad so we hide it in the electric bill
like I say this is an example of
government at its worse and there's
nothing more to be said than
that any questions if there are some
okay questions for representative
Harrington representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman thank you Mr Harrington
for taking my question um we heard it's
representative Harington representative
Harrington yes and you're still Mis as
well but
representative
um so we heard quite a bit of testimony
from folks who would be affected if we
passed uh this bill
and I've heard you make the this
argument that you've made this morning
in the past about the fact that it's not
electric energy but the can you tell us
what what R EC stands
for the Rex it's renewable energy
credits right so it it does qualify as
energy correct it it doesn't say
renewable electric credits I'm not
debating about what it qualifies what
it's whether it's energy or not my
question is what does it have to do with
electric rates it would be the same
thing as if you said okay let's put a
hidden fee on I don't know U your water
bill because we're going to subsidize
people who put up solar panels nothing
to do with solar panels nothing to do
with hiding it in your water bill but
that's what we're doing here with
electric rates we're hiding it in here
because we don't want to step up to the
plate and say I think this is worthy and
I'll pass a tax on it we so again go
back ask your constituents make make a
thousand phone calls you will not get a
single person unless they're actually
getting subsidy that will say I'm paying
higher electric rates and I'm glad to do
it so subsidize W ship people followup
follow
up um I I hear what you're saying um so
the renewable energy credit program
though is part of the state's overall
approach to the renewable portfolio
standards which Renewables include all
of the local sustainable energy that is
noncarbon emitting um and so
so you we're still trying to pull out of
the renewable portfolio standard just
you know one section of that standard
which was identified as beneficial for
the state which was why it was included
in the first place because it's a
resource that we have here and uh and
industries and jobs and all that go
along with it right that's what we keep
hearing testimony on is that well I
disagree with you on two on two points
first it wasn't in the original
renewable portfolio standard it was
added some years
after a lot of lobbying by one
particular group so it wasn't in the
original bill it was an afterthought
they could sneak it in and uh get away
with charging people higher electric
rates and no one would know about it
second you mentioned carbon emitting
well obviously when you burn wood what
happens you give off carbon dioxide you
give up a lot of carbon dioxide in fact
if it wasn't for the lobbying of the
wood people in New Hampshire it probably
wouldn't be considered renewable as in
Massachusetts I think you have to have a
thermal efficiency of uh 40% to qualify
for a half a wreck and I think it's 50%
to qualify for a full wreck which
obviously no wood burning plant makes so
uh it's it's that that assumption that
you're saying that it's not uh emitting
carbon is wrong it does emit carbon
dioxide when you burn wood you give off
carbon
dioxide may may I clarify a point go
ahead thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
Harrington it was my understanding that
the Department of Environmental Services
actually has to qualif ify plants um
that are you know receiving thermal
wrecks in terms of their emissions in
order for them to qualify for renewable
energy credits in terms of what they're
emitting is that is that accurate to
your understanding there are standards
but one of them is not carbon dioxide
because no nothing none of them would
meet that because when you burn wood you
give off carbon dioxide I mean you can't
it's it's an absolute byproduct you have
an option don't burn wood or give off
carbon dioxide one or the
other further
questions representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Harrington uh just a
couple of things but uh conf you you're
saying trees give off carbon dioxide but
in growing trees consume carbon dioxide
and you wouldn't have trees if they
didn't consume carbon dioxide so it
seemed to me
that trees would be or burning wood
would be part of a renewable cycle as
long as you didn't burn up all your wood
and you did in a sustainable fashion so
I'm having trouble with the notion that
it's bad to burn trees and almost
equally as bad as burning fossil fuels
which are not renewable as far as I know
are you saying so so it's remember we're
not here to debate we're here to ask
questions so it's clear that it was
intended here as a place to identify and
incen incentives for energy whether it's
electricity or thermal energy uh doing
that in the state with State resources
as opposed to burning fossil fuels are
you saying you would rather get rid of
this incentive for a native capability
to generate electricity and you would
rather burn fossil
fuels well first of all your question is
sort of uh doesn't make a lot of sense
let me put it that way to start with if
you're looking at options here you I
have a facility I can put in a
condensing natural gas fired uh furnace
that's going to be 95% efficient I don't
even have to have a chimney I can use a
plastic pipe because the waste heat is
so little or I can put in a wood chip
which is probably somewhere in the 25%
efficient range and as far as this
concept of with Native energy well we
don't have native cars should we have a
subsidy so we start building cars in New
Hampshire um I know I don't think we
build any refrigerators in New Hampshire
so we this this concept of that we're
getting it from other parts of the
country is somehow bad because we export
a awful lot of products to the rest of
the country do we want them to shut us
off and say oh no no all of our
high-tech manufacturing that we do here
should be made in Michigan rather than
us selling them to people in Michigan so
it we can get native and they do the
same thing to us all that's going to do
is drive the price of everything
Skyrocket uh this this concept that
we're somehow not one country but
individual states that have to uh look
at how we do things it's that's a f i
mean it just doesn't make any sense so
follow okay no no followup this is
degenerating into a debate rather than a
question and answer session
representative rhos do you have a
question go ahead
please thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Harrington do you
actually know
the technical
specifications um of any of these
high-tech wood pellet boilers in terms
of combustion efficiency I mean you're
citing some figures and it seems like
you're just pulling them out of the air
do you actually know the technical
specifications of of the heat conversion
efficiency I I don't have an exact
number for that no okay thank you any
further questions seeing none we'll next
call on Morton Bailey of the lime green
Heat
of lime green heat whatever that
is Morton
available okay well next here
okay Mr Christensen has submitted
written
testifying next is Brook Brooks Peterson
energy I'm sorry I didn't
there okay next up is
Jim Van
okay how about Jason stuck I know he's
here from the New Hampshire Timber land
Owners
Association and remember we don't need a
discussion of the wood industry we just
okay good good morning um for the record
Jason stock executive director of the
New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and uh I appreciate the
opportunity to come and testify uh in
opposition to to this bill today to
House Bill
567 last week um you got kind of a a
primer on the forest products industry
and kind of how low-grade wood markets
interact with the ability to manage
Timberland in the state but also how
they dovetail with all the sectors
within the state's Forest products
industry including solidwood which would
which includes Lumber um as well um
House Bill 567 does more than just
modify the thermal the thermal wreck
portion of class one um and I don't want
that to be lost uh in this discussion it
completely eliminates class three which
are the existing biomass plants um the
the existing biomass plants which do
produce electricity so this is more than
just thermal recks this is also an
electricity generation bill as well um
and I wanted to just make sure that's on
the record and that you folks um just to
kind of put a put a point on that we
thermal recks but also the existing
biomass plants both contribute to the
state's Forest products industry um and
and our our economy and one of the
pieces so you heard last week about
class three kind of the the the
industrial or I'll say uh commercial
electricity generation to bring the
focus to the thermal piece the the
thermal piece the thermal wrecks are an
important component of a growing and
emerging portion of our industry you
heard last week from Two testifiers
durgen and croll
lumber and uh Britain Lumber two
Sawmills that are installing wood
boilers to generate heat and also
electricity and they are also
participating in the thermal wck program
this program is working it is spurring
innovation it's spurring renewable
energy um and is a great example of I
would say a a success story in trying to
diversify what's happening out there on
the landscape when it comes to
electricity but also when it comes to uh
Just Energy in general or heat um so I
think you know I again I wanted to just
get on the record today that for all the
reasons that we mentioned last week on
House Bill 219 and kind of the broader
impacts on the industry and kind of what
we're seeing on the landscape and our
ability to manage that landscape this
bill also does also would stifle what I
would consider some really neat projects
some Innovation that we're seeing that
helps diversify and make make sure that
these B New Hampshire businesses remain
viable and continue to operate and those
Pro those businesses again as you heard
last week are generating local taxes
they're they're supporting local jobs
and again this is also making them s
sufficient and then on the environmental
aspect of it I think durgen and croll
said their their project would displace
9,000 gallons of propane consumption a
year so with a local local wood product
and a product that they generate as well
um it was touched on earlier and I'll
just bring a point to it about the
carbon aspects or the carbon aspects of
of burning wood last week I turn I
passed out a document it's from the US
Department of Agriculture this is the
state's it's called the forest inventory
analysis the USDA does an analysis of
the entire landscape of New Hampshire
once every five years they go out they
have a series of plots across the state
and they measure Timber growth they
measure Timber removals land conversion
and a host of other
things and think representative Swanson
hit the nail on the head trees trees
sequester carbon yes you burn carbon
carbon is released when you when you
burn a tree but that tree if you don't
pave over where that tree was removed
another is going to to grow in its place
in sequester
Carbon on page two of this document is a
pretty what I what I say is probably the
most simple way to look at what's Su
what we call sustainability in the state
of New Hampshire growth forest growth
continues to outpace both removals and
tree
mortality um and during this period 111
million cubic feet of trees are growing
is that's the bet that's the net net
change so in the state of New Hampshire
we continue to grow more wood I.E
sequester carbon then we do release it
from REM from burning it or putting it
and I guess the other pieces when you
put it in a solid wood product this
table this is stored carbon so this
discussion about whether or not burning
wood is is sustainable or whether it's
carbon neutral we think our our premises
is what what clearer picture do you have
of
sustainability and carbon neutrality or
positive carbon than you do with the
USDA when you look at the health and
growth of our forest I just wanted to
point that out um I'll conclude my
comments on this again you heard a lot
about it the RPS in general and the
forest products industry on my testimony
on
219 um there are in addition to Tom
christon there are a number of other
folks that did put in cards that were
unable to make it today um in the forest
products World winter is is the time
that you make hay frozen ground and so
to take two days off was they just
couldn't do it so they came on last week
submitted their testimony and said set
please provide the regards you have
their testimony on 219 which is also
applicable as you pull cards I'll give
you the high sign that they're not here
but their 219 House Bill 219 testimony
applies thank
you thank you I have a quick question
for you since 2014 when class one
thermal became a part of the
RPS there has never been since 2014
there has never been a sufficient number
of wrecks generated to cover the
obligation in the
RPS and yet the percentage has gone
up every year since it went up uh Z .4%
in 2014 0.6% in 2015 0.8% in
2016 and also increased annually by
0.2% through
20123 if we're not generating enough
reck uh
um should those
percentages go down should the the
obligation be
decreased it's a great question and it's
certainly something to look to look into
I I would suggest if this does go into
some type of a study or the RPS in
general is being looked at in in terms
of a study I know back when this was
passed there was also some expectations
that conquered steam was going to be
generating thermal wrecks and of course
as we know that project did not did not
come to fruition so certainly that would
be a question um something to certainly
take a look at I know Charlie nebling
who was I think slated to speak later
this morning this is he can speak
forwards and backwards about the number
of projects and the number of projects
in the queue and whether or not there
are sufficient projects to to fulfill
that obligation he's looking more
globally I tend to focus on just the
durgen and cwls the Britain numbers the
the lumber people he's looking at beyond
that at other other facilities
commercial County that are installing
thermal thermal
projects and he is on Deck he'll be next
all right additional questions
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr stock for
taking my question um I I wanted to ask
about the industry because I know that's
pretty much who you represent you have a
lot of knowledge in that regard um my my
concern is what changes we would wrought
if we we heard testimony last week say
from U John Moses who came in front of
us from a family business up in bath uh
Britain Lumber and he indicated that you
know margins are small but with the
class one between the class one and
class three they're investing in
Innovative technology right so they're
they're making Investments benefiting
the community can you give us an idea of
the
um of the balance right now in that
industry in terms of how precarious it
might be for some of these businesses to
be staying in business because I
wouldn't want to think that we would be
um we would be passing something that
would hurt New Hampshire businesses and
the the the the timber economy um sure
thank you great question I I think with
any business any business or industry
stability is is
Paramount you start you know they're
making their their investment Horizon
and the time that they're you know the
time and money that they're investing
today may be for a project that's two
three four years down the road um that
project if this if say thermal reck as
in the case of Britain Lumber or durgen
en croll is part of that investment
decision that they're making today for
that project down the road
to start introducing legislation or you
know passing legislation that pulls that
out of this decision process that is
incredibly disruptive and really hurts
that project but ultimately hurts that
business um we see it in the logging
side of the business as well if I'm a
logger and I have a chipper and I'm
trying to decide all right I need to
make a capital investment I have a 700
,000 chipper that I need to purchase do
I do I upgrade that chipper or don't I
well how is you know I see I hear from I
hear from the Timberland owners that
house bill 219 is being considered House
Bill 567 being considered all right as a
business person as a New Hampshire
business person am I going to invest in
that chipper if I know there's
uncertainty in those markets and so it
that uncertainty really wrecks Havoc
with kind of investment but also
business planning Capital
planning I hope I answered your question
Thomas okay representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman um so the followup would
be also about the low grade timber
that's another thing that we hear about
a lot is the sort of uh Forest
maintenance if you will um would that
aspect of New Hampshire forestry would
that suffer or would Jobs go away for
the people who actually move that Timber
and get it where it needs to go if if
these um businesses that take that would
um are no longer in operation or their
operations are scaled down because they
um are
losing you know these Investments that
they're trying to make the answer is
absolutely we we have seen that when
when the
plants um when there were a number of
plants that idled after all the vetos
that occurred 3 four years ago we saw an
immediate contraction in in logging
capacity companies that had three
crews um maybe a hand crew for for Big
Timber and and and then a chipping crew
for for chipping type jobs said all
right you know I'm getting rid of you
know I'm going to lay that I'm going to
lay that chipping crew off and I'll just
go with one crew the the other piece
that happens out of that Dynamic is is
okay I had let's say I had two Crews
operating in the woods one was doing
chipping work one was doing hand cutting
on kind of the high quality high quality
saw log lots and then on the the biomass
chipping Lots where I had clients that
wanted that product I get rid of that
well that company is no longer producing
the same volume of of Saw logs at the
same time that they were when they had
two Crews and so what we have also
started to see is pressure in The
Sawmill or the solid wood side of the
sector because there's just less wood
being managed the other piece that I
think is important and is that there are
a lot of wood Lots in the state of New
Hampshire that have been the term is
high graded and products like biomass
are the only way the only feasible way
to economically go in and remove that do
that weeding and thinning and move
remove that junk wood and so we've
gotten to a point where the markets have
gotten to the so tight that there are
land owners that said all right I'd like
you to come in and do this lot and the
logger said okay well I can't touch it
there's too much low grade there call
someone else and so we have Parcels that
are not they're just not getting they're
just not getting the treatment the siloc
cultural treatments that the that they
want for long-term growth and
productivity
representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair um so uh as
you noted the build dresses not only
thermal wrecks but biomass uh use as
well if we were to uh um eliminate the
thermal Rex not the biomass what tax
would you propose would be a good
substitute
what would be a good substitute tax to
to make up for thermal recks
yes it's a great question and that's why
it you know I don't have a I don't have
a a list of taxes that I'd say ah here
you go but um what I can say is this is
that there are a lot of industries that
are tangential to what we do
that benefit from the work that happens
in our forest whether it's
hospitality whether it's Rec outdoor
recreation and so you know I think that
would make a compelling argument that
this is this is a this is a Statewide
there's a Statewide benefit that comes
from our forest being healthy in our
tourism industry and all of that that
goes with that and so again I don't have
a silver bullet I don't have a here here
representative bernardy here's tax
number one here's tax here's a specific
tax that's going to plug this hole I do
asking I've been saying since 2015 it
ought to come out of the room and meals
tax representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um and thank you for being
here Mr stock um we know that we're
seeing dry winter
that are leading to droughts in the
spring um and your industry are seem to
be the stewards of the forests and we
have an awful lot of trees in New
Hampshire so my question is if we cut
back on harvesting the timber in any way
would that impact the Wildfire threats
that we're um probably going to be
seeing more and more of in in New
Hampshire great question you know you
you start monkeying or cutting back
Management in in the management of
forest wildfires are just one of many
threats um we have a lot of a lot of
invasive bugs and critters coming into
the state and eating chewing on our
trees that we need to get rid of um
anyone with ash trees or hemlock trees
will will tell you that between the
emerald ashbo and The Woolly ad delid
there's a there's a need for markets
that consume that consume those chips
consume that wood if if you want a
health forest fires is is is one piece
um that's one one piece of the puzzle
but there's just general Forest Health
and productivity that we need to keep in
mind as well thank you you're
welcome representative partiall has a
question thank you chair and welcome Mr
stock um I'm trying to ask this question
in the way that uh my constituents I
received quite a bit of mail on this
issue on and many of them do seem
concerned and I know that online we have
245 oppos this bill seven people support
it so here goes by eliminating thermal
reck will we be more dependent upon
Expendable and imported fossil fuel in
your opinion this two-part question well
absolutely and I think durgen and croll
gave us the the the perfect answer to
that question with
990,000 was it 90,000 gallons of propane
they are displacing with their with
their boiler boiler project which is
that's one project that is that is tied
to the thermal wreck program so
following up then in your opinion would
this potentially create a more
dependency on fossil fuel and more
volatility in consumer prices such as we
saw in uh
2022 I yes the answer is yes I think and
we you know not to go down to Rabbit
Hole but energy you know it's having
diversity of energy sources it's like
your stock portfolio you're going to
have shares of different products
because everything doesn't move at once
energy is the same same way and I'll let
the the utility energy people talk about
speak to that but I think biomass is a
great hedge it is a local native fuel um
that comes out of our forest we are the
second most forested state in the nation
it is a great hedge against some of this
volatility and where these plants are
located across the
state is it also provides some you know
some stability out there because they're
out on the landscape and it's not one
central location on the Sea Coast of New
Hampshire that's trying to distribute
power you have local generation that's
occurring dispersed across the landscape
which I would also argue is as much as
the fuel diversity is also a benefit
thank
you all right seeing no more questions
we need to move along here I've got a
dozen pink cards left and we have two
other public hearings this morning so we
need to try to we've already spent over
an hour on this well actually almost an
hour and 45 minutes on this subject so I
think it's I think we're starting to
hear
repetitive uh information and I'm not
sure that's going to get us anywhere
next up is Charlie
nebling Good Morning Charlie welcome
back
please make some original points and
make them as quickly as you can I will
thank you Mr
chairman um my name is Charlie nebling
I'm a a Forester I live in bosin New
Hampshire and I've spent probably the
last 15 years of my career as a an
advocate supporter of uh modern wood
Heat eating and combined heat and power
technology in the state of New Hampshire
because I think it's good for the State
of New
Hampshire um I'm circulating two sets of
testimony my own as well as that of Mr
Joe Hogan who is the
CEO of Continuum at North Conway the
developers of the Ridgeline Community
project in Conway Mr Hogan I believe was
here last week but was unable to be here
today so you can REM remove his card but
uh with his permission I've I've
submitted his written
testimony
um just a little bit about the history
of of
thermal this was
debated extensively during the uh
original RPS legislation in
2006 as a study bill in 2007 is House
Bill
873 ultimately the legislation set in
motion a study by the Public Utilities
Commission of adding thermal to the
RPS and in addition the original
enabling
legislation recognized the benefit of a
more fuel diverse and Technology neutral
RPS by allowing the renewable energy
fund to be utiliz for thermal renewable
projects in the original Bill House Bill
um in 2011 there was a bill to recognize
heat from combined heat and power
projects in the
RPS that same year the Pu issued their
study indicating that the addition of
thermal to the RPS was feasible and in
2012 it was incorporated as part of a
comprehensive RPS Reform Bill uh which
was heard by this committee debated and
discussed and deliberated over
extensively by the legislature that year
and ultimately passed in the form of
Senate Bill
218 so there's a little bit of History
um as I've indicated before to the
committee I think the primary reason
that it passed was because thermal was
ultimately structured as a carve out in
class one and assigned a much lower
alternative compliance payment a cealing
price uh I believe at the time class one
electric was
$55 and maybe a little bit higher
because of the annual CPI
adjustment and the ACP for thermal was
set at $25 so it was seen primarily as a
cost-saving measure but also a move to
diversify the
RPS um by recognizing thermal
Technologies and a reminder to the
committee we use more heat energy in New
Hampshire than we do electricity it is
more than onethird of the total energy
consumed in this state and that is per
the
eia um my testimony summarizes some
statistics based on the number of
projects that have become eligible to
generate thermal wrecks that list which
came from the Department of energy
website and is dated or updated as of
December 2024 is on the last three pages
of my
testimony but a few statistics the total
installed capacity of these systems
which are biomass and
geothermal is 57 megawatts that is
approaching the the installed capacity
or name plate capacity of the Burgess
biopower plant in Berlin which I believe
is 70
megaw um
these are property poor school districts
rural
hospitals County
facilities uh businesses Municipal
facilities uh State uh University system
campuses Plymouth keen and the Thompson
school at
UNH uh so they they reflect a sort of a
interesting diversity of
beneficiaries many of them financed by
public tax
dollars um and the primary reason that
people consider this technology is to
reduce operating cost
now these systems come with a higher
Capital cost uh burning wood a solid
fuel is just fundamentally more complex
an engineering proposition than burning
oil or gas they're anywhere from two to
four times the capex of a comparably
sized propane natural gas or oil system
so there's a big upfront cost and wrecks
are seen as a way either of paying down
that Capital cost and reducing the
payback period or and or reducing
operating
cost these systems spend approximately
$7 million a year on chips and pellets
sourced from within New Hampshire those
are fuel dollars that stay here
circulate in our economy and multiply
and they've displaced the need for over
4.1 million gallons of heating oil
equivalent on an annual basis so there
is a significant economic benefit to the
Hampshire uh they have spurred
Innovation uh you heard Mr stock
reference several projects I want to
mention three additional projects uh DCI
Furniture in Lisbon New Hampshire which
is the last large Manu uh furniture
manufacturer in the state with 165
employees is in the process of
installing a biomass combined heat and
power system that will generate thermal
wrecks the balsam's Redevelopment which
is on again off again I recognize that
but uh they tore out an old
inefficient uh wood burning boiler that
heated the hotel complex and are
planning a significant new addition and
expansion of that
complex and the last Mr chairman is the
Ridgeline project which you have
testimony from Mr Hogan uh speaking to
the importance of that that's been three
or four years in planning and financing
during a very difficult financing period
That's 126 acre uh combined senior
residential assisted living and
Commercial camp cus in the Redstone area
of Conway it's a green field development
that fact the fact that you are in the
ground uh building at the same time you
are making a decision about how you're
going to heat makes possible District
Heating and there is a site plan this is
dated early January
20125 that
um helps to illustrate the scope of the
campus and the number of buildings that
will be heated from the district plant
and I should add that it's only the
larger buildings the smaller Cottages
are are not costeffective to heat with
District
heating uh this project uh is is
planning on T-Rex Revenue as part of
their project Financial performa as are
the others that I
mentioned and to conclude my
testimony um Mr chairman I just want to
speak to a couple of of the comments
that uh representative Harrington made
the question that representative
Bernardi
posed and comments from a witness uh
week ago I think the reason we've seen a
Slowdown in modern wood heat is probably
four or five-fold first um in the
mid2 Oil and Propane dropped in price
that price differential drives
consideration of renewable heating
Alternatives probably more than anything
else I think the attention that
strategic
electrification has received across the
board in all aspects of energy
consumption um
has in in a way sort of sucked the
oxygen out of the room and pushed to the
fringes uh nonel electric renewable
Technologies I think the controversy
over the biomass power plants and the
attention that uh Governor sununu's
vetos received perhaps had a um a
chilling effect on consideration of the
use of wood even though the use of wood
in
heating um and to address a
misconception of Representative
Harrington's is on the order of 75 to
95% output efficient based on the fuel
and the technology
used and lastly um this committee has
heard no fewer than four bills in the
last seven or eight years to eliminate
thermal or repeal or significantly alter
the
RPS I can't emphasize enough what an
impact that has on the marketplace and
on those who are responding to a price
signal set in the original enabling
legislation and who are planning
projects with a two to
foure cycle uh that is from conception
of the idea to
implementation financing and
implementation
to to not know whether this policy will
be in place or not
um it's had a chilling effect House Bill
225 in 2017 House Bill 213 in
20122 House Bill 166 and
2023 and two years ago this committee
passed by a 19 to1 committee vote House
Bill
233 which actually set in motion a
process at the department of energy to
consider alternative heat verification
strategy for smaller systems why did you
do that and Mr chairman you were Prime
sponsor of the bill to Avail the
incentive to a broader array of
Technologies and in particular smaller
systems for which
the uh the um BTU meters was too
expensive a proposition and incidentally
that process is underway at the doe and
hopefully they'll have a draft uh of of
alternative measure to consider
relatively
soon to your question representative
Bernardi um this these Technologies used
to benefit from a 30% Federal renewable
energy investment tax credit the Biden
Administration took that away uh as a
condition of the passage of the
inflation reduction Act and the clean
electricity standard that was in that
bill they foreclosed on the ability of
high efficiency Heaton systems to be
eligible for that credit so uh one
possible means of uh restoring some
measure of uh incentive for Capital cost
would be to restore the federal
investment credit on these
systems and I just wanted to bring that
to your attention and that concludes my
testimony Mr chairman I'd be happy to
answer any questions two quick questions
number one can you define district for
us you talked about District Heating and
the second question is can you contrast
the price of wood heating versus propane
or
oil yes uh District heating would be uh
where you have a central heat plant and
heat is distributed through a grid
either in the form of steam low pressure
high pressure or more efficient hot
water through super insulated
underground piping two buildings where
that heat is transferred to through a
heat exchanger to a hydronic Grid in the
building uh it's very efficient the
technology has been uh developed and
improved in Europe it's available here
in the US there are many examples of
that uh uh right here in New Hampshire
marac Valley school district has a
district heating plant for four
buildings heated with wood which
parenthetically they replaced a
resistance electric heating in their
high school when they did that um there
are other good examples conquer steam
was was the biggest example before um
before that that uh system went offline
several years
ago uh the second question is what is
the comparative cost green chips are
going to be somewhere around
$6 to9 per million btu on a heat output
basis dry chips
somewhere around 12
to15 per million btu and Mr froling can
speak to
that pellets somewhere between $8 and
$22 per million
btu propane depending on what the price
is today but at uh $350 or $4 a gallon
is north of $30 a million btu and oil at
I think the last time I checked the uh
doe website it was
$3.9 a gallon residential retail
delivered is somewhere around3 or $32 a
million btu so that's the comparative
heat cost but that's just uh sort of an
Apples to Apples comparison based on
the efficiency of conversion of that
heat and the Heat and the energy content
of the fuel and its moisture
content okay thank you anybody else have
a quick
question representative partial thank
you chair V and thank you for your
testimony today um my school board uh a
few years ago installed a a um dry chip
uh heating system and a concern was
expressed to me I'm hope you can explain
this to me that with the loss of thermal
recks uh to uh um supplement the cost of
heating they would probably have to pass
those costs on to their to our taxpayers
and the result of high and resulting in
higher property taxes is that uh are
they accurate in that
assessment uh yes they are they're
probably
receiving somewhere between 20 and say
$24 per megawatt hour U of of gross
revenue from the sale of those thermal
wrecks uh that is revenue that and I
don't know what the policy is in your
school district but in in many school
districts that's used to reduce
operating cost offset other unrelated
operating costs and or pay down Capital
cost on the original
investment now if if that Revenue isn't
coming in it has to be either they have
to reduce costs through other means or
uh they have to uh replace that Revenue
with with taxpayer dollars or some other
source of Revenue thank
you representative McGee please make it
quick thank you Mr chair I will so on
line 17 of the bill where they're
listing uh classes uh in the RPS and uh
under class three on line 17 it
basically says 2025 and thereafter we're
going to go from an 8% a lot that's been
there since 2015 to 1% can you speak to
what that change would do to people who
are participating now because I'm not
sure everyone here is clear on that that
that kind of drop from 8 to 1% well
that's class three is the existing
biomass and landfill gas projects uh
there are probably others
here more uh able to speak to the impact
of that change on supply and demand d
dyamics and wreck prices
but in general if you lower the purchase
obligation and the amount of Supply
remains constant the value of those
crash okay seeing no more questions I'm
going to invite next up to the U well
before I invite the next
speaker I'm gonna have to say you have
forced my hand we still have 12 cards
left
we're already two hours into a public
hearing on this bill so I'm going to
have to limit testimony from this point
forward to two and a half minutes per
person and if we don't finish by 10:30
and then I'm going to have to suspend or
recess this public hearing yet
again which I think is totally
unnecessary but like I say you force my
hand so next up jod grimas please give
us uh your perspective as quickly as
possible I am going to talk so fast two
and a half minutes keep
up thank you Mr chairman for the record
my name is jod Grimble ASM lobbyist here
in conquered my client is Bridgewater
power company Michael Larry was here
last week he could not be here today I'm
passing around his testimony I think a
lot of what I would have said has
already been said by by Mr stock and Mr
nebling so I'll be very brief to tell
you two couple a couple quick
things yes the issue in the build itself
for us an existing biomass power plant
is on line 17 in the bill which is class
three where it goes from 8% to 1% and
then also on page two section four it
says class three and it strikes out
existing biomass so that is where the
independent biomass producers that are
currently have been existed since 2000
well in this program since 2007 would be
wiped out you would only have methane as
part of class three that is the part
that we're very concerned about because
it would impact um those benefits that
you've heard a lot about today so um
that is specifically to the existing
biomass plants again I think about the
biomass plant benefits is three energy
economy environment I think you've heard
a lot about energy their Basel load 247
probably 360 to out of 365 days a year
they produce energy electricity um
economy they have payroll they're
usually the biggest tax players in their
area and that supply chain of wood which
you've heard all about very important to
the um local and Statewide economy and
then environment you've heard about
sustaining forestry um weeding the
thinning the forest weeding the garden
decreasing fire risk and you also
learned about the byproduct of wood ash
that helps a lot of farmers in the state
of New Hampshire so those are the reason
we oppose it um the only thing I would
add and Charlie touched on it briefly is
the legislative history this same exact
bill has been to this legislature twice
before uh 2022 it was House Bill 213 and
it was sent to interim study by a vote
of 21 to Z from this committee um House
Bill 166 which actually came out in
2024 um was voted 19 to1 inexpedient to
legislate and I'll leave you with this
this bill would have eliminated biomass
wood from receiv receiving Rex the wood
industry remains extremely important to
the state for many jobs and the health
of our forests elimination of this class
would only further damage an already
struggling industry not only in the
North country but Statewide for this
reason the majority of the committee
felt this bdy was not ready to be
enacted and recommends inexpedient to
legislate that was 2024 so I'm hoping
you'll find this bill in expedient to
legislate the blurb is already written
and um thank you very much for your
time thank you seeing no questions I'll
invite the next person up which is
Conservancy does not appear to be here
so we'll move on and H have Sam Evans
Brown give us whoops gave you the wrong
card Sam Evans Brown up
next two and a half minutes Sam
please thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh cleaners and Hampshire
similarly is in opposition to this bill
um I'd just like to reiterate something
that Charlie nebling did mention but
just to just to call it out since
Charlie said a lot of really valuable
things uh just two years ago in 202
three this this body unanimously passed
HB 233 which created uh the possibility
for creating new metering standards that
should solve the supply constraint of
thermal renewable energy credits and
make available the production and
consumption of of T-Rex to residential
customers which I think is a uh positive
step forward uh unfortunately due to uh
statutory concerns about the creation of
the Department of energy they felt they
couldn't proceed with that Ru making
until they had been given additional
authority to to uh to make decisions by
rule or order so there was a second bill
that was required last year before that
rule making could commence it is now
underway and so as soon as it's
completed there's I think a lot of us
are quite hopeful that there will be
more thermal wrecks that are flooding
into the market and dealing with the the
cost of compliance issue that has been
flagged by by a couple of folks um the
second thing as I would I would just uh
say I do think there is a strong Nexus
between electricity
rates uh and the the thermal sector
right so anytime we have a a source that
is producing heat during New England's
particular particularly challenging
times which is the the cold dark days of
winter which is when our natural gas
pipelines are constrained any source
that is that is taking that strain off
the natural gas pipeline network is
going to result in lower electricity
bills so in so far as we have uh thermal
sources supplementing electric heating
or natural gas heating it's going to
result in in lower electric rates so I
think there is a strong argument for
this program being attached to electric
rates uh and with that I'll close my
testimony okay see no okay seeing no
questions for Mr Sam Evans Brown thank
you sir for your testimony and next
meis thank you chairman thank you
committee my my name is Jared Muller I'm
here representing misus we are a
residential um wood pellet borderer
manufacturer and also a distributor of
wood pets we distribute about 12 to
15,000 tons
annually and I wanted to talk about kind
of the unclear messaging we were excited
about Bill 233 to include residential
things at a easier
rate uh to be part of this and now we're
seeing this in opposition of that and
quite concerning we have decided not to
do business in the state of New
Hampshire on two occasions because of
kind of the inconsistent messaging
regarding biomass and have built a Depot
in Massachusetts instead and we'll
proceed forth probably building one in
Vermont in the next couple of years and
have skipped that's been a problem
couple of things I wanted to bring up as
well that does need to be the Rex
uh we were excited about the being made
easier for the residential Market the
unclear messaging uh for the State of
New Hampshire and repeatedly bringing
this up year after year or a couple
years in between and a couple things I
also wanted to touch upon in 2018 when
the us. Environmental Protection Agency
under the Trump
administr trump Administration
officially declared biomass to be carbon
neutral I'll allow representative Mr
Harrington to debate that with his
Democratic colleagues because they're
the ones that have challenged that and
also two that uh if you do refer to the
Wood pet heating database of the EPA
certified
equipment they are upwards of 90%
efficient and then some uh thank you for
consideration okay thank you seeing no
oh representative McGee thank you Mr
chair hi nice to see you again um thank
you for being here today so uh it it
sounds like you you've been following
what we've been doing here because you
you were planning to maybe be doing
business in New Hampshire and then you
thought better of it from your statement
so my question is you said that you you
mentioned twice that you thought that we
were providing unclear messaging like to
to what we're doing but is it unclear
messaging or is it unclear policy uh uh
unclear policy unclear yeah yeah okay
thanks okay seeing no further questions
froling representative Wendy Thomas has
a question thank you Mr chair um you
mentioned that you've stopped doing um
deliveries in New Hampshire or work in
New Hampshire can you um specifically
give me the impact of how
much chips you have not provided and and
what that would equal in in terms of
energy well I I don't have the numbers
in front of me as far as how many you
know but you have quite a few people
that have taken advantage of some of
your rebates and have installed
residential systems that
are kind of waiting for these wrecks to
be easier like we talked about in the
previous Bill and this obviously would
squash that which I think this whole
committee thought would be a good idea
to make it um instead of net metering to
do it based on actual weight of what was
delivered uh which is programs that
other states have modeled your program
but have made it a little easier and
have been highly beneficial and
successful in particular in Maine um so
I I don't know how to qualify it totally
but um certainly an impact and has
certainly steered us clear of here to
invest further thank you very much okay
thank you seeing no more further
questions I'll ask Mark froling to come
up and give us his perspective in two
and a half
minutes that's perfect for me I'm a man
of few words but thank you so much um
representative Vose for holding this
discussion um obviously this um wreck
incentive is really important for our
company uh but more so than our company
because we're just a very small company
um it is actually really important for
our customers um who are their wreck
recipients
and so these Rec of our of all of our
clients is actually uh the rec
recipients are mostly of public um
Schools public um counties and things
like that so it's about um most of our
Recs about um 80% go to um back back to
the state and so they would be the
losers of that and so um how does that
money where does that money come from
when the rec goes away it would actually
come from the taxpayers so for instance
um in Jaffrey New Hampshire I I believe
you you live in Jeffrey or close by
anyway so represented Jeffrey and um so
in that school and I can't do the
physical calculations for that if they
are getting you know they're using 300
tons right now and so they're getting 90
wrecks um uh no sorry 900 recks in a
year right now it's about $188,000 worth
that money would have to then come from
the taxpayers clearly because that money
is now no long longer available same for
Treasure County they're getting a little
bit over 2 and a half thousand wrecks
that money would have to come from the
state itself so 80% of the rec that our
company has installed and we're sort of
um you know a larger installer for sure
for this technology um um goes directly
back to the state or to municipalities
and to to individual towns so that money
will have to come from the taxpayers in
the future I don't see any way around it
so it's really just shifting it from the
rate payers to the taxpayers but it it's
not coming from other places so I just
want people to be aware about who who
who they're levying the tax or the
incentive to in the
future um as far as um represent
Harrington representative Harrington um
uh the combustion efficiency um as
mentioned by you in the 40% is about 99%
combustion efficiency the overall
thermal efficiency of a boiler maybe
that's what you were targeting at is
between you know on a steam boiler in
the 70s all the way up into the 92% on a
pallet boiler with drier fuel so um and
as per um the EPA we are carbon neutral
in our technology um I typically use the
word near carbon neutral because um I
feel like it represents that a little
bit better because we make deliveries
with diesel trucks and we go into the
forest with chainsaws and things like
that and even though the carbon cycle is
quite neutral in its Behavior I like to
also kind of own up to it there's use of
um of fossil fuel technology in our
industry and so I like to really be very
transparent about that and typically use
the term near carbon neutral
um I think it's a fair
representation okay thank you for your
testimony one quick question when you
talked about the efficiency of the
boilers was that using green wood or
dried wood yeah the efficiency is it's a
great question um clearly maybe an
engineer or something like that but um
the deficiency is mostly related to the
um water content in in in the fuel so um
if you have 50% moisture in the fuel and
in your wood that comes from the tree
and you put it into the um boiler the
usable energy that you get out um is
only a portion of that because it takes
a lot of energy to actually burn off the
water in there first so then you have
the remaining energy that you that you
can use in your radiators and things
like that and so that energy is sort of
the um you
know that efficiency um is basically
calculates how how
much the the useful versus the nonuseful
energy is kind of calculates how
efficient your overall boiler thermal
efficiency is so and so typically we you
know on a on a steam boiler it can't be
quite as efficient because of the higher
temperatures and the conversion to steam
we have some losses there and so um hot
water boilers tend to be a little bit
more efficient but it really mostly
depends on the moisture cont off the
fuel so your answer is that drier fuel
burns more efficiently much more yes do
you have
any because you're in this business do
you have any data about the cost of
drying the fuel the and the amount of
energy that's needed to dry the fuel how
does that compare to
the resulting efficiency of the fuel
once it's burned in a boiler cost versus
efficiency see H but physics of physics
basically takes the same amount of
energy no matter where you are if you
are drying it in your boiler versus in
um so if we're drying Fuel and it taks a
certain amount of energy and of course
related cost um it takes the same amount
of energy to dry it in somebody else's
boiler on site at a school the reason
why we do that is just like refining
fuel oil for instance um you refine it
so a car can run very efficient is same
reason why you actually season your wood
in your cordwood boiler um if you don't
season it then you have a lot of other
um tars in your chimney and things like
that that makes it very undesirable so
it's really just a refining process and
it takes a certain amount of energy and
it just makes it more useful um one more
quick thing that I wanted to say even
though we are receiving this incentive
is quite clear to me um and um a lot of
people seem like it's maybe it's not
quite fair to receive this incentive and
things like that I believe Mr Harrington
was saying something that we shouldn't
be getting this but you know there's uh
the oil and gas industry and I have a
couple Pages I'm I'm super limited on
time here so I can't really read these
all but there's two two pages of oil and
gas incentives um that are actually in
our federal tax code and so we don't
have any of these tax incentives from a
federal standpoint and so we're just
literally getting this tiny little slice
of the pie here and it is really
beneficial for our state as I mentioned
our primary beneficiary of this wreck is
actually directly back into the state I
don't really see why that is so
important for Mr Harrington to sort of
eliminate that incentive okay no
debating here we're just trying to find
answers to questions anyways there's
other going to debate me I want a chance
to
respond no because we're not going to
have a debate
representative L relle has a question
perfect yeah thank you Mr chair it's a
very simple question do any of these
boil
designs allow for condensing
boilers yes you can um you can make a
wood boiler condensing boiler
correct thank you all right no further
questions we'll move along to Mr Kevin
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everyone I'll try and be quick as I said
Mr Kevin Porter here and conquered our
family owns and operates Timberlands
throughout Marram County uh largely to
provide a source of thermal energy
sounds like you've already gotten a
primer on forestry so I'll try and stick
to energy economics here um now more
than ever thermal energy and electricity
are intertwined and that's only going to
increase with heat pump adoption and
heat pumps are great uh but they do add
to those wintertime peaks in demand
which is becoming more of an issue here
in New Hampshire uh by supplementing
those with wood energy it's a great way
to smooth out those demands and provide
a another way to generate heat for
residential and Commercial and
Industrial
customers um secondly related to that uh
going forward our Energy System is
moving from one of a small number of
large Institution power plants to where
we have a larger number of small
distributed generation uh and wood
energy is a a prime example of that uh
for those that may study our electric
bills you may have noticed that the
largest reason we've seen increase is
because of transmission and distribution
so by having smaller projects like wood
projects we can help mitigate those
costs um that have been hitting all of
us in the in the pocketbook last thing
I'll say um re are really about uh
sending price signal sign to the market
and they're really about monetizing
externalities for every gallon of fossil
fossil fuel Fuel Oil propane that's
purchased in New Hampshire most of that
leaves the state and we never see it
again um if it's in the winter time it
probably leaves the country and we never
see it again uh but if we're talking
about wood energy you have a whole
ecosystem of land owners loggers
truckers Mill Operators um help recycle
that money and and keep it
local um
with that I urge you to oppose this Bill
thank you very
much okay seeing no questions we want to
thank you for coming to talk to us and
we'll call on Matt Ley of the forest
Society
next good morning thank you Mr chair uh
for the record I'm Matt Ley I'm the
public policy director for the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Forest um I'll be brief uh we oppose the
bill and it's really you know when we
look at the purpose for the RPS that's
where our opposition comes from you know
that purpose talks about local renewable
fuels and resources you know further
talks about you know how these types of
sources can um lower our dependence on
other fossil fuel sources and it you
know again talks about you know how the
RPS keeps energy investment dollars in
New Hampshire those are all valid goals
they were valid when the RPS was
established and they still are so again
um we oppose the bill but I'll take any
questions seeing no questions want to
thank you for your testimony and give
the last word here to John Gage from
minutes and please make this about the
bill and thermal energy and nothing else
please
uh thank you chairman and committee for
hearing my testimony I oppose this bill
um representative Harington I'm a rate
payer so you can ask me um reducing
demand for gas heating will lower the
demand um will lower the prices uh and
so this is just a sensible thermal and
electricity um energy are mixed as we
heard um I think we need it's important
to diversify our state's energy
resources um
but I'd like to talk about why this
committee seems to be stumbling on a lot
of these things um there seems to be a
disrespect for science in particular
climate science I'm going to have to
stop you there that's not the subject
this public hearing you like to discuss
this bill we'd be happy to hear it but
otherwise uh you're dismissed I do so
the problem is that the external costs
of the pollution that were mentioned
before from fossil fuels not being
reflected in their prices is going to
end soon and the state should be aware
of that and the reason that it's not is
the influence of the fossil fuel
industry through money funding front
groups that have a strong influence in
our energy policy mix they're confusing
you they're tricking you and this is
causing a problem in decisions like for
this bill um okay you're not addressing
the subject of the bill so I'm going to
cut off your testimony there and thank
you very much for being here and close
the public hearing on House Bill HB 567
FN and I will now open a public heing on
House Bill 674
FN relative to non wires or nonwire
Alternatives time of use tariffs and
multi-year rate settings and call on
legislation morning Mr chair and good
morning fellow committee
members I'm going to be brief about HB
674 FN this is a a bill that is intended
as a vehicle for utility reform and as
you're all aware uh utility reform is a
heavy lift and um so this bill really is
a work in
progress and I would love to see nothing
better than to have this bill retained
in committee and to uh undertake a study
on utility reform on a bipartisan basis
because I think that we are you know
from the 30,000 foot view that people
like to reference I think we are largely
in agreement on the aims of utility
regulation and what we want the
utilities to do better at namely bring
on more generation keep costs low and
enhance uh Marketplace competition while
at the same time uh maintaining a viable
utility business for their shareholders
so you know it's a it's a hybrid
structure uh it always needs to be
looked at and uh pushed forward um I
think the utility on their own aren't
going to do that they're quite happy to
you know go through pu docket after pu
docket and then come to us retroactively
and say can you please fix this in
statute I think that's not our duty as a
legislature we ought to be looking at
how to frame utility structure to best
serve our constituents and uh so
hopefully this bill might be a vehicle
to start that kind of conversation
otherwise um I think that's all I've got
to say on it I'm happy to answer
questions or defer to people coming
me okay thank you representative Kaplan
questions for the representative
representative Harrington has one yeah
I'm just trying to clarify this so I
understand um when it talks about
required default service providers to
establish fear and reasonable time of
use tariffs so you're referring there
just to the energy portion of the
electric bill not the transmission and
distribution
I'm not sure about that I mean time of
use tariffs come from the demand side
right so that would have to that entails
some sort of distribution of the
electricity I'm follow up follow up yeah
I'm I'm not maybe um maybe my question
wasn't very clear I'm just trying to
figure what you're saying here I think
the intent of the bill is to say that
the utility shall provide fear and
reasonable time abuse tariff for
seasonal daily Peak and off peak usage
for everybody and the electric bill is
broken into multiple parts and the two
major ones are transmission and
distribution and then um energy uh which
is you know somewhere around 45% so
would this apply just to the default
service energy and I bring this up
because let's say I was buying from a um
a third party rather than from the
utility I was getting my energy from a
third party would I also pay higher
transmission or would that affect my
transmission and distribution cost or
would those be unaffected by this bill
that's an excellent question
representative I'm not sure I'm able to
answer that I mean I know that there are
you know questions about third party
providers and and whether they're paying
their fair share of transmission and
distribution so that's a very
complicated question I'm not able to
answer that thank
you additional
questions seeing none we'll move on next
up will be Matt Young from the New
good morning and welcome back to st&
you good to see you soon Mr chairman
thank you um for the record Matt Young
I'm an attorney with the New Hampshire
Department of energy um the department
does have a number of concerns with this
bill but um I think given Mr or excuse
me representative kaplan's testimony um
if the bill is not going to proceed
we're happy to yield our time um and uh
um I didn't did you let me just clarify
representative Kaplan did you say you
didn't want this bill to go
forward I'm going to leave that in the
hands of the committee I I would love
this bill to be retained in committee as
a study um and if not I'm happy to leave
that you know the the final uh decision
on what to do with this bill to you okay
I got it thank you
all right then you don't have to go
through your point by point if we're um
going to be considering this at a later
time so we can move on so thank
you last up on this bill is Alexander
spidel of the New Hampshire Public
Utilities
Commission good morning uh Mr chairman
and members of the committee uh the
Public Utilities Commission wanted to
indicate that we don't necessarily have
a set position on a number of these
Provisions but the position that we do
have that we'd like to put forward
before the committee is that we had
concerns regarding subpart Roman
3C and the issue we have with this is
for starters it says if you look at
Roman 3 line 18 on page one of the bill
it says that the department of energy
and Public Utilities Commission and then
when you go to part C uh line one of
page two of the bill it says set rate
cases in accordance with RSA 3787 so we
just wanted to flag to the committee
that the department of energy does not
set rate cases the Public Utilities
Commission adjudicates rate cases um
furthermore the commission wanted to put
in a plug and uh last year I had given
testimony in this general area as well
uh regarding the favorability of the
six-month default service rate setting
cycle uh it's been established for our
regulated utility since the early 2000s
in the case of Liberty and also
Unitil and definitely uh for PSNH right
away when they went into divesture mode
their six rate uh six-month rate cycle
started uh for the procurements in
around
2018 so uh the benefit of that six-month
rate cycle versus a fiveyear cycle is
that there can be responsiveness to
market conditions as they develop and
that often means upside benefit for
consumers when prices go down and I
would also throw out to the committee to
as a point of uh consideration is
imagine if we were sitting here in
February of 2020 uh what would our
crystal ball tell us about the World
Market and uh political events of the
next 5 years I I don't know if we would
necessarily guess exactly what would be
happening over the next 5 years in
February of 2020
um so that would be the substance of my
remarks thank you any questions for Mr
spidal representative Harrington has
one yeah so I'm a little confused with
with that what that has to do with this
bill you are saying that a
fiveyear but this bill talks about a
fiveyear average I would guess this
talks about time of use tariff which I'm
assuming would be uh instantaneous based
on the LMP or the the real time time
either that or day ahead uh no
representative Harrington we're not
addressing the time of view segment of
the bill the bill that we're looking
segment that we're looking at is part C
of Roman 3 which says that rates for
State Electric default service customers
are established every 5 years that's a
five-year rate setting cycle for the
default service energy rates okay
followup followup that's but that's what
I'm confused about how can you have time
of use rates and have a fiveyear rate it
seems like you can't have one or the
other but you can't have both that's an
excellent question I uh I would think I
would defer to representative kaplan's
uh characterization of this being a work
in progress but it seems like the two uh
things are in tension great tension
that's that's correct thank
you further
questions seeing none let's get the
utilities perspective on this bill and
eversource and by the way that is the
legislation thank you uh chairman uh
members of the committee Michael AATA on
behalf of eversource uh I'll be
exceptionally brief uh we do have a
number of concerns with the bill uh
really do appreciate representative
Kaplan uh reaching out having a a
conversation about this the other day
walking through those concerns and his
receptiveness to uh you know put some
more work into this the the only other
thing I'd say aside from from our
appreciation uh is we do think that
there has been some progress made uh
recently in fact last year on the
integrated distribution planning bill
that you all passed and is now law on
the uh non wires alternative section
where utilities have to file um these
distribution planning documents every I
think it's five years and include an
assessment that they have done of
non-wire alternative so there was some
some activity and progress made on that
but really just uh we do have uh
concerns no need to go through them uh
Point by point and really do appreciate
representative kaplan's uh willingness
feedback
okay
so I guess that's it no further pink
cards no further questions we'll close
the public hearing on House Bill
FN and representative Kaplan I'd remind
you that we need a pink card from you
about uh for introducing the bill and I
would also remind
representative McGee that we need a pink
bill which would be House Bill
681 establishing a Statewide online
energy data
platform and
and so whoops this is for
74 I got a
late pink card on
674 unfortunately I already closed the
public
hearing
um but since we have a few minutes I'll
some where's my
okay I miss print on the card this is
supposed to be 681 excellent okay so now
we can that's straightened out we can
now call Representative McGee to
681 thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee nice to see you all this
morning I'm representative cat McGee of
Hillsboro 35
Hollis um I'm come to you today to ask
for your support on HB 681 a bill that
seeks to edit the initial language in
statute that describes the
characteristics that need to be included
in the state's design of the Statewide
energy data
Hub these items uh listed in the statute
which may be found on page two of the
Bills starting at line 16 include
governance development implementation
change management and versioning of the
platform standards for data accuracy
retention
availability privacy and security
including the integrity and uniformity
of The Logical data model and Financial
Security standards or mechanisms to
assure compliance with privacy standards
by Third
parties that was the original language
of the statute which was passed in um B
I'm sorry SB 284 back in
2019 and that language basically pushed
forward um a docket at the Public
Utilities Commission where um interested
parties and interveners including myself
um came together to try and satisfy
these
requirements uh as is referenced in the
Bill's analysis the framework and
operational guidelines that the
governance Council which was also
established by that
legislation uh who worked on the
technical issues of this software
project were approved by the Commission
in an order on March 2nd 2022 that order
found that both the technical approach
and the governance Paradigm endorsed by
the utilities the department of energy
and the other stakeholders who had been
working together since the bill passed
in 2019 were consistent with the
requirements set forth in RSA 378 col
51- 54
um under findings in section three on
page one line 15 the bill language
references the public utility
commission's order number
[Music]
26589 acknowledging that the parties to
the governance council at the end of
line 18 you'll find quote have
collaborated effectively to create a
plan for the development and governance
of a Statewide multi-use online data
platform in a manner that is mindful of
the need to avoid excessive rate
impacts section three on page two
starting on line 20 says quote the
membership Authority and consensus
decision-making Paradigm of the
governance the platform governance
Council as approved on March 2nd 2022
shall apply to the planning construction
and operation of the
platform I was in the conversations
around how this project moved forward
and we were meeting we had 158 hour
technical session
um during 2020 during
Co um with the it professionals from all
of the utilities as well as it
professionals who intervened on the
project from around the country because
they had been party to other efforts of
this type in other states around the
country if we had had the slides set up
this morning I had just three simple
slides that showed um the other states
in the country that have already that
have individual utility platforms
available for their customers and also
the ones that have attempted to do a
multi-utility data platform because I
understand that for many of you this is
the first time you're hearing anything
about this project but it has been
ongoing for the full full time and the
governance Council as it is currently
constituted under the leadership of the
chief technology officer and it
development manager at
Unitil they they meet weekly so they
have a a 4 p.m. Wednesday
meeting uh to discuss all of the issues
around um where they're at right now is
they're ready to submit an RFP to find
out the cost to actually build the
project it's been speculative up to this
point and um once that RFP is returned
then the cost benefit analysis that is
also pending can be completed because
they can't do that until they have an
actual cost uh to build it but um
so let's see the bill is needing because
the initial hurdles have all been met in
the design of the requirements as
established and we need new language
that will guide um the effort
forward the process um allows for
objections from any member of the
governance Council the technical
expertise utility expertise Department
of Education expertise and the Office of
Consumer Advocates legal expertise
provide a sufficiently broad knowledge
base to approve proove project decisions
and to file rate reimbursement requests
to the Pu as with any other utility
investment to be submitted once the RFP
and cost benefit analysis are completed
and approved by the Pu the RFP is ready
to be submitted to the Pu as I had
mentioned and uh my understanding is it
only lacks sign off from the Department
of energy or it would have been
delivered today they can probably speak
to that the language that will be put
into state law uh that no util is that
no utility shall recover costs that are
not prudently incurred nor shall there
be any recovery of or on investments
that are not useful are not used and
useful that's the term used and
useful that language means that the
utilities who are charged with managing
and developing the maintenance of the
and maintenance of this project cannot
recover monies they cannot justify
through this
lens what this bill seeks to do is set
up the technical and administrative path
for the energy data Hub once a
successful RFP response is in hand and
the pending cost benefit analysis is
completed later this year it's expected
in the
fall I should say that I cannot fathom
any reason that this bill would have a
fiscal note as passing it will have no
fiscal impact the project itself has a
cost and we can talk about that later uh
when HB 723 comes up I don't want to mix
the two uh
topics um this bill merely seeks to
update statutory language so that the
governance Council can continue to
manage the technical and administrative
decision-making um because they have the
it expertise to do so it's a software
project um that was the original intent
of HB
284 and if the RFP and cost benefit
analysis proves the energy data hub's
value and that the cost is just and
reasonable then these statutory changes
to define the governance of this
software project should move forward in
the hands of the governance Council that
was defined in the original statute to
provide the leadership and Technical
expertise to manage the tool once the
original statutory specifications were
met I thought this year was the right
time uh for a transition from the public
utility commission's oversight to the
utilities um Department of energy
consumer Advocate and other energy
stakeholders who make up the governance
Council as they have been working on
this project since
2019 there is no reason for technical
oversight from the Public Utilities
Commission because the project
management is being done by uni Till's
professional it department and I'm happy
to take any
questions thank you representative McGee
for introducing this
legislation so I have a quick question
for
you they've been working on this you
testified since 2019 that's six years
yes
and I personally have kind of lost
track uh so could you explain to us why
we need to mandate the use of an online
data platform if it's something that
utilities would find useful wouldn't
they just do it on their
own thank you for the question
um the util ities in in some cases
actually have applications that they've
designed and um that allow people to
access their energy
data uh in some cases and in some states
they also have front-end apps that
people can download on their phones that
kind of thing uh what the brainchild for
the data platform was that I thought was
really interesting is the idea of having
all the utilities data so if you're
if your town skirts multiple utility
districts um or if you are trying to
look at your energy usage in general it
includes electricity and gas so it is is
basically a data Hub it's a place where
all of uh the energy from all the
participating utilities and uh their
subsidiaries in gas as well as electric
would would reside so what it does is it
enables people to slice and dice their
data into information in whatever kinds
of slices that they want so it it
broadens the ability to do planning
create grid
resiliency uh uh realize energy
efficiencies and savings because you can
actually manage what you can now measure
um I I uh was in charge of metrics years
ago and when I was in the uh Technical
Training Center at John Hancock
Financial when I first started working
there they said you're in charge of
metrics and I was like okay um but what
that basically is is taking data and
turning it into information that's
actually useful to people so um you know
managers and others will be able to
understand what they're looking at what
kind of gaps they're trying to fill and
uh what happened with this project one
of the reasons it took so long I mean we
were in covid when it first started I
was on the call for the hearing um on
March 2nd
2022 uh all of the stakeholders doe
included you know we were unanimous uh
in our presentation to the then
Commissioners um and what what happened
was my understanding is I'm not on the
go well I'm still I still get the
notices for the governance Council
meetings but I only go if I know of
something that I want to hear about so
they are very gracious to still keep me
as a member of the pack but um there was
a opportunity to secure a grip Grant um
and uh like a grid
resiliency I don't know what the acronym
stands for but um there was a call for
proposals and it was a um a competitive
Grant and those proposals were favoring
efforts that
were um Regional
grid resiliency kind of thing
so Unitil took the initiative and went
forward and asked um some of the other
states that they're already functioning
in and the other states basically in New
England if they wanted to participate
and I think everybody signed on except
maybe Vermont but anyway they they put
in a joint Grant so that took the that
sidp them for well over a year um 2023
to 2024 and they got the answer back
last year that it was a competitive uh
Grant and there were five times the
number of submissions and they didn't
get it so um yeah so that's that's what
happened it it we would have been uh
turning it around sooner than this but
what what we have and I do have handouts
that are being created upstairs which
I'll present I I want to speak on 723
obviously too because I have knowledge
about the thing um is that we have a
sort of a full set of who benefits how
they benefit user stories
and also the original legislative
objectives that we were trying to
satisfy when we were trying to develop
requirements for this tool um and there
is
currently a highlevel estimate from
dunsky based on other states that have
tools like this as to the amount of
savings that we can expect and I have
information on that to to pass out to
but we won't have the actual cost
benefit analysis to make a decision
until the fall so we we really don't
have um what it'll cost to build it
there's a lot of projections out there
and I'll just say to you I was a program
manager in a software engineering shop
at skillsoft and when the software
engineers and people who had dealt in
software on this project began
discussing how it would move forward it
was very difficult because we didn't
have a department of energy then there
was no point person which is why I
stayed with the project I I was like
somebody has to be able to articulate
what's going on here and so what was
interesting to me is that
um uh there was not anybody or there
were very few people in the state agency
infrastructure who had uh technical or
software
background and so um there was no one to
have sort of ownership for the
project and what we tried to do was
figure out a way to
satisfy the legislative language that
said that the utilities would be in
charge of building it and operating it
without a goldplated price tag from the
utilities and so we we worked on the
software side of it to say it should be
done through agile practices it should
maybe be outsourced to utility
API um companies that do this do this
all around the country right there are
several and so the RFP will be going out
to those people to sort of build the
specs um and we will know what they are
going to charge us before before that
happens so we actually think it's going
to be lower uh than the stuff that's
been projected um and I have a back of
the napkin on what it would actually
result in on people's bills because we
we have you know some information also
about how it would be charged back as a
capital expense but I don't want to go
into all that now um um and I don't even
know if I answered your question at this
[Laughter]
point I don't know
either no I do do appreciate your your
your answer thank you any additional
questions uh representative Harrington
has one yeah thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question just a
clarification uh on a couple of parts of
the bill on line 25 on page one it says
the uh governance Council operates under
a con consensus decisionmaking model
does that mean majority rules no it
means if you don't have consensus it
doesn't go okay that means unanimous yes
okay and followup yes followup okay if
if that means unanimous then when you go
over to um the second page where it
talks about um decisions of the
governance Council line uh let's just
start with line
22 uh when it's sented to by blah blah
blah blah blah and it shall be deemed to
be prudent and lawful nothing in this
paragraph shall preclude a person AG
grieved by a non-unanimous decision of
the governance Council so it sounds like
one point you're saying the decisions
have to be unanimous and another Point
you're saying if they're not unanimous
this is an outcome that you can pursue
so what happens if it's not unanimous
let's say it's 5 to one uh does that
then have is it been prudent and
lawful well I think you can probably
speak to the consumer Advocate who's a
member of the governance Council to talk
about uh how that would work in reality
I think what what the verbiage is trying
to do here is say that if someone is
opposed to any of these decisions that
are going through then they have the
option of seeking relief uh through the
commission to try and adjudicate that
followup lack of unan unanimity I could
say that okay follow up but I'm that's
why I'm confused because you said that
their consensus decision- making which
means the only decisions they can come
to is unanimously then you say if it's
not unanimous any grieved person who I
don't actually who who that is I guess
it could be any rate payer I guess um
can be agreed by a non-unanimous
decision can appeal to the to to the
commission so I it just seems like
something's not something doesn't work
right there understand and understand
what you're saying um well I think that
the consensus decision-making model is
one that was adopted by the governance
Council in order to work through the
issues that they have if they have
disagreement they try and get it to a
point where everybody can live with
whatever the decision is but again I'm
not on the council so somebody else can
probably speak to that better and I know
that um Clifton Belo will be here for
the two two o'clock event representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question sure i' actually like to follow
up on on chairman V's question because
he was asking about uh why haven't the
utilities just gone ahead and and and
done this um are there beneficiaries
other than the utilities if this thing
was really up and running I mean could
could a just a a residential consumer
use this could could uh a third party
provider use it could Community power
use it to help make decisions and there
and therefore it would be Beyond just
the benefit of the
utilities well I can speak to when this
when this went to subcommittee this is
the first official act that I had as a
representative was I got tapped to take
this Senate bill that was coming over uh
on this you know Statewide energy data
platform that nobody really understood
and they asked me if I wanted to run the
subcommittee and I ran with that
subcommittee I mean I went over to the
person whose idea this was he was
working at the time in the consumer
Advocates office but he was a former CTO
and he had been tracking Texas basically
um and there was some other states uh at
that time trying to do the same thing
which is pull all the energy data
together in order to use it for benefit
and benefit of everybody it's it they
referred to it as democratizing the data
and of course the resistance initially
was the utilities own the data so they
didn't really want to give up the
control of the data so that people would
be able to make better decisions without
going to them for that data um so that
process would be facilit ated and to
your specific question yes it would be
available uh to individuals and third
parties to municipalities to building
owners private businesses um facilities
like hospitals and University
installations so anybody that owns a
grouping of buildings or a compound
would be able to slice the data so that
they could see all of their energy usage
and they could make better decisions
about how to improve their Energy
Efficiency uh in in whatever complex
they were managing so it's something you
can't do today it's very hard to do
today because of the lack of uh access
to the
data representative reyolds has a
question thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you representative McGee for
spearheading this project for all these
years um is the is the is the big idea
behind
this
project and the vision for this shared
you know uh universally accessible
database that good Pol good public
policy and good business
decisions are based on
good data and shared understanding and
right now you
know we don't have that for the State of
New Hampshire we have all all this
everybody's energy usage data is sort of
private and Sil
you know by
utility it's nobody can nobody can get
the big picture is is the idea that by
having this system we could all have
shared more a better shared
understanding of energy usage energy
usage patterns Trends so that we could
have a more informed uh debate uh
discussion about what we're trying to do
here before you answer that question I
was goingon to say thank you for the
layup and it's a good question it is a
good good
question but I want to point out
that it's a time- wasting question in
the sense that you asked it three
times you you asked the question then
you sort of paraphrased your question
and then you asked it again and so what
I'd like all members of the committee
and I'm not I don't mean to single you
out representative re but what I'd like
all members of the committee to do is
think care about the question you want
to ask and then when I recognize you ask
that question and not repeat it
endlessly thank you Mr that's not a
criticism of you I'm I'm just just a
reminder to everybody that we need to we
need to get to the nub of what's
important about these bills and the way
we do that is asking good precise
questions that can elicit a good answer
and you probably forgot the question by
now but if you didn't you can answer it
I was going to say are you going to
paraphrase it no U thank you Mr chairman
for the clarification and thank you uh
representative reels for the question um
I actually was speaking with uh Clifton
Belo recently uh about the sort of um
the opaqueness of understanding our
energy we can't really see it uh and and
if you if you don't have access to
understanding
the totality of something you're trying
to manage it's very difficult so yes
Clarity would come from that and I told
him that the way I like to describe it
is you can't manage what you can't
measure and he said that's good so maybe
he'll use that today because he was
trying to figure out a way to say it
simply but
um data is information and at this point
we don't have a mechanism to be able to
translate our energy data into useful
information and uh we have assessments
that show that if people have the
availability of that information they
will learn how to use it um and one
additional thing that I was going to
save again for this afternoon's um
hearing but I thought I should mention
it is the last time I spoke with Unitil
who's managing the project at this point
and they're managing the RFP and all
that so they're they're sort of the
primary utility in terms of the uh
technology
project they said that they are planning
to hire an intern who's dedicated to
writing apps once the database is
available so that there will be
userfriendly simple apps um that all the
different constituents uh and I will
provide a document that shows all the
different user stories for you know from
Individual up to government and P I mean
the Pu grid resilience and grid
modernization would really benefit from
this tool as well because again
we don't have any insights into some of
the things we're trying to resolve and
the data can help us get
there okay seeing no more questions for
representative McGee whoops there's one
more representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair um this this bill appears to be
best practices for managing a heck of a
lot of data um but my question is
regarding the fiscal note uh Financial
costs seem to be misre presented on the
floor so I'd like you to confirm that
there is no fiscal note to this bill and
that you as the prime sponsor have said
that there is no fiscal impact yeah
there is a fiscal note on the bill but
I'm not sure how or why it got there
because the bill itself is about how the
governance Council would assume
responsibility uh for the platform which
has already achieved all of the things
that were in the original language and
so they would be they have been the
decisionmaker body they are the most
knowledgeable about what's going on with
the RFP and all that stuff um so while
they're still going for approval on the
RFP to the Pu and they're also going to
be going back to show that there's a
cost benefit analysis that would warrant
us doing it um those are steps that were
defined again in the original
legislation and everything else that's
in there has already been completed so
there's a full set of requirements now
that meet all the standards for security
and privacy and governance and all that
so it's just it's just a transition
Point that's what the bill is doing so
the bill doesn't have anything to do
with whether the platform gets built it
just updates the language which is
currently describing a project that
we've already fulfilled we've already
completed all of those things so they
don't need to be in language anymore
thank you you're
welcome okay so you no further questions
Let's uh find out what the consumer
Advocate has to say about
House Bill 681 Don CH welcome back good
to see you
sir uh thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record I am Donald Cree the consumer
advocate of course my job is to Advocate
on behalf of the interests of
residential utility customers and uh
taking seriously the Chairman's
admonition not to be repetitive I'm
going to try and not repeat all of the
uh very informative testimony that the
sponsor representative McGee just
offered to you uh I I do want to take
everybody back to the good old days of
2019 when uh Senate Bill 284 was uh
ultimately signed into law by Governor
cunu that was one of two energy related
bills that year that Governor cunu did
not veto and while I obviously don't
speak for governor sonunu uh I I think
the reason he didn't veto that
particular bill was because he perceived
the potential of a Statewide utility
customer data platform as one that could
Advance the policy objectives in the
state's 10-year energy plan which is to
say uh be technology neutral and
consumer
empowering uh to representative corman's
question the whole point of a Statewide
utility customer data platform like this
is to allow individual customers to
share their usage data as it's acquired
by the utilities with third parties that
can help them do cool stuff with their
energy usage and you know the experts
can tell you all that cool stuff it has
to do with everything that you can
imagine so uh the bill uh originated
with a Cooperative effort between Folks
at Unitil and folks in my office and we
proposed it at the time because I
thought that the utilities would
actually try to thwart something like
this as antithetical to the kind of
hegemony that they were trying to
perpetuate but we got the bill through
the legislature again for the reasons I
think uh I stated Governor cunu signed
the bill into law and then the utilities
uh actually surprised me by being
willing to work with us to try to
develop this thing and lo and behold uh
I would say two of the three uh major
Utilities in this state have been quite
proactive in terms of lending their
technical uh and operational expertise
to the process of answering the question
how would you build something like this
the utilities were very protective of
the back end of their data management
systems and so they wanted to make sure
that none of this would kind of sneak
into the back end of their systems and
wreak havoc with it so we were able to
satisfy the utilities and develop a sort
of programmatic concept for how to build
something like this that would protect
the utilities but still allow something
like this to develop and as a result of
the uh contested administrative
proceeding before the
puc that the original Bill mandated we
got there and we filed a settlement
agreement that the Pu ultimately
approved so why do we need this bill
well I I I think that the way it is
evolved and from my perspective the
reason that it has taken us five and a
half years to get even to where we are
today which is to say still not having
built this thing is that the Public
Utilities Commission has sort of cast
itself in the role of a I don't know a
kind of a project manager or overseer or
maybe board of directors or something
like that and I I do not mean to trash
or even criticize the Pu for having done
that the Pu has a lot of expertise that
it could contribute to that kind of
project oversight unfortunately though
that is not the reason we have a Public
Utilities Commission and it is very hard
to work with a project overseer that you
can't just call up and talk about the
project with right because we're in the
context of the contested case procedures
of the administrative procedure act
whenever we're communicating with the
Public Utilities Commission about the
data platform that's a form of
litigation and it is a very slow and
stilted and inefficient way of being
accountable to whoever your ultimate uh
substantive decider is so what this bill
does in my opinion is it restores the Pu
to its rightful role as the ultimate
decider when it comes to the prudence
and used and usefulness of utility
Investments and this will be a utility
investment if it gets built so uh when
we proposed a similar idea in the last
legislative session uh the Pu was very
critical of this idea saying that we
were trying to strip it of its Authority
that is not what this bill is
endeavoring to do this bill is
endeavoring to assure that the Pu does
exactly what the general court has
created it to do become the ultimate
watch dog when it comes to prudence and
used and usefulness of utility
Investments those three Concepts those
two concepts prudent used and useful are
the traditional F focuses of Public
Utilities Commission oversight uh
chairman Vose asked a really uh
perceptive question which is why
wouldn't the utilities do this on their
own and you know I found myself thinking
as I was listening to representative
McGee testify that if I had known they
might do it on their own I might not
have proposed this bill to begin with
because it wouldn't have taken me five
and a half years to get even to where we
are which is on the brink of being able
to put out a request for proposals I
didn't know in 20 I I thought the
opposite in 2019 that the utilities
would not do this on their own I think
the benefit of having a statutory
framework for moving forward with a
project like this is that it kind of
forced everybody to the table and it
forced the utilities not just to
collaborate with stakeholders but also
with each other that I've learned
doesn't come naturally to the U ities
it's not because they're uh obstinate or
not inherently Cooperative as people or
organizations it just doesn't come
naturally to them and it helped to have
a legislatively mandated encouragement
to have everybody come to the table the
governance Council has worked really
well and it offers I think potentially a
model for how to do other things like
this that involve collaboration among
the state's investor utilities and
others who have an interest in what the
utilities do uh and then I guess the
last thing I want to address is the
question that representative Harrington
asked about uh the sentence that begins
on line 25 on page two of the bill that
says nothing in this paragraph shall
preclude a person Agri by a
non-unanimous decision of the governance
Council from seeking relief from the
commission as otherwise provided for
under this title and of course
representative Harrington's question is
well wait a minute I thought you said
everything the governance Council has to
do has to to be unanimous and that is
true the governance Council operates by
consensus so no decision of the
governance council is effective unless
everybody agrees to it so what the
sentence in the bill that I just read uh
deals with is the situation where there
isn't a decision of the governance
Council but some member of the
governance Council who is unhappy with
the lack of consensus can then turn
around and go to the Pu and say well
wait you know the governance Council
didn't agree with my suggestion that uh
all of the um all that that the website
of the uh or the web portal of the data
platform should only have uh the colors
red white and blue on it I'd like to see
green well if you don't like that
decision then you can go to the Pu and
file a petition with the Pu and then the
Pu can basically overrule the governance
Council in that instance so it's a bit
of a safety valve for people who are
unhappy with the result of uh consensus
decision-making that said the consensus
decision-making model and the governance
Council model has overall worked really
well so this bill simply uh clarifies
and uh rewrites much of what was
originally enacted in Senate Bill 284 in
light of what has been essentially
positive experience in the five and a
half years since uh Governor cunu signed
the bill into law uh I could go on and
on this has been an important aspect of
our work over these last five and a half
years but uh again taking representative
or chairman V's admonition seriously I
think I'll stop talking there and say
that I hope you uh consider this bill as
a useful vehicle for ex for advancing
the public policy of the
state okay thank you very much
now you Amplified representative
corman's question about
customer
benefits and I asked a question of
Representative McGee along the same
lines so my question for you now is if
there is customer demand for access
to a Statewide energy data platform can
you point us to surveys or uh letters or
requests that have been received
from customers asking for this kind
of
functionality uh the governance Council
actually has submitted I believe to the
puc a uh public survey that was
conducted in the province of of Ontario
and I I know that maybe Canada isn't
that popular these days in some quarters
but the reason that became Germain is
that you know in order to really
determine whether there's customer
demand for something like this customers
have to kind of know what's possible and
what a a program like this could
actually enable so if you surveyed
customers in New Hampshire and said hey
you know if there were a Statewide
utility data C if there were a utility
customer data platform available to you
would you use it I would imagine that
99.9% of customers in New Hampshire
would say huh like what is that I I I
don't even know what is so how can I
tell you that I would use it so in other
words this is an example from a customer
perspective of unknown unknowns right so
you know you looked it appeared I
believe that there was significant
customer interest in something like this
in a place like Ontario where a program
like this has been made available to
people so you know it all depends on how
you phrase the survey questions like if
I were to ask you all as individual
customers if I told you that there were
a utility program that could be
available to you that would allow you to
hire a third party that would manage
your electricity usage for you in a
manner that would cut your electricity
bill in half like if I asked that
question I dare say you would all I
certainly would answer that question yes
would that prove irrefutably that the
data platform is going to be a success
probably not but I I hope that was at
least somewhat respons responsive to
your question well yes my followup would
be has anybody asked that question that
you know of well we have not asked that
question here in New Hampshire for the
reason that I
stated okay good additional questions
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr Cree for
taking my question um you mentioned that
we're getting close to putting out an
RFP uh do you can you give us any more
information on the timeline for when it
might go out and when proposals would we
would be coming in and then uh decided
on uh if I'm remembering correctly uh
and as representative McGee
characterized this we're still waiting
on governance Council consensus around
the language in the
RFP uh and then I think that that goes
to the puc for them to approve before we
put it out so it's a near-term item but
it's not the RFP is not going to go out
tomorrow representative Harrington has a
question yeah just referring to what you
said there with regard to page two line
item 25 you said that a member of the uh
Council if they were aggrieved could uh
challenge a non-unanimous decision to
the commission but in the in the writing
it says shall preclude shall not
preclude a person AG grieve so is this
person have to be a member of the
council or can any any person is it
obviously the any person can seek relief
from the Public Utilities Commission as
provided for under title 33 of the
state's revised statutes annotated which
is the pu's enabling statute so what
that sentence just means is that by
virtue of being a member of the
governance Council and participating in
the consensus decision-making process
you don't relinquish your right as a
person generally would have to ask the
pu by petition to either do something to
do something that's that's the import of
that language and if if there's a better
way of saying that representative
Harrington because it seems to be making
you uh uh itchy I guess I'm happy to
improve I'm I'm happy to I'm happy to
have you improve that sentence or make
another run at it follow up just quick
yeah it just seems to me that it needs
to be clarified because you're using
you're saying the the word say person
you're saying a member of the council so
somehow we have to yeah you could
substitute M of the governance Council
for person in that sentence and I think
it would maybe be more precise from your
perspective I don't think it would
change the meaning representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for being here um Mr C
can you um please estimate the number of
person hours that has been invested in
this um data
platform project since
2019 uh that's very difficult to do
because I don't work at the utilities so
I don't know exactly how many person
hours each of them has invested I will
say it would be interesting to hear what
Unitil might say about that because they
have in particular invested a great deal
of time and and as soon as I said that I
think uh my friends at eversource also
deserve a lot of Praise so I it's in the
hundreds for sure uh as among all of the
utilities our office the department of
energy and uh as representative McGee
noted you know stakeholders in the
industry meaning representatives of
innovative companies and few of them
frankly are based here in New Hampshire
uh that would be willing or eager to
come in and provide services to
customers uh of the sort that would be
facilitated by the data platform and and
by the way uh just to kind of and again
at the risk of annoying the
chairman some of it has to do with
Energy Efficiency right like if you can
you energy usage data is very helpful to
the determination of what Energy
Efficiency measures at a particular home
or business are going to be cost
effective and which are not and as I'm
sure the community power Coalition of
New Hampshire and other people in the
community power aggregation business
will tell you it's also very helpful for
aggregation programs to be able to Ping
this kind of information as to their
individual uh residents and customers so
that they can be Innovative in terms of
the service that they
provide followup followup so is it safe
to say that um if we didn't pursue this
data platform that we would be throwing
away a lot of work that has already been
done very much so yes thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank Mr CH for testifying thank
you for the opportunity and invite next
Chris Elms and Dan faen from the
Department of energy to give us their
perspective on this
[Music]
legislation good morning yeah good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record uh Deputy
Commissioner Chris Elms of the New
Hampshire Department of energy and I'm
joined by our regional policy director
Dan faen we are uh the department of
energy is neutral on House Bill 681 but
we do have a lot of concerns uh House
Bill 681 represents a a significant
change away from the existing statutory
framework for the Statewide multiuse
data platform existing statute provides
that the Pu determines whether the cost
of the platform to be recovered by
customers is unreasonable and not in the
public interest and then statute by
Statute would be able to direct the
department of energy to defer
implementation of the platform should
the Pu make that
determination uh this bill removes that
ability it shifts approval away from the
Pu and gives fiscal authority to the
data platform governance Council if this
bill were adopted the governance Council
which is a non-public entity by their
own bylaws would approve its own
expenditures deeming them prudent this
would presumably be a conclusion that
the Pu could not reverse upon review
this bill approves by Statute decisions
of the governance Council that would
otherwise be considered by the Pu at
hearing following independent review and
comment by the doe and with the
potential for public participation and
comment this bill completely removes the
transparency and process associated with
that approval in its bylaws the
governance Council has defined itself as
a private entity that is not subject to
public meeting requirements under RSA
91a at present there is no ability for
non-members of the governance Council to
learn about offer comment on or object
to any matter that comes before the
governance Council and is decided by
them indeed governance Council decisions
are not public at this time until they
are filed for review by the
Pu we uh at the department of energy
have a problem with the idea that
anything ascented to by the governance
council members is prudent we find this
extremely problematic because deeming
something prudent is up to Regulators
empowering the governance Council to
deem something prudent effectively gives
them a blank check and uh exempts
expenditures from regulatory review in a
pu proceeding the doe makes
recommendations on prudency under the
consensus model which we would we would
uh characterize as awkward uh this bill
codifies the only uh you know that this
bill would codify uh the only option
that the department of energy has had uh
you know to would to to stop you know or
to consider something we disagree with
would be to fully object and grind
everything to a halt by bringing it to
the
there's been a lot of pressure from
members of the governance Council to
ensure that that things didn't get
slowed down and uh you know folks have
brought up things like when we were
applying for federal funding uh you know
how how devastating it would be for the
ability to apply for those federal funds
if the department of Energy's
concerns uh or or possible objections
were raised and and we missed a federal
deadline uh we have been comfortable
letting some of these decisions move
forward because we knew we would later
have the ability to review them at a pu
hearing that pressure uh you know
doesn't that pressure doesn't stop us
from doing our job regardless of how
appropriate it's been and and I'm not to
say that all governance council members
have been you know inappropriate but we
certainly have had people you know make
statements like if you don't you know uh
if you don't go along with this we're
going to go to the media and say that
the governor is trying to turn down
Federal funding right and so so doesn't
stop us from doing our jobs but knowing
that we had the ability to come back
later um has has made it possible for us
to not simply just grind everything to a
halt uh at every step taking that from
the doe and the Pu now would be Ain to
the legislature simply allowing a group
of non-governmental organizations
including for-profit
companies uh from taking on the
responsibility of regulating and
approving their very own
project for us I you know I think you
know knowing that we've been tried tried
to be collaborative to let things move
forward uh it's it's hard now to see
that that sort of rug could be pulled
from us with a the legislature coming in
and just deeming everything approved
especially given the fact that there is
a multitude of information that's
considered confidential that goes into
this that this legislature hasn't yet
reviewed so uh approving this bill would
just as a matter of law codify all those
decisions you have have two data
platform bills in front of you uh it's
really up to the legislature to
determine what direction you want to
take if any uh but we do have concerns
with this bill uh I think you know if
you do pass this bill there's a real
risk that you saddle our rate payers
with a costly Endeavor and you know uh
it it might be unlikely that we see
broad-based benefits for a long time
governance council members have
financial and ideological incentives to
get this across the line this bill would
strip any sort of reasonable regulatory
review and uh sort of I guess as a
threshold matter I think this bill is a
move away from transparency it's away
from accountability and it uh tries to
empower unelected bureaucrats and
financially interested special interests
to advance their agendas at repair
questions so we do have questions um my
first question
is there is a fiscal note attached to
this bill and the department was charged
with coming up with um a response to the
fiscal note request has the department
done so yet and is there anything you
could share with us sure and and what I
saw online uh so you know the way the
fiscal Pro note process works is the LBA
will send a questionnaire on bills that
they think might have a fiscal note we
fill out the questionnaire answer the
question so uh that that should be
online I don't have it in front of me oh
it has been completed though yeah yes I
do and I do have that in front of me um
and it it has an an estimated upfront
cost of between 4.6 million and 7
million with ongoing costs of 272,000 to
416,000 that's our estimate of how much
the data platform will take to get up
and continue to
operate well that's a significant chunk
of money so I guess we need to see that
fiscal note I will um talk to the uh the
clerk's office to see if we can get a
copy do you know when that fiscal note
was
completed uh I can find out for you Mr
chairman okay thank you all right uh
questions representative Vice chair
Thomas has a question uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question very simple question since you
mentioned one of your concerns was
given today are you absolutely sure that
you would be receiving Federal funding
uh Dan can correct me if I say anything
wrong but thank you that's a good
question uh there were two two
applications for federal funding uh that
have come in on this process um under
one of the iig or IRA funding sources uh
the feedback from the Department of
energy both both applications were
rejected the feedback is public in the
do it uh there was significant
difficulties associated with it so no we
we have not been awarded any federal
funding and I'll let Dan add to that
yeah that's correct it was uh the grid
res grid resiliency and Innovation
program uh opport funding opportunity um
and
yes additional questions representative
schneller has
one thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr RS for your testimony
um you had said and this will require
quick followup the department is neutral
on this bill I think you it
said yes we're neutral uh quick followup
yes go ahead thank you uh it sounds like
the department would be relinquishing
where this to go forward a fair amount
of regulatory Authority and I'm just
wondering how that uh ties out with the
uh the position of neutrality the New
Hampshire legislature is perfectly at
will to dictate uh how how these things
would proceed so you know we want to you
know know you to know you can you can do
this if you want to we would have
concerns associated with some of the
regulatory review but um that's that's
within the legislature's perview thank
you representative McGee has a question
yeah this is just a clarification of a
question that already happened it it
says on the top of whoops I made a
mistake you uced you introduced this
bill I did but it's it's regarding the
fiscal impact because it says right here
the bill does not have provide funding
nor does it authorized new POS there is
no fiscal impact to this bill because
this is not initiating we haven't seen
the fiscal note so this there's a fiscal
note on 681 as I have it printed and
it's the same fiscal note that's on the
bill that's coming up later okay well
when the rest of us have access to the
same information you do we can discuss
that
representative Harrington has a question
yeah this is a question on the
delegation of authority it it it says
that the um the council uh decision
shall be deemed by the department of
commission to be prudent and lawful so
I'm I'm trying to figure out how this
works so because Senate turns around and
says you can you can appeal to the to
the uh commission so is that mean that
the Commissioners have to then sign this
as an order or they just don't do
anything anything I'm I'm kind of
confused here this thing it seems like
this non-elected group is going to have
at least some of the authority we now
give to the commission so I would I
would uh defer to attorneys just on the
on the just to be 100% sure but uh you
know my reading of that would be that if
the governance Council ascents to a
decision unanimously that decision will
have the force of being determined to be
prudent uh you know by the Public
Utilities Commission when the utilities
go in for a rate recovery
follow up so the Commissioners then
would be forced to accept that whether
they agreed with it or not that's my
understanding okay thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair I am very
confused about your fiscal uh uh notes
and your your estimations so we're
looking at two bills and you're saying
if we keep the data platform it's 4.6
million as a cost and then in House Bill
723 if we get rid of it it's 4.6 million
to 7 million to get rid of it so what
are you saying if we keep it or if we
don't keep it it's going to cost New
Hampshire 4.6 million minimum that
doesn't make any sense to me at all
thank you so uh I'll let Dan answer that
I uh I don't have the other bills fiscal
note in front of me uh either um but
again we fill out questionnaires uh that
are well we don't need discuss to
discuss the other Bill's fiscal note
because that's not the subject of this
hearing yeah so I have I have before me
listing between uh the initial cost
estimate listing between 4.6 and 7
million and that's just a portion of the
total costs related to the data platform
um that's where we believe the initial
backend upgrades will uh will will come
to after that there's going to be
additional cost to build and operate the
platform itself because there are
different pieces here there's the the
data platform which talks to the utility
backend systems they all have to be made
to speak the same language um those are
our cost estimates for for those pieces
at this time followup followup so does
this bill I'm talking about 681 does
this bill have a
cost we've provided the cost estimate of
a prudently of of something that would
be determined as prudent by the the by
the governance Council that's our
our the danger we see and and to add to
that you know this bill would would take
away the ability for the Pu to determine
whether or not those costs were
unreasonable uh and then instruct you
know that would they would have then
ability to instruct us to defer the
implementation of the
platform representative bney has a
question thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question the 4.6
million to 7 million is that uh the
total for all the utilities or is that
each individual utility and then the
same question with the uh maintening M
maintenance and operation costs uh and
then last question so this is just the
utility portion it doesn't include
anything related to the actual data
platform that's separate that is correct
this is the estimated cost for all three
utilities together um so not not
individually 7 million each but up to um
and this does not include cost for the
data platform
itself representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for being here apart from the Govern
governance issue and the cost would you
agree that the basic concept here is a
good
one the the basic concept of the data
platform
affirmative I don't think it's my place
to tell you whether or not it's a good
thing it's been directed by the
legislature and so we are here to you
know implement the statute thank you for
your answer thank you Mr chair
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
gentlemen uh in terms of the governance
and role of the puc on page two
line four I'm reading for purposes of
rate regulation the department and the
commission should treat Investments
approved by the governance Council no
differently than other Investments for
inclusion in the utility rate base
does that not give the puc and the
department oversight over the just and
reasonableness of any investment
incurred by a you know data a data
platform thank you for the question and
it's a good one uh it's in the
legislative findings and should is a
word that says it would you know we we
should do that um if you look further
down page two starting on line 22
through lines 25 decisions of the
governance Council when ascented to by
the members of the governance Council
shall be deemed by by the department and
the commission to be prudent and lawful
so uh the reading of that is that
anything that's ascented to by the
governance Council would would de facto
make the the Pu consider it
prudent thank
you
okay representative reels has a question
thank you Mr
chairman since
the governance Council was established
pursuant to a sounds like extensive pu
proceeding and Order and since the
council
operates you know established itself and
and decisions must be made by 100%
consensus isn't that a pretty high bar I
mean isn't that a pretty
um give folks assurance that the
decisions that they make are going to be
good and in the interest I mean sounds
like we're guarding against
yeah I'll just leave it there thank you
ask it once so I I do appreciate the
question and and it's a good one you
know the the the model and it's not to
say that the model is is imperfect or
perfect or anything like that but the
model was built in light of the statute
including that pu review at the end to
ensure that reasonableness so removing
that that Safeguard in that was this
whole thing was built in the context of
concern all right I don't think I think
we've heard the last word on this
subject because the first bill we're
going to discuss after uh this afternoon
is another bill related to the data
energy platform but I think we're fun
done for this morning so I want to thank
everyone and uh I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill
681 and I'm going ask everyone in the
room to please exit so that the
Republican caucus uh can uh have a
meeting so thank you and we'll see
1:00
e
okay good afternoon everybody time to
resume activity for science technology
and energy for Monday the 10th of
February for those of you who are
waiting for public hearings on three
bills we will start those public
hearings at 2:00 not
1:00 from now until 2:00 we will be
conducting executive sessions on bills
heard
previously so if you need to go make a
phone call or something Now's the Time
to do
it all right so let's begin by opening a
an executive session on House Bill
FN
which prohibits offshore wind energy
infrastructure and I'm going to move itl
on this legislation and I recognize
representative
bery I second
that so the reason we're going to move
itl on this bill is
we endorse the concept of restricting
offshore wind development until all the
scientific and other questions or
economic questions are answered
answered but we don't feel this
bill passes muster for doing that
correctly this bill prohibits legitimate
business
activity this bill could have serious
constitutional questions as it and
federalism questions because it
interferes with furk and with bom and
possibly other federal
agencies this bill is kind of redundant
to a bill that we pre uh passed
previously or two two bills that we
passed previously
actually and we we believe that this
bill will lead to a lot of potential
lawsuits States like Massachusetts and
Connecticut and Rhode Island suing New
Hampshire for being obstructionist when
it comes to Offshore wind so as a result
of all that we believe that itl is the
best solution for this legislation
future com further comments Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr
chairman I concur with the chair's
analysis although I am a firm believer
that we should not have any offshore
wind here uh in in this state or in our
fishing territory until questions are
answered and answerers
satisfact I uh support wholeheartedly
the the New Hampshire Fisherman's
concerns that there are issues out there
that are unanswered there are
environmental concerns coming from
potential cooling stations uh seabed uh
disturbances um marine life there are a
lot of questions to be answered before
we allow offshore wind however this bill
as the chairman has said is written in
such a way that there's a
constitutional uh issue there there's
the the the restrictions mentioned uh
the bill is worded in many ways that can
cause us a lot of problems the intent of
the bill is great if it had just said we
ban it but it goes on to to produce a
lot more information and also eliminates
uh a few um departments that maybe we
don't want eliminated so unfortunately
this bill is not ready and so therefore
I I have to support
itl further
discussion representative nder thank you
Mr chairman and I agree with everything
you said um I am going to be voting
against the itl but not um to be a pain
I just the fisherman came out and their
story really resonated with me and so my
vote against the itl is for
discussion see none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of the
adoption of the motion of itl for House
Bill 575
FN by sh
Thomas yes representative ner no
representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative par
yes representative Kaplan yes
representative
Thomas okay sorry representative Corman
yes representative rolds yes
representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman of
oose
yes 16 to
one by a vote of 16 to one the committee
adopts the resolution of
itl for House Bill
575 FN I will write the committee report
will there be a Minority Report no sir
consent without objection we'll put this
itl representative
Swanson just question Mr chair
uh still a bit new to the process but
I'm curious were there are any uh blue
sheets or online voting regarding this
that we could
record I do not know uh I'm sure there
probably were but they're irrelevant to
an executive session at this point all
right
so with no further discussion of this
bill needed we'll close the executive
session on House Bill did it go on
consent yeah yes there was no objection
so it's on consent
so we've closed that public that
executive session and now we will open
an executive session on House Bill
654 FN which is a bill relative to
allowing small customer generators the
ability to participate in group net
metering and I recognize representative
Bernardi I move itl on this bill
recognize representative Summers I
second that motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt the motion of itl for House Bill
FN I
recognize representative
[Music]
bernardy thank you Mr chair yes uh itl I
believe is appropriate because this sets
up potential double dipping on net
metering and we had both the doe and the
Pu to comment on that and oppose the
bill so with that I'm
it's makes sense to move
on further discussion representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman uh as we
know I was the Prime sponsor on the bill
uh and I was unable to participate
because of illness um I know there was
some question about the intent of the
bill and the intent was that somebody
who would have say some panels on their
house would also be able to be uh in a
nit metering group as one of the people
receiving benefits from an off-site um
uh
installation uh I heard a lot about the
double dipping I don't quite understand
how that's double dipping that said I'm
not going to die on this hill and um
I'll vote against the motion but I I
understand
representative Swanson just on
the just a comment as far as the double
dipping I don't see where that's an
issue I don't understand how it could be
accomplished I use net metering myself
so it it that argument doesn't make
further further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl on house bills 654
FN vice sh Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Brey yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan
yes representative uh Corman
no Representative rolds
no representative La relle
no representative Swanson no chairman
Vose
yes okay um one two three four five six
s eight n 10 11 12 two one two three
by a vote of 12 to5 the committee adopts
the motion of itl for House Bill 654 FN
representative Bernardi will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report yeah I guess so represent
representative Corman will write The
Minority
Report and I need that by close of
possible contact me if it's not
possible okay with no further business
to do on that bill I'm going to close
the exec session on House Bill
654 next we'll open an exec session on
House Bill
541 establishing a committee to study
energy and Telecommunications
infrastructure
survivability and
resiliency and I recognize
representative Shel schneller for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move itl
on HB 541 recognize representative
Matson I second the motion please moved
and seconded that we adopt the motion of
itl on HB 541 I recognize representative
schneller
to Mr chairman uh this bill as proposed
represents a broad and lofty goal to say
the least and all by November 1st of
2025 five Mr LC from eversource uh
paraphrasing uh said that while the
prime sponsor representative McFarland
was certainly eloquent in his
presentation eversource has established
an active efforts ongoing in not less
than eight state and federal agencies
each charged individually with what this
bill is proposing they're charged uh
with reviewing and executing varying
plans for energy infrastructure to
ensure survivability and resilience
as this bill would have it direct Mr
Lata also suggested that the same
activity is happening with the within
the executive branch he spoke of
hardened and soft redundancies ongoing
cyber security policies and procedures
to protect and resuscitate critical
systems in the event of partial or total
failure given the above the committee
whose formation is contemplated in HB
541 would have such abroad and nebulous
task before it that I suspect the only
resulting report would consist of inac
in actionable vagaries on subject and
issue matters that are in great detail
already being
addressed so while well intended I
recommend that the members vote to itl
HB
541 further
discussion representative McGee I'll
just say I can concur with all of those
points I think we kind of felt the same
way about about it further discussion
representative Corman thank you yeah I
think representative schneller uh said
it quite articulately um my notes uh say
that uh Mr Lata mentioned several
departments uh dealing with security
meters operations Data Systems
communications supply chains and I
forget what else but there was a lot
going on already at
eversource further
discussion representative
Summers well I was in favor of this and
I'm really interested in cyber security
and where it's going for the state I did
feel that this was too broad myself and
I look forward to hopefully another bill
coming up more defined in particular to
a particular uh item so I'll be voting
the
same further discussion Vice chair
Thomas just I agree with everyone here
the report uh time is too sure for a
report that has such vast amounts of
data to to collect in agency to work
with so I agree with
itl further
discussion seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
for House Bill
541 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
uh Corman yes representative rolds yes
representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman oos
yes
170 by a vote of
170 the committee adopts the motion of
itl
for House Bill 541 repres resentative
schneller will write the committee
report without objection it'll go on the
consent
calendar hearing no
objections it's destined for the consent
calendar and with that we close the
executive session on House Bill
541 moving right along we'll now open an
executive session on House Bill 224
FN and
I recognize uh representative ner to
pretend to Pro uh produce an amendment
or introduce an amendment thank you Mr
2025-the
innovation rebates ourf Monies to rate
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um I think we're all concerned
with lowering energy costs and that's
part of the reason that we have a
renewable energy fund I think the
testimony that we heard during the
hearings was um opposing uh the collapse
of the fund and we recently received uh
all of us received a bulleted list from
Heidi crawl um regarding uh some of the
key points points in those remarks from
Granite State Hydro Power
Association um and the value of the
rebates program excuse me representative
could I inter interrupt you for just a
second sure I apparently I forgot to
obtain a second for a motion of the
adoption of this amendment so I
recognize representative
PL I I'll second the amendment okay
thank you so now it's official you can
continue your discussion sorry to
interrupt thank you so so on the changes
uh I'd like to understand a little bit
the changes in the language uh in the
amendment from the original bill because
I see the bolded language it's
um let's see it says all pay starting on
line 12 it says all payments to be made
under this section shall be deposited in
the fund any remaining monies paid into
the fund under paragraph two of this
section and then it crosses out excludes
Class 2 Monies shall be used by the
department of energy to support thermal
and electric renewable energy
initiatives and offshore wind
initiatives including the office of
offshore wind industry development and
energy Innovations then it goes on to
cross out class two monies shall
primarily be used to support Solar
Energy Technologies in New Hampshire all
initiatives supported out of these funds
shall be subject to audit by the
department of energy as deemed necessary
and then it adds language in bold that
says that are inaccess of administration
costs funding for the office of offshore
wind industry development and energy
Innovation and incentive payments shall
be re rebated to all retail electric
rate payers in the state on a per
kilowatt hour basis in a timely manner
to be determined by the
commission
so
uh I'm just trying to figure out it it
sounds like we are saying that this is
going to save people money but we have
an RF report that we get each year
telling us how much of that funding is
going out the door to help us invest in
projects that lower rates for everybody
so we will no longer have that dedicated
non-aps fund um which you know was
designed the money was designed not to
be moved somewhere else or used for some
other purpose right it was a dedicated
about the fact that it would be BAS
basically uh eliminating a fund that has
a specific purpose that is actually
beneficial to the state of New
discussion representative
reels thank you Mr chairman um I would
also like to take issue with the
sponsors characterization that um
changing the renewable energy fund to
Simply Be uh passing
through Pass ing back most of the money
back to rate payers would be saving them
money um again referring to my ranking
members uh she just mentioned the the
report from the Department of energy
that shows how that money has been spent
over the years and how many uh new
installations of behind the meter
solar that that fund has
supported um we all were told here in
the first couple of weeks the session we
were shown by ISO New
England how much of a
contribution to lowering Demand on the
grid every day of the
year uh all the behind the meter solar
makes uh sure that varies dayto Day
based on the length of the day and the
amount of sunshine but all that behind
the meter
solar the area between the on the duck
curve graph if you all remember uh is
dramatically reducing Demand on the grid
every day and that is reducing electric
costs for all rate payers so you know
the
uh the law that we have and the purpose
of this fund talks about investing you
have to invest to reap benefits and this
is a
successful program that has spurred
investment and saved rate payers and
continues to save rate pays a lot of
money if we cut the legs out from under
it we're going to be making a foolish
decision further discussion
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman we're discussing the amendment
now is that correct that is correct okay
as I read it the amendment all it's
doing is adding in a carve out um for
the office of offshore wind industry
development and energy
Innovation um so that their funding from
the RF is not cut am I correct about
that you are indeed so so even even if I
want to keep the RF I would also want to
keep funding for the office of energy
Innovation so I would probably vote for
the amendment but then against the
underlying
Bill representative Kaplan has a qu a
comment yeah I mean uh thank you Mr
chair I would I would agree with uh
representative corman's assessment of of
the amendment and it is an improvement
however I just want to piggyback on some
of the previous comments and and add
that uh you know by by eliminating this
fund and and the projects that it has uh
that it has helped over the years that
that would also be hurting many
municipalities many towns across the
state whose uh whose property taxpayers
would definitely appreciate the ability
to continue lowering operating cost of
things such as high schools and
municipal buildings based on these
discussion representative migy thank you
Mr chairman um I went back searching I I
like to parenthetically say because I'm
crazy over the weekend I went and looked
up uh some former RF reports that I had
I have the one from October 2023 in
front of me and on page 19 there's a
table of the cumulative rebate program
results through June 30th of
2023 and there's also a graph on that
page that shows that the RF expenditures
are 11% of what goes into some of the
Investments that have been made in New
Hampshire and 89% of the funding for
those projects comes from applicant
investment so it is an incentive program
absolutely but what we're getting in
terms of on this chart it says that the
rebate funds dispersed were
$39,100 this is cumulative rebates to
date but the aggregate applicant
investment was 325,000 some on dollars
so what we're getting is we're getting
an outsized benefit for this small
amount of money that is being made
available through the state in order to
just incentivize people to make the
Investments work and I you know I think
it's a Pennywise pound fool thing to say
that we would take away something that
really costs people pennies in order to
uh do away with a program that allows
for this type of private investment or
encourages this type of private
investment because we all benefit from
this private investment in uh in local
sustainable energy projects on this
particular table the RF rebate program
here it says it's by um by category and
they have residential electric renewable
energy with PV and wind residential
solar for water heating residential wood
pellet boilers and furnaces uh
commercial and Industrial Solar
Technologies electric and thermal so
those are a lot of times roof
installations and uh cni wood pellet
boiler furnaces these are all
Investments we want people to make
because it it lowers demand
and you know we're trying to eliminate
or shap gave Peak because the peak in
our Electric System is where the high
prices um Peak and uh if we can shave
those Peaks we can have uh more stable
pricing so there's there's a lot of
value in this program that we don't
generally discuss in this committee
although I do believe the people who
came to the hearing for 224 did try to
inform us of the value of this program
but just the graph that shows that 89 %c
of the money that's being used is
private investment right it it says that
it's uh that we're making really good
dollars it would be fascinating to know
how much of that 89% of private
investment would have been made anyway
even if this incentive wasn't available
I mean if you offer people money free
money they're going to take it whether
they need it or not so there's there's
no evidence that says that without these
incentives that any of that investment
would not
discussion representative
Swanson so I I do concur with
representative McGee on this matter as
far as the return on investment and I
believe if the citizens of the state or
the rate payers of the state knew what
this was for and what you that it was
actually going to toward investing in
Greater resilience in their energy
Supply and Electric Supply and that
there were actually Investments being
made and whether you can draw a straight
line between that or argue about whether
those would have been made anyway I
think that the encouragement to do it is
is there and I believe that uh that
would be the case they would support it
so uh yeah
I'm I believe this is itl further
discussion representative par thank you
chair um I've been listed to my
constituents and I'm looking at economic
stability with diverse uh Energy
Services that's one of their
concerns uh fossil fuels uh are
predicted to be is within possibly short
as 30 years uh be totally expended we
need something that's going to be more
reliable than fossil fuels and less
volatile and also many of my
constituents have uh voiced health
concerns over ing fossil fuel and how it
decreases our gross national product and
with 10 to1 on average opposition to
constituents further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of
amendment
I CH Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative
parshall the motion is to t l no adop
the amendment oh adopt the amendment uh
yes
yes representative Kaplan yes
representative
Thomas oh she's not here representative
Corman yes representative rolds
yes representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman Vose
yes
170 by a vote of
170 the committee adopts Amendment
2088 H and the chair now recognizes
representative n for a motion thank you
Mr chairman on House Bill 224 I move
ought to pass as amended chair
recognizes representative
PL thank you yes I'll second that
amendment to to
bill representative Vice chair Thomas
thank you Mr chairman um uh now is the
appropriate time to talk about the uh
amendment in terms of monies being given
back to our Rays all I can say is we
have very little control over a lot of
the cost of our electric bills because
we can't control the cost of the actual
energy rirs our constituents my
constituents expect us to do something
to keep some to keep the the uh electric
bills low however small that we can
contribute I believe we owe it to our
constituents to at least show them that
we are doing something to to reduce the
electric bills because everything as you
know is just too high this is just it's
a small way of showing it but it is a
way of showing that that we are doing
something so I support this bill asot
paa representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and uh I I
would just beg to differ with the
characterization this as a small bill I
think it's a it's a it's a large step in
the wrong direction in terms of
the detriment to our state's economy and
and the businesses that will be
disadvantaged by us pulling the rugs out
from under them like this U I also think
it's going to be detrimental to our
towns and our municipalities that uh
whose operating costs have been allowed
to go down because of some of these
projects uh I think the small savings is
is a is a Pennywise pound foolish uh way
of approaching uh and it also panders to
people as if as if they they can't tell
that the wo is being pulled over their
eyes by someone telling them oh you're
going to save a couple Pennies on your
bill but this is going to destroy your
you know your property taxes are
probably going to end up going up that
that that's that's clearly a scam so I
will be voting against this further
discussion representative
McGee thank you Mr chair I I mean I'm
always a fan of Do no harm and trying to
figure out what we're actually doing it
may feel good to be able to say to
people we're doing something to save you
money on your bill but the renewable
energy fund as I mentioned earlier is a
continually appropriated dedicated
non-aps fund that is funded with
alternative compliance payments those
payments are the utilities obligation to
provide energy that is a certain
percentage clean from clean sources uh
or from renewable sources um and so my
question is if we eliminate this
dedicated fund that is funded by
alternative compliance
payments what does it do uh in terms
of maintaining the stability of our
position on having
25% of our energy from clean sources is
that going to also be tanking that
commitment because that is what's is
still in statutory language in terms of
further discussion I would remind
members that even though the
utilities make alternative compliance
payments those payments actually come
out of our pockets because the utilities
recover those costs from rate payers
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman um we we have this comment from
Heidi croll that says as a general
principle dedicated funds should not be
used for purposes for which they were
not established or intended and I agree
with that so call me oldfashioned but I
think that the renewable energy fund
should be used to support oh I don't
know renewable
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of adop of U the adoption
of otpa on House Bill 224 FN
Vice chair Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parall no representative Kaplan no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no
representative La relle no
yes okay it's
eight yeah 10 to seven by a voted 10 to7
the committee adopts the mo motion of
ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 224 FN
representative nter will write the
majority report who will write The
Minority Report
I will Mr chairman and might I just add
I just happened to look up the online
opposed okay so representative McGee
will write The Minority
Report and that concludes our business
on House Bill 224 FN so I'll close that
executive session and we have one more
piece of work to do here so I'll open an
executive session on House Bill 46
6fn relative to utility investments in
distributed distributed energy resources
Harrington I move itl on this bill I
recognize representative Summers I
second that motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl for
House Bill 460 FN I recognize
representative herring
well I mean it's pretty straightforward
I this bill is attempting to do stuff
that's under the purview of the Pu and
they're looking at it right now a lot of
this so the topics are being reviewed
there and we ought to wait until we see
what the results are before we start
making changes uh they're doing a
detailed analysis of it which we really
don't have the wherewithal to do here so
I would suggest the put this it Al for
now and if you just satisfied with what
the Pu does come back next uh next year
with a with a similar bill
further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chair yeah I I hear that um that
point of view and so it's a chicken of
the egg thing I think um the point of
the bill is to say these are the items
that should be considered at the Public
Utilities Commission and it it is
clearly in the purview of the
legislature to define those things in
statute that should come in into
consideration um that perhaps are not
being discussed um so I I think we had
hearings in order to get that input as
to whether there was individual push
back on aspects of the bill that would
be inappropriate for consideration at
the Public Utilities Commission so I
would still argue that the language that
was provided in
460 is
um uh would be relevant and would be
helpful and useful to have there it's
not um uh it's not a question of who
who's defining what it's a question of
what needs to be defined and the bill
was attempting to bring forth the things
that are perhaps not getting adequate
consideration in some of those pu uh
discussions so it was trying to clarify
that point that was the whole that was
the whole point of it further discussion
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman I think in general it's
important for us to bear in mind that we
are the legislator and all the authority
that the Pu has is derived from statute
passed by the legislature so if we think
that it is a good idea for these items
to be included in the pu's deliberations
and I see no harm in saying that
explicitly to make sure that that is
what they
discussion seeing none wh representative
McGee well the last thing I would say is
based on the conversation uh we just had
about what the bill is intending to do
and where the authority probably should
lie uh I would ask that we consider
voting against the
itl so I might as well say that before
we
discussion representative Matson do you
have your hand up no
all right seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the question on the call the
role rather on the question of itl for
dfn MCE chair Thomas yes representative
nder yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
bernardy yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas no representative
Corman no
no Representative rolds no
representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman Bose
yes 10 to eight by a vote of 10 to8 the
committee adopts the motion of itl for
House Bill 40-
FN representative Harrington will and I
think already has written the majority
report will there be a Minority Report
yes there will by me representative
McGee will write The Minority
Report and if I could have those please
by tomorrow at close of business I'd
appreciate
that and with that we will close the
executive session on
House Bill 460 FN and we'll be able to
get to work here in just a few minutes
on a couple of public hearings but
before we do that we'll take a break and
I will remind anyone who is sitting in
the room that if you intend to
testify on the bills coming up after
2:00 that I need a pink card so we're
going to be hearing House Bill 723
repealing the multi-use data energy
platform 672 to allow offgrid
electricity providers in New Hampshire
and 690 FN directing the department of
energy to investigate the state's
withdrawal from isoo England and other
strategy decisions that impact rate
payers in relation to New England's
Environmental Policy so we will see you
at 2 o'clock thank
you
e
looking at what I liked about the AI
responses is they give a really
comprehensive answer on what categories
you know they outline it all what
categories uh there would be Savings in
uh and how they would be derived so um
curious
e
okay 2 o'clock time to resume our
business for the day so I'm going to
open a public hearing on House Bill 723
dfn repealing the multi-use data energy
platform and I call to uh introduce the
bill representative Lex Lex bney of
Grafton
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee my name is Lex bney and I
represent Grafton District 11 thank you
for the opportunity to introduce HB 723
FN repealing the multi-use energy data
platform which is covered in RSA 37850
through
54 uh so we've had a presentation
earlier um but just to kind of give a
very high level explanation the
Statewide multi-use energy data platform
is a very complex
uh and large software project with
moving with many moving pieces so it
envisions a state managed Central
database of energ use data and then it
requires each of the utilities to
develop software that can feed data from
their internal system into the state
manage Central
database since the passage of this law
six years ago there has been two
attempts to get Federal funding from the
Biden Administration both unsuccessful I
was not able to get a copy of the
rejections but the department of energy
shared with me some of the reasons for
rejection including uh one does not
adequately build a case that the
proposed project will lead to proposed
benefits the project impact may be
unrealistic and does not justify the
Project's economic
viability and the department of energy
able able to provide more details uh
when they
testify so the issue I see with the
project can be broken down into two
parts one part is related to ownership
and cost and the other part is related
to operations and
benefits uh on ownership I'd like to
read a short exerpt from comments
submitted by representative McGee to the
puc docket for this project this is in
response to a question about
stakeholders quote the fact that there
is no owner from the state at this
juncture is a huge roadblock and what
will be a fairly complex and Technical
undertaking without informed technical
oversight from the state leading the
project it will be unlikely to succeed
end quote I totally agree with the
sentiment that an owner is needed to
sheer this project this makes sense but
I disagree with the premise that the
state can or should fill this role this
kind of complex and ambitious project
should really be owned by a software
company that can better balance costs
versus requirements to meet Market needs
uh New Hampshire Department of energy
isn't a tech startup it doesn't have the
extra Personnel nor the resources to be
a tech
startup at the previous Bill hearing I
heard that unitel is currently taking on
this role and if that's the case perhaps
we don't need this law unitel with other
utilities can and should take the lead
uh the project and lead the project as
any other capital
investment uh as far as cost we still
don't really know what the total cost
will be especially the cost to build the
data Hub which is separate from the
utility portion uh the fiscal notes
estimates the cost for for just the
utility portion is 4.6 to7 million with
then ongoing operational costs of under
half a
million the federal government twice
judged the project to lack economic
viability but let's say that department
of energy hires new staff to run this
project the funding materializes The Hub
is built and the project goes live there
are still many issues un
questioned the entire platform is opt in
for the utility customer and it's not
clear what incentives folks will have to
opt in without clear incentive or
benefits most people are not likely to
opt in my understanding is that without
a large number of customers joining the
data will not be as valuable the
marketing and user acquisition abilities
to solve this problem are the better
bread and butter of software startups
and where a lot of them end up failing I
don't see how the government would do a
better job in this but let's assume that
somehow we get enough customers to opt
in and we reach our useful critical mass
the next is is will be granularity of
data the massive massive major majority
of customers in New Hampshire have
meters that only report monthly usage
totals and not the better Ami Smart
Meters that provide hourly data so is
the limited data still valuable enough
to entice participation and thus cover
the cost of the platform uh that's an
open
question if there are business customers
willing to pay for this level of data
then presumably they could just fund the
project now uh um as an example from
another
department the Secretary of State office
last month put out an RFP for a um a
registration system which reads quote
the state does not have funds available
for this project funds shall be
generated through an appropriate
registration and annual fee which
vendors shall address in their response
end quote as a taxpayer this is the best
RFP I've ever read and I like this
approach if the project is economically
viable let the market figure how to
build it and fund it the state can
oversee it at arms length and endorse it
when it's up and running the same could
be done for this data
platform last point on the data Hub
itself before I wrap up I'm a customer
customer of New Hampshire co-op and they
provide a portal where I can log in to
view hourly usage data this all works
without a Statewide data Hub and as a
customer I don't see why I would opt in
to additionally share my data with
another database or want to pay to build
out such a database it may be reasonable
to have rate payers cover the cost to
upgrade the utilities internal systems
to provide similar experience as New
Hampshire co-op and each utility can
make that case to the Pu on the other
hand the Statewide data Hub seems
primarily geared towards business and
organizations and so they should cover
that cost not the rate
payers I know people have put a lot of
effort into this project and I'm sorry
to be the bearer of bad news but to
quote the fed this project is just not
economically viable it's best that we
cut our losses now and and concentrate
on areas where the department of energy
and the utilities are more aligned to
make progress on clearer goals such as
modernizing their internal software and
upgrading to Ami
meters once a significant amount of
useful data actually exists and enough
businesses are willing to pay for it I
believe the market will provide
solutions to this problem more
efficiently without legislation in
conclusion if this repeal passes this is
where we may go next one last year
Massachusetts passed a bill to require
the utilities to build out a similar
project
it makes sense to have a bigger state
with deeper Pockets lead the way on this
two before we spend money on more
software projects we need to assess the
existing software mod modernization
efforts at each utility some of you may
recall last term there was a buil to
change net meeting rebate from annual to
semiannual and one of the utilities
testified that it could take as much as
a million dollars to implement this
accounting change why is that I'll be
willing to sponsor legislation to dig
into this issue and the general issue of
software modernization at
utilities and lastly we need to have a
lot more data to justify the expense of
building a data platform how do we
incentivize utilities to
cost-effectively upgrade to Ami metering
so that there is data to put on a
platform thank you and I will take
answer any
questions thank you excellent bill in
introduction I appreciate you doing that
a lot of good work there questions from
the committee representative McGee has a
question thank you and thank you
representative bery for taking my
question so you um I think you covered a
lot of things that one would cover if
they were sort of on the outside looking
in right so my question is do you have
any insights into the uh expertise or
Talent levels of the members of the
governance Council and the people that
have been involved in developing the
solution I do
not so followup followup I guess the
question question would be I you you
mentioned several things that you
thought should be considered and I I
guess my question would be do you have
any information that they have not been
considered in other
words how do you reach your conclusions
about how the
project has been
run I don't recall making any
conclusions about how the project is run
well you may I respond go ahead clarify
your question clarify so you mentioned
that you had heard about um the federal
government rejecting the the regional
plan that was submitted for the grip
Grant and you
quoted uh a a phrase from the denial and
used it to infer that there was
something that wouldn't work about the
program or that it was non economically
viable I think is what what you said um
so I just wonder H how much information
you have about that in order to make
that allegation against the data I'm
told so representative can you give us a
little uh a bit about your background in
software development and uh working for
startups Etc so I've been a software
developer for 25 years now I worked for
uh for federal government contractor for
10 years and then for
um private companies for the last 15
years okay so you know a lot about
software development and developing
particularly Government Contracting
software excellent additional questions
representative Thomas has a question uh
Wendy
Thomas
is okay um
several times you quoted um the the feds
in denying this or saying something uh
about this program could you please
provide pointers or printouts of those
objections so that we can verify them
and check the context in which they were
made I would love to except I could not
get them myself I my understanding is
they're confidential so
followup followup then how on Earth did
you how are you able to quote them if
you have wer I was given some excerpts
from or or explanations of what was in
them in the
rejection Department of
energy we will be hearing from the
Department shortly so you can ask
further questions
there representative Swanson has a
question for you thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative Bry
uh good discussion and uh but it I
having trouble are you saying that to
accomplish the goal of providing a
publicly
beneficial uh uh data capability which
you know data is probably individually
managed by the utilities but this would
be a comprehensive state level public
one but that somehow this would be
better done by a software startup why
would a St software startup have the
initiative or the s of to do this on
their own sure so uh just to
differentiate um from a customer's
perspective let's say Unitil or or New
Hampshire co-op or or ever Source when
you log in to your portal you get some
information there so that part is done
by the utility themselves and in the
case of New Hampshire co-op they
actually give you your hourly usage data
on on their online portal um so that
part makes sense for the utilities to
make the case to to the Pu and and and
build it out or upgrade or whatever um
with the the data Hub that's more of a
business focused solution because it's
taking the data that each utility has
and then packaging it or aggregating it
or providing it uh more for for
businesses and so I think it makes sense
that that part is built in a way that's
most economical by a com for-profit
company that can do it efficiently and
and produce just the the data that's
needed by the market followup followup
uh you're saying it could be done more
efficiently but why would anybody do it
at
all so my understanding is that there is
a market for this data that there are
companies who who want to know um usage
in in order for example to make
proposals on projects and things like
that I mean that's the whole reason for
this for this uh project is that there
is a uh a market for it it's just the
question is how much it cost and who
will pay for it thank you thank you Mr
chair representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you m thank you representative Bry um so
I understand that there's a market for
this and that perhaps a startup would be
a good a good place to start for that
but why why do you object to the state
acting as an incentivize to bring that
on if if such a data Hub such a service
would be beneficial to the state as well
and to all rate
paays U thank you for that question
question I I think I don't object to the
state incentivizing it I would object to
um it having unknown cost and then
payers representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman um
representative B you familiar with the
dunsky study on this that uh says that
uh they estimate uh just under a a
mid-case scenario that after 5 years the
total benefit s are about
18.6 or $8.7 million alog together and
after 10 years uh
62.2 million alog together that seems
like a lot of benefit and um a lot more
than the cost of the project I'm not
really sure how that who that benefit is
to is it to the customers the rate
payers themselves or to the businesses
or um it it's to everybody together all
all the utilities the customers the
businesses the um uh third parties
aggregators everybody all
together and I think I think that that
probably combines the the portal that
each utility has and the data Hub and so
my argument is that the the the portals
provided by the utilities is useful and
I think utility each utility can make
the case just as uh New Hampshire Coop
was able to do it on their own um so
that that probably also provides a
utility and that's probably included in
the percentage so how would you split
off what benefit is for the customers
and their utility versus the data
platform itself is there a split there
representative
McGee thank you yeah I'm just realizing
that you know this is the difference
between having been involved with this
for a really long time where all these
questions have been answered and having
somebody come to it new and ask all the
questions again um so uh I just wanted
to um point out on the dunsky study what
we have so far which can't be completed
because we don't have the cost back from
the rfps to actually do a an accurate
quantifiable cost benefit analysis um
they do show a graph and they break down
all the details and I did provide you
guys with a handout on the how the dunky
um benefits break out um but the primary
beneficiaries are
uh residential and Commercial rate
payers so um that's the discussions
around who benefits from this and what
kind of projects would create the value
that we're trying to achieve those those
have been those have been sort
of revolving in this group for a long
time they don't want to just build
something to build it so um so my
question is did you get a chance to look
at the handout that I gave you uh on the
questions
around uh
quantifying how having an entire set of
completed technical requirements
including user stories refined project
scope and standard data model for the
Statewide energy data Hub prior to going
to RFP what kind of an impact that would
have on costs and I think because of
your area of expertise you might be able
to uh comment on that too if you have
all those things defined before you go
forward so well they were just passed
out uh momentarily so I I have not had a
chance to look at them that makes
perfect sense thank you may I follow up
yes follow up okay so um one of the
other things you did mention is that you
thought that it would be best if a
software company was handling um the
project and again the the governance
Council and the folks that intervened on
the project came to that conclusion as
well so I just wanted to let you know
that
um that the way that I mentioned earlier
the we didn't want the utilities to be
building it and then telling us what
they spent because we didn't want to
incur goldplated costs and so the way
it's been managed is that the IT staff
at one of the utilities has taken on The
Lion Share of being the management for
pulling together the RFP but they are
planning to Outsource to a company that
does utility data work to incur the the
lowest possible cost for a set of
requirements that are done so um can you
comment on whether that's the least
expensive way to go we've also asked
that it be run as an agile project to
again keep the cost
low thank you for that so as I gave the
example of the Secretary of State where
they put up an RFP uh that's asking
software companies to or you know uh
businesses to bid and provide both the
solution and then how they will fund the
solution from the fees and and the
entire cycle so in that case um they
just have to list what their
requirements are and then the business
would build the software figure out how
to pay for it and then the the
government at Arms link would manage it
and and endorse it and it's seems like
it would be a good fit for something
like this that's uh mostly targeted at
businesses representative Bernardi has a
question thank you
chairman so you may have just answered
the question but I said this is targeted
businesses because I'm listening to all
this we're going to build out this
big computer software thingy that's
going to provide benefits to us I have
no idea what benefits you're going to
provide me as a as a retail customer of
electricity I I I have no concept of
what you're talking about so what are
these benefits that I'm going to get out
of
this thank you for that question so just
as an example if uh if you are a New
Hampshire co-op member uh when you log
into the portal one of the things it'll
show you is actually your hourly usage
and that might be useful if if your bill
went up for some reason and you don't
know why it went up knowing what time
you know the little the little graph
shoots up right you can think oh maybe I
ran some some specific device or
something so it's useful to kind of
backtrack and figure out where your your
usage went um but New Hampshire co-op
does this without any Statewide data
platform so that that's the point I'm
trying to make thank
you representative Harrington has a
question this should be an easy one so
the co-op has time of use
rates uh they don't have time of use
rates but they do have Ami meter so they
can show your hourly usage followup
followup but without time of use I mean
okay so I know I'm using power at 4
o'clock in the afternoon as compared to
four o'clock in the morning I'm getting
charged the same regardless of where I
use it what's going to push me towards
saying well I won't use it at Peak time
or I'll use it at this time and not some
other time so yeah thank you for that so
the it's not about using in general or
not using it's maybe you have a device
that you used that you weren't aware
that use so much electricity right let's
say you have a dishwasher running or
something and and every time it runs it
spikes up so much and you just didn't
expect it to spike up that much so that
that would be one thing you can learn
data okay representative McGee has
another question thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative bney um so when
you put in this bill were you aware that
we that the project was about to go to
RFP and didn't have a cost an actual
cost yet or that it had uh not secured
the cost benefit analysis that would
allow us to understand uh of what
benefit all these years worth of work
and even volunteer work from people has
uh has brought
together uh I was not aware of those
details but I don't think in my
testimony they were relevant to the
making followup well at this point would
you consider the idea that maybe we
should have that information after all
of this effort before we decide to kill
it like maybe retain the
so representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Bry uh relative to the
startup it it sounds like uh the rfps
being discussed under the current
strategy uh are actually tailor made as
an oper opportunity for a software
startup I mean uh you know even if it
goes forward if if uh uh your bill to
kill it doesn't go forward and uh it is
as it is is there a potential for a
software startup to make a proposal
against the r fees that are going to be
put out yeah thank you for that so I I
think the the issue would be that at
least the example I gave with the
Secretary of State office is that um
you if you're if you want the company to
figure out how to pay for something and
build it at the same time they would
have to kind of Whittle down the
requirements to something that is
buildable for the amount of money they
think they can get for it so so in the
case of the registry database that the
secretary of state is building the the
fees for the usage fees will be will be
determined by the company that's
building the software to figure out you
know to balance the the how many
features they can provide and how much
they have to charge and fees and then
the secretary of state would say okay
that makes sense um so in the case of
the RFP here this is more like just the
comp you know company's going to say hey
this is how much it's going to cost us
to build these requirements without I
think giving them an opportunity maybe
to say you know um to do the cost
benefit of not necessarily cost benefit
but to figure out how much they can
actually get for it right like who are
the customers that are going to pay this
the money to fund this project
thank you Mr chair okay seeing no
further questions I want to thank you
representative for introducing this
legislation and let's hear next from the
Department of energy and ask Dan failen
legislation thank you Representatives
glad to be here this afternoon to talk
about HB
723 uh so I'm not going to rehash too
much ground this bill clearly removes
the requirement for New Hampshire's
utilities to develop a data platform uh
the department is neutral on the bill as
introduced um you've heard this morning
about some of the challenges that the
governance Council process has how it
limits the Department's oversight role
and makes regulation a little bit harder
for us um the process has been
cumbersome and frequently boxes Us in
repealing this requirement would relieve
that pressure and give both the
department and commission uh latitude to
perform their jobs and I'm going to head
on a little bit of a tangent here
because it's something that has come up
that and it sort of illustrates the
difficulties of the governance Council
process um one of the big things we've
dealt with is having confidential
materials and having things that are not
meant for public discussion because they
haven't been approved by the GC they
haven't gone through a full process um
the rejection form that the US doe
provided for the grip Grant is public
information and has been entered into
the Pu docket um so that's available for
everyone to peruse on your own um
however the dunsky cost benefit report
has not been made public and is still a
confidential work document of the
governance Council um so I I'm limited
in what I can respond to on that subject
um one thing that I did want to raise
was that repealing the requirement for
the data platform does not stop the
utilities from going about this project
and developing one on their own um if
the utilities can make a real business
case for this and say who will benefit
and and how much they will benefit for
it uh they're free to make that claim in
front of the Pu and and even undergo
this project with the spills passage um
but they will have to make sure that
they make the benefits clear when they
do that and there's real concern that
they won't be able to you know the the
data platform has to talk to the
utilities backend systems which means
the utilities need to spend Millions on
upgrades they need to then spend more on
the data platform itself um even after
all these Investments there's concern
that the utilities lack metering
capabilities to provide useful data to
the platform itself um so what benefit
then do customers actually see for
something as infrequent as monthly data
uh when higher quality data is held back
by years and possibly hundreds of
millions of dollars for advanced
metering infrastructure uh it's an open
question and something that we are
concerned about as we guide the data
platform through the process um whether
or not this bill moves forward the
department is uh taking its role
seriously in safeguarding rate payers um
and safeguarding rate payers uh
ultimately we're going to ensure that
utility dollars are being spent in a way
that has tangible benefits to rate
payers and I think this bill would
enhance that ability uh thank you for
the opportunity to testify I'm glad to
take
questions could you give us the docket
number uh absolutely that is docket
number
d191
197 thank you
questions for Mr faen representative
Harrington yeah there was a lot of talk
with previous um speakers on cost
benefit who benefits uh in specifically
looking at residential rate payers would
they need a time of use meter in time of
use rates in order to get any benefit
from this information it's an open
question um and I think that uh the the
benefits are in in some cases unclear
and that's something that we saw in the
in the response to the grip application
that you know us doe didn't think that
the benefits necessarily were going to
hash out um and it's something we are in
the department are very concerned about
and want to make sure we would get a
real sense of what the benefits are
before moving forward with these
Investments followup followup yeah I'm
just trying to figure you know if
someone gets this information so they
can go in and look at a plot whatever it
shows when they use electricity if
they're paying the same the electricity
24 seven then first of all there going
to be not much incentive to do it and uh
if they're not going to be able to save
money so I would think if you want to
encourage people to say okay between you
know 4 and 7 o'clock in the in the
winter you're going to be using power
prices are going to be higher so I'm
going to try to cut down on my usage
during that time that would be a benefit
but without that time of use rates I
don't see how you're going to
residential customers going to get
benefit from
it I agree with your
perspective further discussion or
questions representative Corman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr ban um
so it seems like we have a little bit of
a chicken and egg problem here right
there's without Ami meters you can't get
time of use and why would you want time
of use if you don't have an Ami meter
I'm wondering does the department have a
suggestion as to how to break this Log
Jam well it's a slightly different
question than the having to do with the
data platform um Ami rollout plans are
being developed by the the state's
utilities but they are early um I know
unil has has extensive Ami deployment
but the other utilities uh not as much
and have not made public their plans to
time followup so so in other words the
department does not have a suggestion
about that I'm just verifying uh we do
not I don't think I don't have a
position on Ami roll out for the
department at this
time representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um you didn't you didn't
State directly but I'm going to go out
on a limb and say that the doe is
neutral on this
bill um but my question is um again I'm
looking at the fiscal note and you have
put 4.6 million to 7 million for
something that doesn't even exist right
now so I'm going to ask the department
of educa of um energy to please provide
us with documentation that breaks that
down so that we can understand where you
got those numbers because it kind of
feels like you pulled them
um that you came up with them
spontaneously thank
you I will follow up on
that additional questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chair I have so so
many I've been scribbling um the first
one I'd like to ask you is is you
mentioned that you thought that this
bill would go a long way to providing
benefit for customers as part of your
closing statement and what I'm trying to
figure out is how it makes sense for us
to wait five and a half years of of work
and not get a cost benefit analysis
before we make this kind of you know
drastic change so H how can it be
beneficial to people if we don't yet
know what the benefits are we and we're
just about to get
those well I I think the department has
concerns about what those benefits may
be and and
the I I I can't sit here and justify
decisions that were were made in the
past but I I think right now I I look at
taking away the uh need for it and sort
of the legislative need for for the data
platform and restoring the
uh regulatory roles of of traditional
Prudence review um as as something that
would be beneficial from the
Department's
perspective followup and the followup
would be are you familiar with the user
stories for residential customers and
third parties and CPAs and
municipalities and Regulators like the
Pu and how this tool would allow us to
use the data in a way that we could
answer questions around things that
we've been trying to solve for a long
time like grid modernization
and uh even net metering tariffs I'm
familiar with the purported benefits of
the data platform um and the department
is committed to analyzing them in a fome
manner thank you representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair uh thank you
Mr failen
um just to be sure I believe RFP has
been mentioned a bunch of times that
it's request for
proposal and having been involved in
generating requests for proposals myself
my recollection is that uh they always
include a list of requirements and to
representative Harrington's concern what
is going to be in the list of those
requirements for that data platform you
mention that you don't care but uh I
guess if if it's left to the utilities
will they have a consistent set of
requirements that they would work to for
a data plat form so that if I say switch
providers I would be able to see the
same kind of information say time of use
or is it you know better to have uh you
know a state provided list of
capabilities or requirements that mean a
concept of
operations so I'm uncomfortable talking
about the details of the RFP because I'm
not sure what is in isn't available for
public uh discussion on that um so I I
just would say that I I
think there's been an effort within the
governance Council to create
requirements for the data platform that
would result in an effective product I'm
sorry I can't answer your question
better thank you for your answer thank
you Mr
chair further questions representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair
um so we heard from the bill sponsor I'm
sorry we heard from the bill sponsor
that um they he thought it would be good
to privatize this you know get away from
government have a smaller government
priv privatize everything If This Were
privatized what would be the Doe's role
in it would you work with them would you
oversee them would you have anything to
do with this project if it were
privatized um hard to speculate um but I
think I wouldn't I
the word privatized I'm I'm struggling
with a little bit because what I see is
more of traditional utility ownership
and in that case you know the the Pu
overseas Prudence review We At Doe weigh
in during proceedings and uh generally
have the ability to uh have a say
through that process so that's that's
Envision okay okay seeing no further
failen I'm sorry did somebody else need
to speak representative McGee
clarification so I heard this um
expressed earlier in testimony on 681
which you were here for with um Deputy
Commissioner Elms um and you uh talked
about
the the purview of the Pu being removed
by that bill and that bill doesn't seek
to do that what the bill is seeking to
do is say that there it's time to
transition to the governance Council
having the ability to make the sort of
day-to-day decisions on how the project
moves forward without having to go back
be to the Public Utilities Commission
for everything they would have to uh
still go in front of them um when the
RFP is received and and when the um when
the cost benefit analysis comes in
because those are pieces that speak to
the just and reasonable the uh the used
and what's it what is used and useful
right so so the the Public Utilities
Commission would still play its
traditional role um
and the fact is that the the technical
part of the project coming back to the
Pu for approval all the time is more
like micromanagement
because that that's not their that's not
their role and that's not their
expertise it might have made sense
earlier in the project but at this point
in the project I think that's the whole
point of that bill is there a question
here well that's I I I'm I'm just
wondering why you're relaying it as
though there would not be any input um
since you're on the governance
Council uh that that is our
interpretation of of that Bill and that
it would remove that Authority from the
Pu okay seeing no further questions for
Mr failen I want to thank you for giving
your giving us your perspective and next
call on Don Cree of the oper Office of
Consumer
Advocate to tell us what he thinks of
this
bill welcome back thank you Mr chairman
uh I'm still Don Cree I'm still the
consumer Advocate um
I I I uh at this point I I guess I have
too much respect for this committee and
too much affection for those of you who
I've worked with in the past on this uh
committee to really spend much more time
on this subject because it sounds to me
to be candid that minds are pretty well
made up about where the committee is
about this particular project and it's
something that uh I alongside a lot of
other people have invested a great deal
of time and effort on over the last 5
and a half years but it doesn't seem to
enjoy the uh support of a majority of
this committee or the department of
energy and uh that is a condition that I
personally have no choice other than to
decide to uh live with you know choices
get made all the time uh I uh just want
to maybe make three things clear just
because I I think there's some confusion
proliferating uh there's a difference
between
downloading data and sharing data so if
you're a member of the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op uses the green button
download my data standard so if you're
you can go onto the co-op's website
enter your uh member number or account
number and it will give you your data uh
in the form of a spreadsheet that you
can then have for whatever use you want
to make of it uh what the data platform
would do is go One Step Beyond that into
a share my data mode and make it
possible for third parties that you
authorize as the customer to receive
that data and then act on it so that's
that's a pretty big difference and uh
much as I'm sure it's great for the
members of the co-op to be able to
download their data we're talking about
taking another step here with this
Statewide data platform the other uh
point I would make that's related to
that is that there is value in a state
wide data platform so even if each
utility uh goes and does something like
this on its own
independently uh that does have benefits
to each individual customer of each
individual utility But ultimately what
we're trying to facilitate here is the
provision we want to attract businesses
that are going to provide Innovative
services to customers and so if you're a
business whether an instate business or
an out of state business that might be
in a position to do that you are going
to be way more likely to do that if
there is one place that you need to go
to get all the data you need about all
of your uh potential customers that are
going to use your service that is the
fundamental reason for a Statewide data
platform now I I I I guess at the risk
of saying things that some people might
not appreciate I just want to say that
it has been obvious to me since the
get-go as somebody who was part of
docket number 19
1997 uh from the day it was opened by
the Pu that the support of what used to
be the staff of the Pu and what is now
the department of Energy Regulatory
support division is critical to the
success of this project that is why we
made the department of energy a party a
member of the governance Council they
exercise a veto they clearly do not
support this project they have the
authority under the settlement agreement
that the Pu has approved to say no more
the project doesn't work for us we no
longer support it it should not go
forward I am totally perplexed and I say
this in all earnestness why they haven't
done that given what you have heard them
now testify to twice they do not support
this project I I have asked them any
number of times over the last five and a
half years to indicate that to me
because if that is their position that
will also be my position because I do
not want to waste tons and tons of time
and rate payer money on something that
the state's energy policymaking agency
does not support I don't understand why
we are in this situation after all this
time but there we are so my card says
that I oppose the bill which I do but it
appears destined to be reported out of
this committee ought to pass I think
repres resentative McGee's idea of uh
consigning it to either interm study or
retaining the bill excuse me uh is a
good idea uh because I do do think it
makes sense to wait and see what happens
in response to the RFP but
uh it it seems again like mines are made
up and I'm prepared to live with
whatever the uh Collective wisdom of
this committee is so I think that's all
say okay thanks for sharing that with us
thank
we'll get a a different point of view
maybe from um another member of the
uh forgotten the name of the governance
Unitil we heard that Unitil has been
heavily involved in this process so
you see I push the button to turn it on
but I actually turned it off for the
record my name is Alec Oma I'm here
representing
Unitil uh Unitil has no formal position
on this bill uh that said we wanted to
be here today to uh go over and outline
what our role has been on the governance
Council which makes sense we've been
talked about quite a bit throughout this
process um as well as kind of go through
what we see as um important steps many
of which have already been discussed in
terms of the value of the data platform
itself and uh the fact that there is
going to be this additional data that's
going to be made available uh through
the typical process uh before the Pu um
I think the best way to qualify or to
quantify rather our role on the
governance Council has been to be uh
good faith facilitators for what the
governance council is aiming to
accomplish in terms of its RFP uh we
have had members of our it Department
including the head of Our IT department
uh regularly attend governance Council
meetings uh he has provided his insight
and expertise into what we believe would
make a uh quality RFP that's going to
ensure that uh this project is
successful and successful by uni Till's
definition and I've talked about this in
previous times when I've been here
before is a successful project for our
customers is one that ultimately
generates cost benefit for our customers
uh Unitil supports projects that we
believe ultimately lower energy costs
for our customers while also providing
them value uh the core concept of an
energy data platform is that uh we
believe that informed customers make
good decisions with their energy usage
uh a customer that has better
information about how they use their
energy will be able to work with third
parties and make those good decisions on
behalf of their family or their home or
their business uh that's part of what
this whole concept is about being able
to empower our customers with services
that will allow them to make those
decisions and by and large save money on
their energy usage to that end uh some
of the preliminary D some of the
preliminary data that is out there in
regards to this project is promising uh
that's why this project has continued to
move forward our voice in the committee
has been to say this project needs to to
go forward in a manner that ensures that
that cost benefit analysis checks out
and that is the role of the Public
Utilities Commission in this particular
situation they are going to ultimately
review whatever is presented and
determine that this project is in fact
in the public interest of all of our
customers so to that end uh my
suggestion or recommendation would have
been if cost is the primary concern for
this committee than tabling this bill
until that cost benefit analysis is
complete seems wise uh I wanted to share
that perspective and answer any
questions that you might have in regards
to our role in this
project thank you appreciate your
testimony so as a representative of a
utility can you help us understand if
the numbers that are quoted in the
fiscal note of this bill that this could
cost $4.6 to7 million
to get up and running and with 272,000
to 416,000 a year in operating costs are
those numbers reasonable are those
numbers in the ballpark well I recognize
that those numbers were provided by the
department of energy in regards to the
cost of the project and I'm in no
position here to refute those costs in
terms of their overall estimates only I
would add that the governance Council
has not completed its work in terms of
determin what the cost or benefit
analysis should be for example I know
that as part of the Federal grant that
has been discussed here uh presentation
was made to the Public Utilities
Commission in terms of that application
and that document did include estimates
in terms of what the potential savings
would be those savings are in line with
the dunsky report that was talked about
here as well although that presentation
before the Pu is in fact a public
document uh that would suggest there are
Savings in the neighborhood of 10 to 25
million
or there are BS in the first five years
um and again so when I say preliminary
data is promising we have some cost data
and we have some benefit data that's
available that says that yes there will
be a rapid payback and potential savings
for our customers the point I really
want to make in this hearing though is
that promising isn't a promise I believe
that it's important for that project to
that process to complete itself so that
we have clear data that shows a cost
benefit and not cost benefit analysis
before any decision is
made so I didn't hear an answer to my
question as a representative of a
utility do those cost numbers of 4.6 to7
million seem realistic to
you I'm not going to contradict the
department of energy regarding the cost
okay thank you further questions
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman nice to see you again Mr Oma um
my question was around I had heard that
Unitil was considering hiring an intern
to create applications that would make
the
data more easily accessible to people in
terms of what they might try to do with
it do you have any more information
about that that you could share with the
committee in terms of you know it has a
lot to do with adoption right whether
people are going to use the tool know
about the tool um so I'm just wondering
what the thoughts were at Unitil around
that because I had I didn't hear any
details just that you were considering
it I'm not aware of any specific plan
involving a specific intern for this
particular project I know that Unitil
has in the past used interns
specifically through the University of
New Hampshire to work with us on various
projects especially those that tie to
sustainability um when we've seen
opportunities for projects like that we
have uh found interns that have sort of
do that kind of data crunch for us to
maybe potentially find Opportunities I'm
like I said I'm not familiar with any
specific resources that we were going to
bring forward here only just in general
I think it's fair to say that we have
been pretty involved with the governance
Council in trying to make sure that uh
we're any kind of RFP is presenting good
data follow up okay my follow-up
question would be I I don't know about
your involvement I don't know what you
know but I wonder if you you would be
able to illuminate for the committee
many of whom are hearing about this
platform for the very first time today
um the benefits as you see them based on
the different groups in the user stories
in other words could you give some
examples of um of how a consumer would
use this in order to save money maybe in
different
categories
so there are probably folks that could
do a a more eloquent job talking about
what the costs or overall individual
stories in terms of the value are I
think of it in terms of uh information
is power we live in the information age
I personally am an information person
I'm a data person I like getting
information I like when my phone tells
me how many steps I've taken I find that
that's helpful information for me when I
make good decisions about how I live my
life or how I operate my home budget uh
this kind of data is on that same idea
the idea of being able to drill down and
providing standardized data that can
then be used across a variety of uses
and having third-party vendors be able
to have that standardized software that
will then help them make good
comparisons help individual customers
whether they're a business whether
they're a homeowner understand their
energy usage on a more granual level and
then that's going to help them save
money my jeep has a fun tool I like to
use it I run the little thing on it it
says how many miles what my average
mileage is as I'm driving at going along
so I can look at that and as I'm driving
if I'm a little heavy on the gas I
notice that number comes down a little
bit so I'm probably spending a little
more than I want to be at that time
that's how we use information the more
data we have the more we can make good
decisions about our everyday usage this
data platform is about that and I just
want to emphasize at the end of the day
regardless of what happens with this
legislation Unitil will continue to look
for uh solutions for our customers that
will help them get good information
regarding their energy usage so long as
those are done in a cost beneficial way
so that's something that we're committed
to on behalf of our customers uh in any
event in any project including
this representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um this project has been
going on for about five years um can you
tell me um how has it been generally
received to date and has there been an
now I personally am not familiar with
any internal workings within the
governance Council and I don't think it
would be appropriate even if I had that
information to talk about those
particular conversations as they were
occurring within the council followup
followup would you like to speculate on
why there appears to be opposition now
nope thank you very much representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so you mentioned that uh
there's preliminary data that is
promising and you mentioned the dunsky
report is there anything beyond the
dunsky report uh in terms of promising
preliminary data uh only the the only
data that I would cite is um again the
report that was sort of used uh as a uh
comparative tool in terms of looking at
what uh the potential benefits are for
our region as well as uh the numbers
that are provided and again preliminary
is preliminary my primary point that I'm
here to make is that we should wait
until we have real data and then make a
decision at that
time representative Kaplan thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr om uh you
mentioned that you are committed to
ongoing work to provide your customers
with the necessary information to to
benefit them in their in their energy
usage uh so that implies to me that you
agree that maybe this is a tool that
that you know that you would develop on
your own but what I want to ask you is
how would you compare a tool that Unitil
might develop on its own as a result of
this legislation to something that is
like a Statewide you know multiutility
uh data Hub which you know how do those
two things compare well not to be too
literal but a tool that was specific to
Unitil would benefit Unitil customers
specifically whereas a Statewide tool
would benefit I I recognize customers
throughout the entirety of the State uh
ultimately what a Unitil specific tool
might ultimately look like I wouldn't
want to speculate here um only to say
that we would continue to look for what
those Solutions might look like whether
they would be similar to or dramatically
different from I I couldn't say at this
time representative rolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman that he will ask
once yes I will isn't isn't a
major goal of
having a Statewide data platform like
this um to be able to attract to the
state third parties providers of
um help customers of all the utilities
take advantage of the information and
wouldn't you know just one utility a
smaller one Unitil uh do you think you
would attract the same level of third
state just on your own generally
speculation is a world I try to avoid uh
so I I don't think I would go down that
particular Road I can only say that
Unitil is confident that we can find
customers okay see see no further
questions I want to thank you for being
here thank you next we'll call on The
Honorable Clifton Belo from Lebanon
representing Community power cor
Coalition of New Hampshire welcome back
Mr Belo hasn't seen you in a while nice
to see you again good afternoon nice to
be back
um I'm here to uh support what uh Unitil
just just testified to which is a
recommendation that you retain this bill
and allow the RF p uh for uh The Hub to
go forward so that we can actually have
cost uh good cost uh more than estimates
potential contracted cost uh by the end
of the summer um I first got involved
with this uh in the docket in late uh
2019 when the commission opened the
docket to consider uh implementing the
legislation um I was part that was on
behalf of the city of Lebanon it was
before the committee power coalition
existed um and uh was part of the
settlement that was approved less than
2022 and have been a member of the
governance Council since and I just I
just want to say that I think the
governance Council has been uh somewhat
um remarkable uh collaboration between
different stakeholders and the utilities
and because it was designed to work by
consensus um we've had to work through a
lot of differences of opinions and come
to Common Ground um and that was part of
the settlement in the docket as well
which was an agreement uh to design this
to be what was called at the time the
minimum viable product but designed it
to be extensible so some of the use
cases would develop over time um and uh
what I can say is all three of the
investor own utilities that have been
very active in the governance Council uh
I'll bring to the table a lot of it
expertise as well as a particular focus
on uh security of individual customer
data and that's very much built into the
design of the uh proposed platform it's
not a central database it's rather an
API of apis um an API is an application
program interface it's a sort of a
modern way to be able to stream data in
a potentially in a one-way Direction so
that it you know you can get data but
not necessarily get into the database um
so
uh a lot of we we did get sort of
sidetracked if you will with the federal
funding opportunity we only made one
application the first year of the
federal funding uh for grid resilience
um infrastructure CP Grant um uh we only
went as far as is a preliminary proposal
and we were invited by DOA to make a
full proposal because they thought it
had a lot of Merit um as previously
mentioned the Doe's response is
available it's at tab 183 it's not
obvious but if you go to that docket
book tab 183 has that uh the full
content of the doe uh response to the
proposal um just of note there were five
times more proposals than they funded
and they didn't fund any software or
data related even though in their own
comments they recognize the potential
value of this approach um and I I just
wanted to mention a couple of the um a
few of the user cases that this that
this offers um but but I should say you
know we're we're right at the very end
of three years of developing all the
technical specifications for the RFP um
and it's it's I think very well thought
through um and we're expect to file um a
a a report a status report to the Pu
which should um assuming we achieve
consensus on on Wednesday and I might
mention the governance Council has been
meeting for one hour Wednesday
afternoons pretty much consistently for
the past three years with you know
occasionally uh taking time off but not
much as well as sometimes an extra hour
on Fridays for the technical work group
um that uh particular Ally Drew upon the
expertise of the utilities uh but the
result of that is that the RFP is
basically done uh there was a final you
know doe wanted a chance to do a final
review of that uh so we didn't approve
it last week hopefully we will uh
tomorrow or or Wednesday um and uh and
file that at the Pu along with the dunky
report um as along with a dunky market
uh evaluation so that will start to give
you a a window into the cost and
benefits that have been analyzed but the
cost we don't know until we issue the
RFP there's very little incremental work
uh left for the council to do or the
utilities or the Pu or the doe in order
to uh uh for the uh pu to approve uh the
the RFP text as it's uh as it's ready
and for that to be issued and for us to
get actual cost figures I I think our
timeline for that part of what will be
filed uh by the end of this week is an
updated timeline for how that's all
going to get implemented and I I think
the expectations from last week's
conversation is we should be able to
have a completed cost benefit uh study
um by the end of the summer so that if
you retain this bill you can then make
an informed decision uh based on uh much
much more uh information and something
we've been working towards really as the
governance Council for the past three
years um I I can stop there but I if if
if you'd like I can mention three use
cases that might be of
interest shall I do that yes okay well
one um first first of all it is based on
green cuton green button uh connect my
data uh not just U see my data but be
able to share it through an API this is
a National Standard that was developed
to try to have a standardized format for
sharing data um it goes up somewhat
beyond that by allowing certain
agregation of data and one case in point
concerns uh multi-tenant buildings in
order to qualify for New Hampshire's
Energy Efficiency programs or in my case
I'll just give an example I manage a
27,000 foot office building it's got a
30e plus old hva hva system and when we
went to look at replacing our rooftop
units um the the technology is evolved
quite a bit and the engineer said well
we need to look at the whole building
usage uh and for that you you need to
obtain from every tenant their usage for
at least a year so that we can actually
size the new Air Conditioning which
which codes require us to size it based
on uh the the actual design and building
use it took um uh it took the better
part of a year just to get every
tenant's permission to share their data
um but that became essential and what we
could see for instance what we saw from
that is oh um we still got a lot of
fluorescent lighting and we could
convert to LED which we did during the
pandemic um and uh lower that energy use
such that the new equipment we purchased
could be smaller in size to accommodate
the fact that when the building was
designed it had more energy use than it
has today because of of these increased
deficiencies um it's a real problem in
multif family housing because of
individual tenants don't want to share
their data with their landlord and yet
for multif family housing to qualify for
most of the Energy Efficiency programs
they have to have whole building data
one thing this platform would do using
standards that have also been developed
in other states is allow a building
owner to say I don't need individual I
don't need every tenants data but I do
need the aggregate Total Building use
gas if you have natural gas plus
electricity and the standard that was
agreed to in the settlement and that the
Pu approved was that if you've got at
least four tenants and no one of those
tenants uses more than 50% of the total
you know energy of all the tenants then
they could give you the aggregated uh
building usage you don't know how much
is by individual tenant but at least you
know the total building usage and from
there you can make informed decisions
about what kind of Investments would
make sense to better insulate your
multif family family housing or do other
Energy Efficiency measures and to
actually qualify in the program another
related use case is trying to move
Energy Efficiency towards a more
market-based uh process right now most
of the the utility programs mostly use
what's called deem savings and they say
well if you do this or that we estimate
that the savings will be thus and they
get approved B on the basis of deem
savings there's the trend towards pay
for performance which says to the
contractor allows the a shifting of the
responsibility to actually produce
savings to the contractor to say will'll
you'll get compensated but based on the
performance that you estimate these
measures will uh save the customer this
much but we're going to actually track
that and compensate you on performance
not just on an expectation of savings so
those are just a few examples of where
this platform uh can be of of
significant
value well thank you I have a couple of
quick questions for you I believe I
heard one other testifier say that a
customer has to agree to share their
data is that correct it it to share
their individual customer data yes that
would be you know I want to share it
with this a contractor or somebody who
wants to quote me on a solar system uh
You' have to give that individual
permission aggregated data you know
there's different standards for that for
a building owner uh that what I just
described could pull the aggregated data
without individual customer permission
for other uses it's a a minimum of a
hundred customers you know if somebody
wanted aggregated data on a community
for instance they could get the
community's total data um but not not um
individual customer data so there's a ex
with the exception of a building owner
um it's a it's aund a minimum of a
hundred different uh uh uh customers uh
in order to get aggregated
data okay thanks so a follow-up question
would be in order to derive the benefits
aggregation would that require
customers
um I'm not sure well for example we've
heard a lot of talk here about time of
use rates oh right and uh other thing
other benefits that could derive from
knowing more about customer data so I'm
just I'm just wondering if in order to
get people to use and to change their
their habits about when they use energy
does that going to require them to make
modifications in their Lifestyles and is
that a realistic hope or expectation um
I I think in in in this day and age
there's an increasing amount of customer
loads that are flexible uh that don't
necessarily require behavioral changes
that that could be automated for
instance if you've got a hot water
heater or heat pump hot water heater
when that actually gets charged up um
you Pro as long as you got hot water you
don't care that's not a behavioral
change but whether it gets charged up uh
during lowc cost hour versus high cost
hours is is a different question and and
certainly this whole data platform
becomes a lot more useful with interval
data um but they're already across all
the utilities there's a certain amount
of interval data for large customers
that's actually hard to access or stream
um so that's part of this API of apis
where you can potentially stream the
data uh to somebody who's monitoring it
and a huge case in point is the state of
New Hampshire which has thousands
hundreds of accounts across these uh
five different utilities and and in
order to track all that
data from from what I understood when
when we had a representative of the
state on the governance Council much
like the city of Lebanon does we have to
actually manually look at each bill and
enter the usage for each month into a
database to get the total City's energy
usage um and that has is is a
significant burden in cost and from what
I recall about the state's
representative saying is State doesn't
even really try to do that because
there's so many accounts it it would
take several people full-time just to be
entering all the individual data and
this data platform would solve that
problem you'd be able to say State of
New Hampshire I want all the data
bundled together and I want it every
month through this data platform uh for
each facility for each utility territory
and it would just it would just come to
you that way um and then you could look
at whether you're making progress on
your energy
goals representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman see now you're digging into the
fun stuff um so the other thing I'd like
to you to maybe illuminate or discuss is
um the
whether the tool can assist with things
that the state is trying to accomplish
in terms of our docket objectives around
grib
modernization um and uh net metering
tariffs you know I was trying to explain
this morning in the bill that I
testified in that being able to turn the
data into information allows us to
manage and plan and so could you speak a
little bit about that because I think we
should understand that as well
um well I I thought it was interesting I
think in one of the fiscal notes doe
said they couldn't provide an accurate
estimate because they didn't have access
to the data on state energy use um so so
that that I thought well that's that's
that's a case for having the uh the
platform
um we we we have heard in part of the
market survey that dunsky did found that
there are plenty of businesses in the
state that have multiple establishments
if you think about any kind of chain
retailer or whatever um and they they
pretty much all interested in managing
their energy or Contracting it out um
it's a fair amount of effort to compile
that and to compare and and part of the
value of the platform was having highly
consistent data so that if you a
particular data field you knew would
know means the same thing regardless of
which utility it's coming from um so I
think just just broadly speaking it it
it it becomes a very useful planning
tool and the notion that you know you
can't manage what you don't measure um
comes into play here which is energ
energy is a big part of our cost of
living these days and um there are ways
to manage it that can produce savings
for everyone and you know I'm haven't
gotten into that because that's sort of
another story but
uh but but but there are things emerging
Gene that this platform could help
enable and capture for
instance FK has ruled and ISO New
England has filed conforming tariffs to
enable small distributed energy
resources to participate in the iso New
England market and to do that FK and ISO
New England is requiring utilities
whether they like it or not if they're
big enough and in New Hampshire's case
it's only eversource to have to provide
interval metering for those customers
even if it's on top of the metering they
already have and that additional
metering which will be highly granular
they've said it's got to be five minutes
got to be capable of five minutes
because that's how we uh balance uh
generation at 5 Minute intervals prices
these distributed energy resources that
can be aggregated to participate have to
have 5minute interval metering that data
could come through the platform and and
the customer could look towards other
inov Innovative service providers to to
help them you know optimize and manage
the point of all this is if customers to
the extent they have a flexible load are
start to be able to respond to the
prices that generators make you're going
to have better price formation supply
and demand responding to similar prices
and we have an opportunity to shift load
off of peak into the valleys and spread
all those fixed cost cost for capacity
over more kilowatt hours rather than
than fewer if we kep keep getting peier
which has been the trend in New
England yeah which drives the cost down
for everyone okay representative Corman
has a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Belo good to see you yep um
so earlier this morning I asked a
question on the uh timing of the RFP and
I didn't get a really concrete answer
but you said that you think that we'd
actually have bids by the end of the
summer yes so um where where does that
come from um that comes from the fact
that the uh everybody as of last week
everybody essentially but doe had signed
off on the RFP text and I believe they
were going to try to work through any
questions they had u in the past few
days um so we're we're expecting to file
it we have a deadline of this Friday to
file a status update the hope is that we
are filing the actual proposed RFP uh
that then needs the commission's
approval for us to go ahead and issue it
um and I think we have a a timetable I
don't have it in front of me but uh
we're hoping they're able to turn that
around relatively quickly um because
it's you know the document has had a lot
of work go to it it's a consensus
document um and um if that's the case
the RFP will get issued by the utilities
not not the state it's important to
realize this is
uh would be owned by the utilities which
are private Enterprises not not by the
state um uh the state would not be the
one doe would not be the one Contracting
for this it would be the utilities um
and the time frame that is uh would
allow us to get uh responses back uh uh
by the end of the summer before the end
of the summer follow up so you said that
the utilities would issue the RFP would
that be one RFP issued by the joint
utilities or separate rfps one one
Unitil has um volunteered to to be the
um sort of sponsoring agent in different
things eversource has been the
sponsoring agent it's it's it's been
reviewed by all three utilities
procurement departments to make sure
complies and and they you know
there there's really no cost for us to
get the responses back um uh nothing has
to be expended there would be some
Review Time involved at the end but my
guess would be if this bill's retained
um certainly before any Contracting
occurred uh the expectation I'm I would
expect would be to report to the
committee that this back to this
committee uh uh to get some indication
on whether there's support to move it
ahead or
not representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr
chair sorry um earlier you mentioned
that this platform looks at deemed
savings no no just that Energy
Efficiency programs the New Hampshire
saves programs mostly rely on what's
called deem savings it's like okay if we
replace this fluorescent lamp with the
LED lamp that should save this much
energy
um followup I guess yeah followup um
does that include modeled and measured
savings as well okay okay thank you well
and there there is some effort to verify
even deem savings it's called em andv
valuation measurement verification um
but at the same time there's a trend and
it's been implemented in in California
for instance uh and and we have an
arrangement where we could use one of
these Flex Flex Market uh platforms uh
that would have contractors assuming
responsibility to actually uh produce
the performance um such that their
incentive is stronger if their set of
measures actually performs uh as as
promised thank
you representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
Mr Belo uh you mentioned supporting this
bill just to be clear uh Bill discussed
this morning had to do with uh uh the
establishment of a Statewide online
energy data platform the one being
discussed right now is House Bill
723 which discusses uh uh basically
getting repealing the you multi-use data
enry platform uh do I understand that
you are in favor of the bill that was
discussed this morning regarding that
data platform and oppose the bill House
Bill
723 correct that's correct
thank you representative Kaplan thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Belo for
coming in I think we have a good picture
of all the work that's gone into the
data Hub platform up to this point to
get us to this point and you you paint a
very Vivid picture of all the
opportunities that exist if we choose to
not kill this data platform um I'm
wondering what I seem to be missing
maybe other people in this room also
shared that lack is is a sense of what
would be what would we kill like what
what are the m opportunities if we pass
this bill can you paint a picture of
that
um well I think obviously the RFP would
never go out um um I mean I think the Pu
would just put the whole thing on hold
until they saw what the Senate did um so
we and I guess it question is does it
become law or not
um uh so I think th this this effort
obviously would go by the wayside you
know I I have a high degree confidence
that Unitil will move ahead uh I think
it's next year that they're planning to
start their next Generation Um
state-of-the-art Ami deployment and uh
from what I understand that their intent
is to provide green button connect my
data a functionality uh uh not just
download my data but able to share it
with other parties um uh but so but I
don't think the other two utilities are
are particularly uh moving ahead with
that um at this time um so I think I
think what we would miss is sort of
knowing what it cost to do this Hub and
um what we would s we would never really
have a handle on whether the
uh the benefits were commensurate with
the cost or out you know clearly
outweighed the cost or whether it was
dubious and I think the committee if you
hold on to the bill could make a
decision whether they think that the
cost benefit is strong enough to allow
this to move forward or whether they're
dubious of it and don't think the
benefit analysis really supports the
cost and deems decides to pull the plug
on the policy um I just think it would
be a better decision with the
information thank you very much seeing
no more questions I want to bring bring
on the last uh person who wants to
testify on this bill and that's Sam
Evans do have a
question well we have 1 hour 45 minutes
to discuss two other bills this
afternoon so I'd like to move on if you
don't
mind is this really crucial to our
understanding of this bill we've been
talking about it today now for almost
three hours I believe it is all right go
ahead please be quick this this is
something that I know that that Mr Belo
can answer that others could not which
is how would the costing for this
project um be done because I know I had
asked you I was trying to do some back
of the envelope
calculations um if we could understand
how many customers it would be across
because I know it's Gas and Electric and
also um what what uh how many years of
amortization generally would a project
like this be spread over for those
customers um if if we were to go forward
with it because that that makes the math
work right and if we can't so we can't
figure
out what it would cost people on their
bills um
my understanding is that this type of
software would be typically advertised
over five years um and I don't have
those customer counts in front of me uh
but in general Ro the formula is to
share it across the five utilities based
on customer
counts thank you okay now we can move on
to Sam Evans Brown to get his
perspective on this legislation and he
has the last word on this
bill welcome back Sam thank you uh for
the record Sam Evans Brown executive
director of clean energy New Hampshire
um we also have a member member uh
position on the governance Council
although we hire a data expert to fill
that role so uh I don't uh I while I
attend the meetings I'm not a voting
member and I'm not the real expert and
if you wanted him I could get him here
so uh real granular questions about uh
the API of API should be retained for
him but going last means that I have not
a ton to say that that hasn't been said
already but I'll just hit on a few
things uh first is the question of the
cost benefit analysis the draft cost
benefit analysis was submitted to the
new Hampshire pu it is available online
I have a citation in the footnote of my
written testimony that I'll hand out if
folks want to read that over it does in
fact find that there's there were be
between 21 uh you know at the midc case
$21 million in benefits over the first
five years of the after the creation of
the of the data platform um and
potentially 65 million over the first 10
years after the creational platform
we've hit on uh really where those
benefits would come from and it really
is allowing these uh competitive third
Market service providers to offer more
services to New Hampshire residents in
order to reduce their energy spending um
and actually think representative brz's
story about being on the New Hampshire
Electric coops service is a perfect
example because the New Hampshire
Electric cop does have time of use rates
all of the New Hampshire utilities have
time of use rates but customers are
often unaware of this because the
utilities aren't necessarily
aggressively marketing those rates and
so customers don't know that they exist
don't know that they could save money by
using them and so creating a a platform
that would allow third-party service
providers to get connected to that data
would create a market for those third
party service providers to come in
Market the fact that they can save you
money if only you were to connect them
with their with your data so that they
could run an analysis showing when you
could uh you know when you could shift
those those uh those uses to those
flexible uses to the low low Peak
periods you know just looking at the the
co-ops uh rate it's 11 cents per
kilowatt hour off peak 21 cents on Peak
um so anything that you can shift to
that 11 Cent period um is obviously
going to be a lot of savings to you as a
as a as a you know electricity user and
I would just say that this generally is
in line with the state's stated position
to use market-based mechanisms to try to
produce savings for customers um but you
can't have a functioning Market without
access to good data um which is
generally the problem that we find in
the in the utility space which is that
data is hard to find um customers don't
really understand their bill uh and
don't understand the bill drivers um and
I'll just flag from the grid
modernization docket that made the
recommendation to create to create this
platform that it said you know sharing
data with the market in order to harness
competition and drive ADV Drive Advanced
Energy technology deployment I think
that's really what we're talking about
here is how we harness Market forces
that don't have to come from you know
utility programs that that uh ultimately
have to be paid for by by the rate
payers so uh that's really all I have to
say happy to take
questions
questions representative McGee thank you
Mr chair and uh thank you Mr Evans Brown
for being with us again so when you
started talking about Market competition
it made me think about um other states
that have already deployed this do you
have any information you can share with
us about any other states and their
markets and how having access to their
data has worked out because I know we're
not alone right we're not the first yeah
so so actually Texas was the first state
to Implement a Statewide utility data
platform Texas is uh renowned for having
the sort of freest energy markets um and
have gone the farthest in terms of
energy deregulation but but again uh
without access to data it's hard for
markets to operate and so I think that's
why data access was a fundamental
principle that um that led to that
adoption New York is the next that was
that is taking that step um and and this
all came from our attempt to get
together the the grip application the
grid resilience and Innovation
Partnerships application and I'll just
note you know the the document again
which is available online that was the
response to the group application there
it says quite a lot of things uh there's
weaknesses and strengths in the
application uh if you read just the
strengths it sounds really great if you
read just the weaknesses uh sounds less
great um but but the the the fact that
this was going to be a New England wide
uh uh uh sort of API that that we were
pushing for the whole region to adopt
was uh was seen as the greatest strength
because then service providers would
have a single platform and they would be
able to work across all of the New
England states and would have an ease of
ease of use that would that would make
their life easier would would lower
marketing costs would lower their
operational costs and allow them to
offer their services to to rate payers
at lower cost I don't know if I answered
your question
there representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um I don't know if you're
going to know the answer to this
question but you're the last speaker so
you get it um
do you know if ISO New England has any
kind of a position on data platforms
like this I I do not believe they do but
um but that speculation I I I think
generally speaking ISO New England uh
really refrains from getting involved in
state jurisdictional questions and
anything on the distribution grid is
really state state jurisdictional thank
you okay thank you very much we'll wrap
up the uh public hearing on Senate Bill
723 with that and representative Vice
chair Thomas will open a public hearing
on repres on House Bill 7
okay I open a public hearing for H B 672
FN and it is to allow for the off-grid
electricity providers in New Hampshire
Prime sponsor representative chairman
Michael Vose the floor is
yours thank you Vice chair Thomas and
good afternoon again to members of the
committee for the record Michael Vose
representing Rockingham District 5 the
town of eeping and I'm pleased to offer
today enabling legislation House
Bill
672 which in the language of the title
of the
bill allows for off-grid electricity
providers in New Hampshire but I think a
better way to describe it is described
in a handout I provided to all of
you
called what I call this uh legislation
as being
the foundation for customer regulated
energy or
electricity I apologize for the fact
that some of the slides in this
presentation are a little bit hard to
read because it was given to me in color
but I don't have a color printer so I
printed it in black and white but most
of the most of the U information in the
readable when I say this is enabling
legislation
basically what this legislation does is
it allows someone to build an energy
facility energy production facility
doesn't matter what type of facility it
is natural gas nuclear Hydro solar
doesn't matter what type the facility is
the idea is that the facility is
islanded and not connected to the
grid and then the facility can sell its
buyer so the classic example of how this
might be used
is an AI Data
Center built somewhere on a huge
Warehouse building full of computers
that uses lots of
electricity someone could build a energy
gener
facility
nearby and sell all their energy to that
Center and the details of the contract
between the producer of the electricity
and the buyer of the electricity would
be up to
them and there would be no regulation
necessary by the state with the possible
exception of citing regulation RSA 162 H
depending on the size of the facility if
it was less than 30 megawatt it might
sighting processing or proceeding if it
would now the first question you're
going to ask is well if this energy
production facility is islanded and not
connected from the grid to the grid How
does the energy get from the producer to
the consumer and the question the answer
to that question is it'll be up to the
producer and the customer to decide that
question obviously they have to build
some kind of a connection between the
producer and the and the customer a
distribution line of their
own
so that's an innovation problem that
somebody else will have to solve but we
shouldn't get in the way of that so
that's why introducing this legislation
to allow the concept of an off-grid
electricity provider offgrid electricity
provider to
that even though there may be
significant problems to making this work
we can at least give the market the
opportunity to solve those problems
and let this situation work it could be
extremely
Innovative it could be really important
to certain parts of New Hampshire too if
someone was willing to build a data
center uh in a section of the state that
populated it could provide jobs it could
could provide uh other benefits economic
benefits to that area and an energy
provider NE nearby would be necessary to
make the whole thing
work now I'm sure that utilities will
tell you that um there are some possible
issues here for example if I have an AI
D Data Center and I'm connected to a
local producer what do I use for
backup and if that backup is the grid
then there has to be some way to make
sure that there is no connection between
the off-grid electricity provider and
the grid itself even if it's in the um
the building of a user of a user of
electricity there has to be a way to
separate the two so that they never uh
contaminate each
other as it as it might be considered
so this
legislation is enabling but it doesn't
solve all the problems that might arise
if someone decided to take advantage of
this
opportunity but at the same time those
are relatively easy problems to solve
and I might even be open to some
Amendment legislation here to uh make
sure that utilities are completely 100%
protected um by this islanded off-grid
electricity
provider so with that basic introduction
I'd be happy to answer any questions and
um explore this idea more fully with the
committee thank you uh r% of those I
have a question to start off with is my
understanding then this enabling
legislation would basically allow for
things such as a smallscale nuclear
reactor to power
one AI data
facility side by side maybe or it would
just all it would allow that correct
absolutely and and I'll do my follow on
which
is
so what kind of like what prevents it
now from from happening um if we're
keeping it uh I'm assuming
this what I should be saying is does
this mean that there the the five think
what limit is still there or does it do
away with
that it imposes No Limit
whatsoever so there what keeps it from
happening now then so the only thing
that keeps this from happening today is
that the expectation of most energy
producers is is is that they would
connect to the grid and Supply their
energy to the
grid this idea says no you don't have to
do that and if you don't do that you're
not subject to
regulation government regulation so
that's the the sort of
twist on the idea of producing energy
that this legislation would
enable representative
Harrington yeah thank you and thank for
taking my question um I'm not sure if
you uh know the answer to this but you
know there is someone that's planning on
doing this with the data center now and
it's the restarting of 3M Island plant
the nuclear plant and I believe they
were going to be using regular
transmission to to get the the um
electricity from the output of the plant
to the data center and FK blocked the
original proposal so I'm I'm what I'm
reading in your bill is that that's not
what you're talking about here it would
be a completely autonomous system where
the power goes directly from the
generator to the user and there's no
interchange or connection into the
regional transmission Grid or even the
distribution system for that matter is
that correct that is correct that is the
definition of off-grid electricity
provider it
means an entity person private company
etc etc that engages in any combination
of generating
transmitting Distributing or selling
electricity at retail to customers not
connected to any existing regulated
representative
Reynolds thank you Mr Vice
chairman are there any um is the impetus
for your legislation uh a request or
the um existence of any real world
private parties that have expressed
interest in this type of thing or a
precedent in another state does this
happen happening somewhere else that
you're seeing New Hampshire could you
know follow in the footsteps capitalize
or is is it is the impetus to sort of
theoretical at this point well that
thank you for those three questions that
was not three questions and the answer
to your your your query your combination
of questions is this is happening today
in
Texas um a group of people in Texas
actually conceived of this idea and have
been uh pushing it in Texas and have
implemented legislation in Texas to
enable this um activity it's Texas is
obviously a much bigger State than New
Hampshire and
the requirement for data centers down
there is pretty substantial so it's it's
much more meaningful down there than it
is up here but when I saw this idea I
thought well why can't we do this here
here there's no reason why we can't do
this here and it could drive some
significant new economic activity for
the State of New Hampshire so I thought
well let's give this a try let's uh
enable this type of
activity maybe nobody will will do it
but then again right here uh just south
of Us in Manchester is the advanced
regenerative medicine Institute
and they are attempting
to make manufacture living human tissue
which is going to require massive
amounts of of
computer uh data to figure out how to
manufacture living human
tissue I don't know what their data
center PL Center plans look like right
now but I can Envision that they might
be building a data significant sized
data center at some point and finding a
way to power that data center is going
to going to be important to them right
now I don't know that our utilities
could uh Supply the energy that such a a
data center might require so having
legislation like this in place could
give them a
solution and the legislation itself
doesn't solve all the Innovation
problems that would occur if such a
project were to get off the ground but
the people putting together the project
themselves would find innovative ways
I'm sure to solve the problems to make
it work if they were given the
opportunity thank you represent of
Stiller thank you Mr
chairman and thank you chairman Vose for
taking my question uh this legislation
would it it's effectively enabling
legislation so it wouldn't preclude new
forms of technology say for super
capacitors as an energy
transmission mechanism which would
require R&D Etc but this is entirely
enabling there's not there's nothing
that would preclude new technologies
coming in to satisfy transmission needs
Etc No in fact I would argue the
opposite is the case that this enabling
legislation would encourage the
development of new technologies to
enable
transmission if you're going to build an
an energy production facility here and
there's a data center here you got to
figure out how to get the energy there
and who knows what new ideas might
evolve to solve that problem indeed
thank
you representative McGee thank you Mr
Vice chair and thank you Mr chairman for
taking my question so I was looking at
the handout that you provided us and the
contrast between Lepa and
CR and this is makes it really clear um
it's on like the second to last page um
and I wanted to focus on the no
regulatory barriers which I'm sure we
would all love I'm sure the utilities
would love that as well but um my
question is how we could allow
individuals who will basically have no
regulatory
oversight um how we can uh
eliminate regulations that are designed
to provide safety so for example with
electricity uh and Distribution Systems
they have to abide by certain standards
and quality of cable and whatever um and
for nuclear I believe those are all
under the national nuclear Regulatory
Commission um nuclear power isn't
something individuals or private
companies are going to be deploying
without I I think Federal oversight just
because again of Public Safety So when
you say no regulatory barriers how can
we just eliminate those we can say we
don't want them but how can we eliminate
them if people are going to be operating
in a space that has required those
safety regulations from everyone else
who
participates so
the legislation would only eliminate
state regulatory barriers so for example
in the case of nuclear uh the NRC would
still
have regulations that that you know any
provider would have to have to adhere to
to build a small nuclear reactor for
example they'd have to have uh NRC
approval but there would be no state
regulatory barriers that they would they
would face as I said if it was over 30
megawatt they might have to go before
the site evaluation committee which
would envir you know impose
environmental reviews on the facility
but no other state regulation like pu
regulation would be
required followup I think currently the
bill doesn't have that clause in it and
you said you were amendable to
perhaps uh you know listing that except
for the site evaluation committee is
that in here because I yes yes that's on
line 14 okay so it is in here okay thank
you
representative
Swanson uh thank you Mr Vice chair uh Mr
chair uh this is kind of exciting
because I think I might have been an off
thee grid energy provider when I was
living in Hudson I had set up a uh and I
hope it would didn't violate any
regulations because I had a generator in
the backyard and I had an is your
question forthcoming please it's it's
coming just a little bit of background
here so if
I in here you describe how it's uh would
be
sold and uh I provided it to myself
through a switching mechanism so it
wasn't con connected to the grid unless
I threw the switches so that I could you
know run
my uh well pump or from the generator or
or get the electricity from the grid but
uh uh apart from that I think I met all
of the uh stipulations here other than
selling it to myself obviously I didn't
do it in the language here can a
company uh actually pay for its own
generation system and doesn't need to
worry about complying with any
regulations if it just installs it
itself as opposed to hiring a commercial
provider to come in and provide them as
Island if it can isolate itself
completely from the grid so that it's
completely off grid then no it wouldn't
regulation thank you whether you sold it
yourselves
representative Thomas please thank you
um
thank you for presenting this bill um
let's talk a little bit about logistics
would an off-grid provider be required
to sign a certificate of deregulation
comma be overseen by pu comma and how
would any members and I'm putting that
in quotations be contacted regarding
continued
deregulation so the answer to all those
questions is or the first two questions
anyway is no and the answer to the third
question is it's not applicable
followup followup um you also mentioned
large data centers um that would be off
grid until it needed to go on grid so it
would be hooked up to both um so my my
you can qualify that but my question is
isn't that having your cake and eating
it
too no the the definition of off-grid
electricity provider is that you are
off- grid period all the time you never
go on grid you are always off grid you
are islanded from the grid that is the
please uh youve had your followup let's
let's go on to representative Bernard
for right
now thank you Mr chair uh
so in discussion of this you've you've
spoken about the provider uh and having
a customer like a big data center but it
this legislation doesn't limit it to
that kind of an entity one could have a
gated community of 35 very well-healed
individuals that want to create their
own little off-scale ey Island and and
do this or or something like that or or
a business that wants to ensure
Integrity of the supply and rely on it
totally on their own is that possible
absolutely some people have com compared
this
islanded um off-grid electricity
provider to a
microgrid a micro grid could be
considered similar except that a
microgrid is only temporarily or
sometimes Off the Grid whereas one of
Grid okay we're beginning to ask similar
questions so I'll ask ask representative
Corman if he has a new one thank you I
do and thank you chairman Vose you
always ask us to ask questions about the
bill this is a question about the bill
uh the bill uh adds a section to RSA 374
it adds 374 colon
3C and then on lines 12 and 13 it says
an offgrid electricity provided that
begins operations onor after the
effective date of this section shall be
exempt from RSA
374 so the the bill is
exempting something from itself is that
right that does sound kind of
contradictory doesn't it but essentially
what that says is that RSA 374 is the
section of law that governs governs
utilities and uh govern governs the the
delivery of electrical energy and so
what this Bill is saying is that if
you're an offgrid electricity provider
uh the effective date of this
legislation then that means that you are
no longer subject
to the provisions of RSA 374 so you're
not subject to a utility regulation
that's the whole P purpose of the bill
is
to to make these off-grid electricity
regulation represent Kaplan thank you Mr
Vice chair and thank you chairman Vose
uh for bringing this bill I I am all in
favor of Market innovation in in the
energy sector I think it's a a powerful
force for good uh however I am a little
bit concerned about just total
deregulation of these uh of these new
micro grids or whatever you want to call
them the islanded uh grids so my
question is don't you agree you know did
do you foresee or maybe maybe you can
look at the example of Texas and maybe
you can find the answer there but AR
aren't there environmental regulations
such as air emissions water usage Etc
that these facilities ought to be
subject to outside of their electricity
regulation yes I I agree with that
that's why this bill unlock line 14 says
that they are or lines 13 and 14 says
that an offgrid electricity provider
shall remain subject to all other
applicable applicable laws and
regulations including RSA 162
H so the only regulations they're exempt
from are RSA
374 thank
you okay I'll take question from
representative Haring
and then from representative
PL I'll make it very quick I think what
you're saying then is that this bill
does takes care of economic regulation
of the generator is no longer applicable
but all the other things like air
permits and water discharge permits and
anything that comes out of uh those
different departments would still apply
exactly represent PL do you wave it off
I'll take your question as being the
last one before the good representative
is over
shellshocked with
questions I I'm I'm afraid chairman Bose
is not going to be Shell Shocked by my
question and I hope not the my question
is whether or not um I understand the
the intent of the bill um whether or not
our micro grid law would already allow
for most of this except for the extra
regulatory
piece I don't think so because a micro
grid as I said earlier can sometimes be
connected to the grid it'll only be
disconnected under certain conditions
whereas these uh islands are always not
connected to the grid by
definition it's a dedicated power
circuit
yes okay see no other questions thank
you representative for an excellent
testimony and and answer session uh next
I'll call up Mr David shulock from the
New Hampshire doe Mr shock welcome
yours good afternoon for the record my
name is David shulock I'm the general
counsel at the New Hampshire Department
of energy and uh I'd like to start by
saying that we are neutral on this bill
but immediately after that I'd like to
compliment representative Vose uh for
being Innovative and for bringing this
bill to you right
um we we didn't fully understand the
intent of the bill before uh
representative V's uh testified uh so
I'd like to just give a a couple brief
observations if the intent is to fully
deregulate everything related to these
um these systems the bill language does
not go far enough to do that
okay these systems would be Public
Utilities under RSA
362 right and and there are many other
statutes besides 374 that regulate
public utility actions right so you'd
have questions of do they contribute to
the renewable energy fund do they
contribute to the
SBC right um and probably a myriad other
questions uh buried within there um I'd
also like to observe that uh there is no
Geographic limitation to these systems
they could stretch from one end of the
state to the other taking distribution
lines transmission lines through all of
our neighborhoods and there is no safety
regulation
whatsoever right uh RSA 3741 is the
fundamental basis for the dep Department
of energies uh safety regulation
accident reporting is in that uh section
as is the Dig Safe program uh these
systems could bury
conduit uh pretty much anywhere but
never have to mark out where it's buried
before people dig now they probably they
would probably want to so that people
didn't disrupt their services but they
wouldn't be required to right so um the
other thing that I'd like to note is
that I
think much of what representative o
would like to accomplish with this bill
you could probably accomplish under
present
law uh without too much difficulty um
and so what I would suggest um is that
uh represent representative o if you'd
like to work with our office of energy
Innovation to figure out ways to solve
all of those problems we'd be more than
happy to do that with you
uh I I don't know a time frame for when
we'd be able to help you uh we have uh
two people in that office one has been
out uh for on an extended leave and the
other position is tied up in the uh
hiring freeze but more than happy to
work with you on on figuring something
out Vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so by virtue of your
testimony do you mean that if a company
and we do have a company here in the
state that does manufacture equipment
for this if someone if somebody wanted
to come in tomorrow and say I want to
put in a smallscale nuclear reactor in
coaz County because uh I'm in
partnership with a data center that's
that's being built there they would have
no restrictions or obstacles whatsoever
to do that provided they follow the
exact same uh rsas that are on here now
I'm a little uncomfortable
Fielding hypotheticals given how one
small fact might change the scenario uh
and but our our office would be more
than willing to to work on those
scenarios with folks follow up follow up
um yes um well the entire bill is
hypothetical really uh to allow new
innovation so I guess I was just asking
because you commented that there was uh
that it could be done under under prison
law I just wanted to find out if if if
if that type of scenario would would
come under prison law and and all you'd
have to do is make sure they file all
all of the usual permits and everything
well there are different aspects to it
so for instance a a nuclear facility
would have to go you you said Nuclear So
nuclear would have to go through Federal
sighting um some State sighting right
um but they can be Exempted from public
utility regulation a number of ways
there's a provision in the statute that
says when a generation facility is
considered a regulated public utility
and when it's not um and then um they
could there's there's no reason why they
couldn't sell all of their output put to
a competitive supplier competitive
suppliers are lightly regulated and
those competitive suppliers could sell
to
anybody and and even be connected you
grd additional questions for Mr
shoock now I'm sorry certain things
would be regulated though like the
interconnection right we we regulate the
side okay see no further questions thank
you very much next up is Donald C from
uh thank you Mr chairman I'm still
Donald Cree I'm still the consumer
Advocate we represent the interests of
residential utility customers uh much as
Mr shulu did I'm really here just to
compliment the chairman for his openness
to Innovation uh I think the same folks
who produced that uh set of slides that
the chairman distributed were kind
enough to talk with me a little bit
about the idea that they came up with
which is based on what happens down in
Texas and I was sufficiently intrigued
by what they were proposing to suggest
that this bill is uh worth perfecting
and possibly even adopting I uh I agree
with uh Mr shulock that there are some
improvements to the bill that could be
made so that it really does achieve what
I understand the objectives of the bill
to be uh we do have we do get I do get a
little worried about telling big
consumers of electricity that they don't
have to contribute to utility the
recovery of utility fixed costs and
system benefits charges and other things
that all other customers would continue
to contribute to but offsetting those
concerns is the idea that maybe one of
these projects could actually happen in
New Hampshire and uh that might have
tremendous benefits for the economy and
the people of the state so I think it
deserves your favorable consideration
and uh beyond that I don't have too much
to add I just wanted to uh add an a note
of ascent to the
discourse well thank you I appreciate
that questions representative McGee has
one or no Wendy Thomas I think yes all I
can see is an arm um I know it's the
black arm um thank you for being here um
so you talked about there might be one
case of this happening in New Hampshire
you know it it it could happen um what
if there are many many these off-grid
providers set up what could be the
impact to New Hampshire's bottom line
income uh if there were lots of these
projects yeah and they're deregulated I
mean does that impact our our budget
bottom line or uh does that take money
away from the state if if all of these
off-grid providers are deregulated like
this I'm not sure what you mean by your
question do you mean it would have
adverse consequences for the utility
consumers who were still connected to
the grid and still taking service from
the utilities it
could uh but you know to some degree uh
this is an acknowledgement that the the
the assumption that electricity is
always a natural monopoly for all
purposes uh we we see that breaking down
around the edges and uh you know there
is no
valid public policy reason why if you
want to use that smallscale nuclear
reactor example why you couldn't build
such a reactor in an economically
disadvantaged part of the State uh
attach it to a data center or some other
Enterprise like a medical Innovation
facility like the one I heard repres uh
chairman Vose mention and you know that
generates economic benefits that would
create jobs and economic activity for
the that would benefit all of us here in
New Hampshire so I think it's an
you okay thank you no more questions
final word on this bill goes to Michael
eversource Welcome Back good to see you
thank you uh Michael lado representing
eversource energy appreciate the comment
uh the opportunity to come before you
today um as the doe noted we we do think
that uh many parts of this are allowed
under the current statutes however uh we
do appreciate that the bill I think
tries to add some specificity and and
detail around uh this this issue which
is I think largely uh folks can make
assumptions based upon current statute
uh about what they can and can't do on
their their own property um I do think
uh it would be helpful to have uh maybe
three clarifications in the bill uh and
I think various questions have touched
on this um the first is uh it would be
very helpful from the utility standpoint
to make it clear that there uh is no
interconnection uh allowed between the
utility and um distribution or
transmission system uh and this offgrid
uh provider whether that's primary or
backup uh and the backup is is where you
know we're sort of focusing our our
attention um we have had instances in
other jurisdictions where um a large
data center looked a site behind a large
um generator they said well there's no
connection here there's no connection
here uh and there was and when pointed
out they said well that's just for
backup you know we don't really you know
intend to use that um when we design the
electric uh distribution and
transmission system we have to to design
it for basically every eventuality and
so if the generator uh stop producing
and they shifted to backup power if it's
not properly designed and interconnected
into the the distribution or
transmission system it could cause
overloading and so just a little
clarification there and I believe it's
in keeping with what I heard was the
sponsor intent that this is uh separated
from uh from the electric and and
transmission system sorry distribution
and transmission system um also just
picking up on a comment that the
department of energy made about um and
others uh about sort of exempting from
being a a public utility exempting from
certain safety statutes uh and
requirements um I think a a helpful
clarification would be uh that the uh
off-grid energy provider uh cannot
construct
infrastructure uh either in or across
any federal state or local
roadways um we think that this would be
would be a helpful um provision to
clarify and avoid any uh safety concerns
uh just two examples that i' I'd give or
hypotheticals one is um again we don't
know what standard
uh that they would this you know
non-regulated entity would be
constructing to uh what remote control
that they would have over their system
uh if there was some sort of failure um
or you know obviously weather events
would impact uh this entity just like it
does with uh a public utility um we
certainly have had situations where we
have wire energized wires down on a on a
motor vehicle uh with individuals in
that vehicle that's just sort of an
example of an emergency situation where
the first responder needs to know
exactly who to call in order to um
address that situation and de energize
those lines so um keeping this uh
contained within you know a piece of
private property or or multiple pieces
of private property that don't cross uh
roadways I think would be a helpful
safety uh clarification uh and then
finally uh the the third recommendation
is um if the uh entity does upon their
own accord decide they would like to
interconnect to um the public
utility uh that they need to pay uh any
cost associated with that
interconnection as I uh previously
discussed we have to do quite a bit of
engineering to make sure there isn't
overloading uh all customers uh if we
don't charge the interconnecting entity
would be required to pay for that and I
don't think uh that would be in keeping
with with uh the you know long held
views of the State of New Hampshire to
to subsidize these
interconnections uh again appreciate the
the intent appreciate the the desire to
add some specificity around um these
off-grid uh providers and I'd be happy
can okay thank you questions
representative
Gorman thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr lato always good to see you um I'm
curious about the the provis Proviso
that uh wires not uh cross roadways I'm
thinking about the wildfires in
California and uh that those were caused
by electrical infrastructure any
particular reason why it should just be
restricted to not Crossing
roadways so when when we uh looked at
this bill what we believed the intention
of it was uh was to make it clear C that
if you own a piece of property um what
you do on that property is is in some
ways your business from a I'll say
public utility standpoint obviously uh
as as the sponsor made very clear there
are you know environmental and and
citing statutes that still apply and so
our our view was you know if someone
today wanted to put some source of
generation in the middle of their
property and build an industrial park
around that and have agreements with
their tenants um that everybody sort of
agreed to then that is what this bill's
uh trying to to enable and so uh again I
think once you start Crossing roadways
you start uh interconnecting with uh you
know other Parcels uh that Cross Public
rights of way then there is a a public
safety issue and the standards that you
build to and the emergency response come
in follow
up again I'm just thinking you know if
there were a fire that happened because
of this infrastructure that spreads it's
it's no longer just necessarily on on
that private property so wouldn't that
be a public safety concern I I it's a
fair
statement okay other questions Vice
chair Thomas thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I'm curious
the interconnection however far or short
it is would it be treated as
transmission or
distribution is the the question the
interconnection to the utility well from
the energy source to The Entity that is
using that energy source sure I
I it dep well so there would have to be
a couple of steps in the process
depending on the size of the generator
there's no limitation on size if it was
um you know below a certain voltage uh
and please don't ask me what that
voltage might be uh you know it would
have to then it would leave the
generation facility get stepped down at
a substation and then distributed
through through distribution voltages
because that's what the the customer
typically would use but there are
scenarios where we have very large
industrial customers that take
transmission voltages so there's just a
lot of of possibilities in there on how
the voltage of the the generator and the
needs of whatever entity is
interconnecting to it apologize not
being able to give you a specific answer
but there's just a lot of variables in
there representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr lado for taking my
question so so um my question is also
about the
um I guess the safety of the electricity
itself of
um the I I feel like the bill I
understand what it's trying to do um but
I feel like it doesn't have enough
definition
around limits Pilots um or parameters
which makes it seem a little bit like
the Wild Wild West um I would I would
like you to comment on being an
electricity provider I know that there's
a a complicated system of phasing
electricity on and off the system and um
I'm just wondering if you could comment
on any thoughts you might have around
the safety of
having large unlimited uh electricity
providers who are unregulated so that
nobody has a sense of whether or not the
energy that they're producing and moving
is is actually done in a safe
way uh I understand and appreciate the
question I think you know ever source is
looking at this from our perspective and
this is uh an entity uh provider of
electricity that we are not
interconnected to and so um the safety
the how they manage uh their system
would be separate and distinct uh from
us and that would be a you know a public
policy consideration of the State of New
Hampshire how much um you know I I would
argue that the regulations in statute
exist for a reason uh we have to comply
with with all of them uh and there's
certainly I believe a a balance that uh
you as policy makers need to strike
between trying to remove regulation to
advance Innovation and keep a certain
amount of Regulation to for the reasons
they were put into place to begin
with representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and I I do
have another question about the first
thing you listed about the U about not
allowing an interconnection between the
uh the off grid provider and the
grid is it possible to have a customer
facility that is connected to both but
at separate times or is it just not even
possible that the fact fact that there's
a connection to one and a connection to
the other inherently means that the uh
off-grid provider actually is somehow
connected to the
grid uh
so if if it is interconnected to our
system if it there is a customer on this
system that is also interconnected to
the um distribution or transmission
system they are interconnected and and I
think
uh as previously stated if they need to
rely on the utility for either primary
or Backup
Service the um the electric utility
needs to design its system to safely
accommodate that and there can be cost
depending on where this is obviously
cited uh there can be cost associated
with that um with that uh
interconnection as well as obviously the
ongoing cost of of providing electricity
service that all customers uh pay into
and enjoy today follow up follow up yeah
I I I don't know if I understood the
answer I mean so if if there's an
offgrid connection to a customer and an
on grid connection to the
customer are those two necessarily
somehow connected and and
therefore you have a real problem with
that or is it possible to actually
physically disconnect so so that the
off- grid connection is not actually
connected to the
grid I guess my response is if it is
interconnected at any point in time to
our system it is connected to our
system we need to design the system to
accommodate that
interconnection okay I have no more pink
cards on this I want to thank you for
your testimony and we will close the
public hearing on 672 and open a public
hearing on how Bill 690 and I'll call on
representative James Summers to
legislation thank you representative
let's
see thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for the for my fellow committee members
to uh uh listen to me uh introduce this
bill it's HB 690
FN um this bill is actually basically a
conglomerate of well A reproduction of a
bill that's come across this committee
many times over the last decade in
different forms um it's been whether
it's been a asking for a commission or a
committee this is actually looking into
different way we're um now that we have
as of beginning of last term Department
of energy within the within the
government we uh this is actually
looking at the department of energy to
actually investigate and to finally to
allow us to get the answers that we've
been looking for for a decade basically
in regards to ISO New England now part
one of this bill is predominantly the
questions and if you notice they both go
both ways what's the benefits to be on
it what's the benefits to separate
what's the benefits of of cost how much
would it cost if we left how what um
what are the benefits of leaving is New
England what are the costs associated
with leaving is New England would there
be reliability impacts if we left would
there be cost ass assciated with that
that could be avoided by um New
Hampshire where we to leave and what are
the benefits of par participating in I
New England so it's looking at both
sides doing a um basically a cost
benefit analysis a com direct comparison
to and it's instead of a commission or
committee being developed it's having
the department of energy actually look
at this and investigate it um while and
where this kind of came up earlier this
term as well is we were talking about
the while New Hampshire as we mentioned
by Doe earlier when we doing the uh
evaluations and and discussions with
them when we first started the committee
this term uh when they brought up that
while New Hampshire generates almost uh
double the power it uses 177% compared
to 10% load uh how are we affected by um
these policies how can that Surplus be
used would that benefit us if we were to
separate how are affected by the
policies and procedures of the other
states within ISO New England how when
they make a policy change how are we
affected or if we not affected um how is
the um and it was brought up actually um
another final note is that the uh this
past Friday within the emergency
technology caucus bipartisan group uh we
gathered together talk about different
Technologies um in relationship to uh
energy producers energy generation and
the State Surplus and we looked at the
opportunities discussed utilizing the
surplus of power and how it would
benefit us if we were to separate and
how they if it would cost us more to be
on our own or if we get the benefit from
ISO New England to where it does benefit
us already and so um that's pretty much
in a nutshell what the uh the bill
actually is I'll take any
questions questions for for the
representative representative
reels thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you representative
Summers for taking my question
um when you say things like New
Hampshire
generates 17% of the energy that goes to
ISO New England and that we have a state
Surplus do you understand that the
generator
the electric generators that may be
located in the state of New Hampshire
are private entities
and
that that the energy they produce is not
belong
to the state of New
Hampshire yes yes I understand that
correctly it is um what I'm basically
utilizing there is that the the
generators that currently even because
they do sell contracts to other states I
understand that right now for example
CBR I believe has a contract with
Connecticut still so much their power to
it um but what I'm utilizing is how much
power by Divi by um sites within the
state how much they generate and then
how much is utilized by the state itself
is
really right thank
you representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair and thank you for uh
introduc ucing this bill um my attention
is drawn to line four and five lines
four and five where it says that the
withdrawal from ISO New England and
other strategies to insulate rate payers
from costs associated with New England's
Environmental Policy can you please
define New England's environmental
policy and what are you talking about
here what I was trying to get it there
was the the differences of States so I
know I bar briefly engage that but
whether or not that um it's basically
asking getting to and asking the
question of the policies in other states
the other five states within New England
they if their policy change actually
directly or indirectly affect the rates
that we pay in New
Hampshire and if it's their
environmental policies that they
Implement if they affect the rates and
directly or
indirectly followup followup so is that
actually a a one of the questions that
the that the
committee would look at is that one of
should it be under the the the questions
that you've identified instead of up up
there I I believe it is um I'm looking
for
here lines four and five
yeah it's a generalization of what the
investigation is going to cover um but
it's covered again I believe I thought
um uh
looking
[Music]
for I thought there was a question
asking about that but maybe
not
um oh um sorry thank you um would there
be cost associated with IC New England
that could be avoided even if New
Hampshire were to leave uh line I even
okay further
questions representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
Summers for taking my question so my
question is around um whether you have
any information on how much Reliance we
have on the flow of energy from the
transmission lines that are part of the
grid if if you have any understanding of
um you
know how much rely on that energy going
through transmission lines that run
through the state of New Hampshire
because if we pull out we I guess we
wouldn't be able to use them anymore I
mean I don't even understand how it
would work I guess that's the question
um my personally I I do not and that's
why um I believe this investigation
would actually bring out a lot of the
questions that we actually been looking
for and to basically explain that so
that we would know the limitations of
could we do this or could we
not thank you additional
questions
seeing representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman thank you representative
Summers um in terms of um duplicative
functions on line 16 uh I didn't get to
go see the iso control room but uh
wouldn't we definitely need our own
control
room that's very possible that we would
and that was but again that was the uh
again that's just it's basically asking
the question if we would what would be
the size and scale of that how would it
be compared to ISO what would the cost
of that be compared to what we um what
the costs are now being a member of
iso rep representative Swanson thank you
Mr chair uh thank you Mr Summers or
representative Summers sorry uh
regarding the original decis there must
have was there an original decision to
at some point in time several years
ago honestly I don't I don't know the
answer I'm assuming yes but I I don't
know that answer I'd have
to follow up so assuming there was
originally a decision that was made some
considerations had to have been or
Alternatives had to be
considered uh presumably if we're going
to investigate pulling out wouldn't we
look at why we got in in the first
place we could definitely look at that
however what the uh and it's possible
that when they went into ISO New England
it was that New England was seen as a a
conglomerate where they had the same
beliefs of what they were for what they
were against and as policies have
changed over the years that quite
possible that states differ in what they
believe is important what should be
covered and what shouldn't be thank you
thank you representative for introducing
this legislation we have three other
folks that would like to comment on it
before we have to be kicked out of the
room so Donald C you're up next to give
us your perspective on this legislation
thank you uh thank you Mr chairman with
your leave I have a just a little piece
of artwork to distribute to members of
the
committee uh let me just say again that
I'm Donald Cree the consumer Advocate we
represent the interests of residential
utility customers I am testifying
in favor of House Bill 690 and I would
like to commend the sponsor for
suggesting an inquiry of this uh nature
and the questions that uh some or many
of you have been asking so far uh go
directly to why I think this kind of
Investigation would be useful what I've
given you and the reason I characterize
it as artwork is that if you look at
these are two slides that I got from
neol which is the uh stakeholder
advisory body to ISO New England and the
one that's marked uh page 64 uh reminds
me of Picasso's gika which is why I
called it artwork and and the point I'm
making is that ISO New England a and
neol and all of the uh Arrangements that
underly and enable are so Byzantine and
complicated that few if any of us
understand them well enough to know
whether our state is well served by
perpetuating these Arrangements they did
not all come into existence all at once
they are the sum total of a series of
events some fortunate some unfortunate
that probably began either with the
invention of electricity or more
approximately with the 1965 New York
blackout which led to the creation of
Nee poool as a tight power pool and so
you've seen this accretion of
Arrangements I think they all are in
place to favor the Legacy interests
which is to say the big investor owned
company ianes that built our uh Legacy
generators and our Legacy transmission
system so I think it would be really
useful to conduct a thorough
investigation into the question of
whether New Hampshire truly is well
served by perpetuating something this
Byzantine and complicated if I have a
legal question say if I want to research
how how has the Pu treated a particular
question over the years since the Pu was
started in about 1911 I actually can do
that I have a great legal database at my
disposal I can search every pu order
ever written and I can generally come up
with an answer if I want to know like
what's really going on like how did we
get here with all of this and what does
it all really mean I I can't do the same
thing it's that complicated nobody
really understands it now let me just be
clear I would be very surprised if at
the end of an investigation like this uh
with the results coming back to you what
this state would decide is absolutely we
must withdraw from ISO New England that
would require us to Island our grid from
our neighbors and I think we would find
pretty quickly that that is Impractical
but that doesn't mean this inquiry
wouldn't be worthwhile to determine
whether there are improvements that we
could make to the arrangements whereby
we trade back uh power back and forth
and interconnect back and forth with all
of our neighbors both fellow States and
with the Canadian provinces that are
also interconnected with us so excuse me
I think the Bill's a good idea and I
want to thank representative Summers for
introducing it I think all of his
questions and concerns are valid and
deserve answers that's all I have to say
I think okay well thank you questions
bill well looks like nobody has one so
next we'll bring up um Chris Elms and
Dan failen from the Department of energy
to give us their take on this
legislation
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee again for the record uh Chris
Elms Deputy Commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of energy joined by
Dan faen Regional policy director um the
Department's neutral on House Bill 690
but if we are directed to pursue the
investigation we would do so happily uh
I'd like to Echo a lot of what the
consumer Advocate said um and and just
say we are in a really interesting time
in the New England uh energy policy
sphere
uh a lot happening with our evolving
resource mix with making the right
Investments whether we can build stuff
uh even the attitude to how we should
approach uh electricity procurement in
the first place um as we've mentioned
State Statute directs the the department
of energy to advocate for New
Hampshire's policy goals and against
proposed policies of other states that
would shift cost to New
Hampshire um provided that those
policies are not in in our policy
portfolio um you know we've talked a lot
about how New Hampshire is unique in the
region we undeniably have different
goals uh every other state has
aggressive decarbonization goals well
our Focus has been on cost and
affordability um we have been really
Market driven for long time but as we've
seen uh both in in uh recent years and
uh in bills proposed uh in this
committee and in the Senate whether it's
uh expanding power purchase agreements
or um exploring energy storage uh you
know credits utility ownership of
nuclear I think there is a lot of
questions about whether or not the the
regulatory structure that we have today
is working as designed um as
representative Summers mentioned we uh
consume about 10% of New Hampshire's
load while we within state borders
generate about 177% so the question I
think that this bill is asking is a good
one uh is this working for New Hampshire
is being part of the New England grid
right for New Hampshire um you know
we've heard time and time again about
how difficult withdrawal would be from a
cost technical legal regulatory
practical perspective uh undoubtedly
those would be really really big
difficulties but what are they can we
put numbers on them can we do that
analysis figure out what's uh
surmountable what's insurmountable and
what lessons can we learn um I have no
doubt there will be value in
investigating it again the folks at ISO
New England I think they do a a really
good job really smart folks who have a
hard hard job the question is whether or
not the regional approach makes sense
for us um these questions are great uh
to the extent that there are costs
associated with the investigation such
as for specialized Consultants which
might be necessary we do think our
current statutes uh give us authority to
to pay for those under RSA 36537 so that
should be uh that should be fine um
happy to take
questions Vice chair Thomas has a
question for for you thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question do if this bill have passed
does this bill give you the authority to
petition the utilities in state and
inquire about how they would react to
this bill in particular the eversource
command center which is second to none
after ISO New England's Command Center I
I think my general council's back there
and he could talk about the legal
authorities I would imagine that that
the utilities and a whole bunch of
stakeholders would be really interested
in providing their perspective to us
whether it's uh the utilization of
infrastructure or opportunities for
further success uh drawbacks they might
see so I don't think it would be a
table representative Kaplan thank you Mr
chair and uh thank you gentlemen once
again um I I wanted to ask the the
sponsor of this bill this question but I
didn't get the chance so maybe you can
answer it for me usually when there's a
study committee there is some vision of
some sort of outcome or Target or goal
or just some kind of picture of where it
might go can you provide that for us
because otherwise this just an academic
exercise it's a really really great
question thank you very much
representative and you know it's it's
one of those things that especially as
the Department's been created and that
investigative Authority that we have has
been explored and I think you know the
this committee and and and uh the Senate
have directed us to undergo a number of
Investigations
um I think it's it's an exciting
development with the creation of the
Department of energy uh but to take it
back to this specific
investigation I I can't tell you that
the answer what the answer is going to
be I do think that there are going to be
tremendous you know uh hurdles right to
to actually leaving the iso and cutting
the wires so to speak but again I think
what we'd be looking for are are those
things potentially worth it are the
benefits going to be uh
outweigh the costs associated with it
what are those other lessons we can
learn what improvements even if they're
incremental can we find to ensure that
that New Hampshire knows that we're
going to be able to stand for our policy
agenda uh in the in the coming decades
uh because you know the the question of
how much it's going to cost is is a very
important question how much is it going
to cost us to not do something is
something we we don't necessarily know
the answer to but this might help us
find out followup followup it so so my
question is you don't really have an
overall vision of where this might lead
which leads me to conclude this is more
like a bluff in a in a poker hand
they're using this as a negotiating chip
of some sort is that correct or not uh I
I wouldn't necessarily agree with that
but I'll let Dan yeah so I think one of
the one of the opportunities here is not
just it's it's not just that it's a
simple black white we we come out with a
report with a big stamp that says yes we
should leave we're we're looking I think
here and with these questions we could
see a lot of ways to improve current
processes so not only uh is it's
something as drastic as leaving on the
table but what are the opportunities
within the current system that we can
better take advantage of and that would
inform our Behavior going
forward you representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um so we've heard
from testimony that we would be looking
at Regional transmission we'd be looking
at Market outcomes we'd be looking at
the control room um somebody would have
to figure out the size and the shape of
that you guys don't have that kind of
background or or or uh knowledge so
you'd obviously have to hire a ton of
Consultants my concern and again um
there is no fiscal note attached to this
at all um and what is up with the
Department of energy fiscal notes are
not provided on so many bills I mean we
cannot go forward on this until we know
what the price is representative I I
appreciate the question because that
would be concerning there there is a
fiscal note on the bill it's been sent
to OS I printed this off this morning I
I'm looking at the fiscal note right
here uh that's my fault it was handed to
me earlier today and I forgot to pass it
now you need a followup or no I don't
followup all right representative McGee
please uh make it brief because we have
Miss Connors who wants to testify and we
have to be out of here by five o'clock
yes thank you I'm aware of the time um I
I heard you say um if you were looking
at this in terms of New Hampshire's
policy agenda and I and I'm afraid I'm
not sure what you mean by referring to
that even though I work in this all the
time because I would be concerned about
reliability and resilience um which I
think is a benefit of being part of the
grid so I'm just curious what do you
mean by New Hampshire's policy agenda
and can you speak to it in terms of um
reliability and whether that's part of
it sure and so under RSA 374 f8 I don't
I didn't bring the actual text of the
statute but you know when you look at
the other New England states who are
making Investments and making policy
decisions based on statutory
decarbonization goals and carbon
emissions reduction goals or clean
energy procurement goals those are all
things that are inconsistent with the
laws of the State of New Hampshire we
don't have those goals and so to the
extent that those costs or cost of those
policies would have to be born by New
Hampshire rap payers we are instructed
to Advocate against
those the reliability piece
followup well I had asked it in the
original question
relative to reliability so that's what
I'm I'm asking it okay so you're all set
then answering it sure so reliability is
is a big piece of of the puzzle uh with
from New Hampshire's from the Department
of Energy's perspective um reliability
leaste cost electricity are the priority
of the department and uh we would be
assessing whether or not ISO New England
goals okay let's give the last word to
Miss Molly Connor is representing the
New England power gener ass generators
Connors thank you members of the
committee I am very sensitive to how
you're probably feeling regarding time
right now so I will try to be concise
and direct while also hopefully being
helpful um for the record I'm Molly
Connors I'm with the New England power
generators Association um to remind you
we represent the non-utility owned power
plants in the region so that's about
27,000 megaw across uh New England the
vast majority of the power plants in New
England are members of our organization
um specifically to uh New Hampshire we
have about
4,300 megawatts of generating capacity
um about 40% of that is carbon free or
renewable and our Members Own um by
owning and operating those plants they
employ more than 750 people um paying
countless millions in taxes across the
state um for the bot the bottom line is
for our members um there and we think
for the entire region but specifically
New Hampshire here uh New Hampshire
benefits greatly from being part of a
regional grid that is handling the and
that is handling the dispatch the
planning and the financing related to
electricity infrastructure and the Serv
the services that come from that um for
us there is no need for a study I can
tell you right now that if New Hampshire
does this study um they will learn that
there will be a significant amount of
work and cost from an engineering point
of view a legal point of view and a
financial point of view if New Hampshire
tries to become its own system operator
there would also be the need to expand
significantly the role of state
government due to increased legal
obligations these costs would be
extraordinary to do it on a go- it alone
basis um because New Ham because NEPA
represents the power plants in
particular I will focus only on the
market aspect of this in my testimony
which again I not to be quick um I think
it's important I should also say I
understand that it can be frustrating
for each state in a regional grid to
have to navigate one another's um
politics and their policies I've seen
that firsthand because I do work across
the region I understand that um
diplomacy and working as a state um with
other states is very hard it's a story
as old as the country I think um in
terms of The Federalist Papers and the
Constitution um but I want to remind
everyone that um the reason that we went
to an independent system operator in a
regional grid was for enhanced
reliability and to and to um really look
at cost overruns that were being um that
were really out of control in terms of
at least power generating facilities
since the introduction of the
independently run markets there have
been more than 10,000 megawatts of new
power plants built in New England
without any rapair subsidies um and so I
I have to emphasize that New Hampshire
has long been avoid of markets in this
region and strong supporters of
competition the New Hampshire policy
according to the energy strategy is that
government intervention in wholesale
markets especially with regards to
electricity should be narrow limited and
time limited um when you do a study that
says we're looking to just completely
leave the regional markets which is what
this bill accomplishes you are sending a
a message to people who have put
billions of dollars of their private
Capital into the into this region and
saying even New Hampshire doesn't
believe in markets now I'm happy to
answer any questions but also want to
reiterate that I know firsthand the
frustration that the states all feel in
having to deal with each other in a
regional a regional construct thank
you Vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um my question is
predicated on the fact that this bill is
only asking the doe to do an
investigation it is not a study
committee it is not a commission or
anything of that nature so my question
would be should they do an investigation
would you be able to participate in the
investigation and provide them with uh
information that they would be asking
I'm smiling um representative because
the answer is of course we would but I
also there is a quote in my family where
we say um stress is when you say yes but
your mind is screaming no I know that
the question um I know that this work
this will be a lot of work and of course
we are totally committed to helping you
guys navigate any questions that you
want I would also remind the committee
that the there have been two other
states that have significantly
investigated this in 2008 the state of
Maine which at the time was very upset
about transmission costs and cost really
cost allocation of transmission costs
did an extensive study um and I will say
they were motivated to leave they wanted
to leave and their ultimate answer was
it is not cost effective the state of
Connecticut as recently as I want to say
2018 um started this process they they
claimed that they were subsidizing the
rest of the region and they were
committed to not doing that anymore they
did an extensive study I remember this
firsthand because I was working at ISO
New England at the time and the iso
complied with all sorts of information
requests it's a tremendous amount of
work and Connecticut ultimately decided
that they were also going looking at
taking on significant work and
significant expense uh at no better um
at no at no better cost for that for
their state I think they all have been
realizing that as frustrating as it can
be to have to work with other states
that are not always on the same page as
one another the it's more effective to
work within the system that we have than
it is to walk away from it so to the
answer yeah I'll we'll help you with
anything representative Wendy Tomas
thank you Mr chair um you may not know
the answer to this but again you're the
last speaker so you get it um who do you
know who oversees ISO New England and
who keeps tabs on them is are they the
top dog or is there somebody above them
um we all keep an eye on isoo England
and I will um they would probably be the
first to say that we at NEPA are one of
their um top Watchdogs um ISO New
England is ultimately a utility it is a
private company that is utility it is
regulated by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission in accordance with
standards set by nerk and npcc and there
are private contracts that govern all of
those relationships that they have with
generators with States and with
transmission operators and so it's it's
not as simple as do we leave the iso um
as Mr Cree was saying there are a lot of
um very complicated transactions that
have led up to this
point thank you you need a followup uh
sorry I I was just saying thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Miss Connors I think
we'll see you again first thing bright
and early tomorrow morning I can't wait
thanks sir okay we'll see you then take
care here all right with that we'll
close the public hearing on House Bill
690 FN and we will compl conclude our
work for today we begin again tomorrow
morning at 9:00 a.m. with uh a public
hearing on a bill to exempt generation
utilities from the utility property tax